foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
today more than ever when the world
comes together to create a better
tomorrow it's going to be magic oh
[Music]
magic
[Music]
with celebration with your safety From
Here There and Everywhere for six
Hollows day and night join the making of
a new world starting October 1st
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this is day one of the fide World Chess
Championship chess.com's coverage is
brought to you by coinbase and
chess.com's coverage starts right now
oh
one two one two
yeah yeah chess.com in the house come on
uh Harry Mack in the house come on yeah
turn your volume up right now y'all we
bout to make this happen love ah come on
my name is Harry Mack I had to hop on
camera and spit welcome to the feed day
World Championship under 35 years that's
craziness been going down since 1886
match format with 14 games many queens
won't be captured the kids will be slain
check out the way I'm a revel in the
Rhymes this is sure to be a true battle
of the mind just so it don't remain a
mystery I'll take a moment to walk you
through the history I said we gotta show
love to the Masters 27 years strong
that's Emmanuel Alaska this next name
here is the honor said it's an end game
master Jose Copa Blanca can't forget
Alexander alicon hey yo it's technique
man just my style of rhyme why is that
well he's a master of the tag and I'm
the master because it's disaster over
trash but when he died who's gonna be
the next leader feed they came with the
three years features Soviet Reign for 21
foreign
I'm getting loose with the style that
was the past let me take it to the now
coming off top with the clever words
time to introduce the first competitor
if you don't know this is the reminder
the end game magician Norwegian grinder
Triple Crown win to go hard for him of
course I'm talking about make this
Carlson Izzy the goat the greatest son
highest score ever 28 81 can anybody
test the crown well I guess so I mean if
anyone could do it then it's nepho cause
he's never been the one to be give it up
beyond the time to see the ill Russian
the one that's causing the concussion
people pay attention from the moment
that he's touching the First Pawn making
the move this Dynamic intuitive the way
he's doing it yeah gonna be an exciting
challenge nepo bout to get the game in
Balance going down 2021 in Dubai
chess.com peace
[Music]
[Music]
and we are live and boy are we ready
chat rooms are buzzing across across the
world it's time for chess to break the
internet once again this is the fide
World Chess Championship the 2021
theater World Chess Championship what
better way to start than with a Harry
Mack Rap Attack perhaps the only way to
follow it up is to intro my two co-hosts
for the next few weeks on the end here
we have the man who you cannot spell
chess without you know him you love him
he is Robert Hess Robert you happy to be
here uh yeah you know I have Fabiano by
my sides yeah pretty happy about that
but in all seriousness it's a great
events the World Chess Championship I'm
pumped speaking of which here's the man
who they're all waiting for we're all
news at this point this is Fabiano
caruana number one in the United States
of America the last Challenger to Magnus
Carlson's thrown in 2018 perhaps the man
most qualified to commentate on what
we're gonna see on the board for the
next few weeks Fabiano we're pumped to
have you and how are you doing thanks
Danny it's great to be be here I'm super
excited to be commentating on what's
sure to be an exciting game and world
championship match yeah I I can't wait
to get into it we're going to spend the
next part of uh this half an hour as we
lead up before the moves are are finally
made on the board previewing things
we're gonna we're gonna give you our
predicted results we're gonna talk about
the different angles coming into the
match today so don't go anywhere this is
the place to be uh and on that note
let's remind everybody what what are we
in store for here the feed a World
Championship uh aptly named this year uh
after the organizing the organizing uh
party feeding but the World Chess
Championship itself has been around for
135 years it's one of the oldest uh
organized events in the in in the world
uh it is for the top prize in chess the
winner of the World Chess Championship
is the world chess champion there have
been 16 they defined their era and
Magnus Carlson is the era that we are
currently living in will that still be
the case in three weeks we're gonna find
out uh and what about the the format
itself in regards to what we're going to
see on the board I'm going to let my man
Hess remind everybody of what they're in
store for here yeah we have just two
players competing for the world
championship title it's one on one 14
games of classical chess the first
player to seven F points wins the world
champion title if it's tied 7-7 we go to
tie breaks the time control they start
with two hours per side and they have to
make 40 moves after 40 moves have been
made they get an additional hour on the
clock for the next 20 moves and after
move 60 they get an additional 15
minutes for the rest of the game with a
30 second increment so if they get in
time trouble the position is complicated
they can build time back up so they can
think through the position and of course
the prize fund the players are competing
for quite a lot of money here it is 2
million euros not bad payday 60 to the
winner 40 the loser unless it goes to
tie breaks in which case 55 to the
winner and 45 to the runner-up not not a
bet not a bad payday at all exactly and
of course the schedule to remind you of
where you need to be uh every every
single day to tune into our coverage of
course this is day one November 26th if
you were wondering tomorrow November
27th is day two on Sunday we have round
three and then a break day before round
four comes back on the 30th that's going
to continue to be the schedule they go
three days on Monday is always off and
then Thursday is off so if you're kind
of just organizing your life around the
world Chess Championship now you know
exactly how to do that a real quick
shout out to the Ambiance here our uh
our awesome Studio we've worked super
hard to put this together thank you to
our sponsor House of Staunton bringing
this bringing this beautiful board to us
you can use the command Staunton in the
chat for more information and to get 10
off and uh and you should consider doing
that looking for a holiday gift okay
well
um it's time for us to get into get into
some of the angles right this is what we
say we're going to do we said we're
going to preview this thing so let's do
it so Bobby
I want to start with you one of the
biggest talking points over the last
couple days was an interview that Magnus
Carlson gave in Norwegian he talked
about a number of things but one of the
topics that came up were comments that
he made that he thought that you and or
dingley Wren would have been tougher
Challengers for him this time around and
that he was not too unhappy to see on
sitting across from him how first of all
compliments you we're glad you're here
right we would rather you be here I know
you'd rather be in Dubai but we're happy
he's here right the chat is happy you're
here but other besides the compliments
aside to you how much of that do you
actually think Magnus really thinks that
he does have a worse head-to-head record
against against John how much of that
you think is gamesmanship and your
thoughts on the psychology that Magnus
is is taking with with those comments
well I think with Magnus there's always
a great deal of psychology because he
places a lot of emphasis on that yeah
and correctly so I think psychology is
super important especially at the top
levels
but it also in general he does tend to
speak the truth he does tell his
feelings I don't think that he's
entirely saying something that that's
fictional and the important thing to
remember is that he has been preparing
for yawn mentally yeah at least for a
long time because Jan was the one of the
leaders when the candidates was
postponed in 2020 so he had to mentally
prepare that it's not 100 sure that Jan
would win yeah but he's certainly a
clearer Contender at that point yeah and
the candidates ended uh already quite a
while ago so
I think that that was those were his
honest emotions when it ended that uh
Jan is not the most difficult opponent
in the world for him yep but now I think
there is also uh some element of trying
to get inside his opponent's head
because we know he likes to do that yeah
it's interesting you say that Yawn is
not the most difficult opponent in the
world for him because Robert on to you I
mean do we need to remind the world that
Yan has a plus record against every
world champion he's ever faced and he
has a plus record against Magnus so talk
a little bit about what you what do you
think that that's relevant here if not
why and and Magnus making comments about
John not necessarily being the toughest
Challenger despite his losing record
yeah well historically I don't think it
has mattered that much that a challenger
has had a winning record against the
world champion the world Champion's a
clean slate it's a whole new event it's
a match format so you don't have the
round robin where maybe if someone needs
a win Someone's Not In Contention so
it's a different vibe altogether yeah
that said I do think Edgar Fabiano here
that Magnus plays that psychology game
and he wants to get Beyond's head if I
if he's sitting right beside me if
Magnus had not won the previous decisive
game I think Magnus will be talking even
more because he only has one victory in
the head-to-head as you mentioned and it
was the last decisive game so he wants
that to continue he wants to get under
John's skin and Jan will see if he bites
well let's bring up our head-to-head
record here and show everybody uh
exactly what we're talking about you
mentioned the last decisive Victory it's
okay so the last classical game they had
that was decisive was in zagra of 2019
where Magnus did indeed beat yon so fair
point right and obviously the last time
they actually played was in Norway which
was Armageddon but still Magnus took
that as well right I want to come back
to one point you just made because I
think it's interesting that this is the
longest Magnus has ever had to think
about who he's going to play right or at
least
I guess he didn't know for sure right we
had of course the the covid the covid-19
pandemic that cut the candidates in half
and he already knew who maybe maybe his
challenges would be so do you think that
helps Magnus do you think that hurts a
little bit to think more and more about
about the fact that he didn't have a
winning record against John and what are
your thoughts on on the time the world
champion has had to put into this I
don't think it hurts him uh I think it
was more stressful for the people
involved in the candidates to to have
that and and Jan of course even though
he had the great emotions of winning the
candidates he still had to deal with the
stress of that
um but I I think that Magnus having that
extra Insight in the in the year break
that we had between two Kansas halves
um is some sort of advantage in terms of
thinking about his potential opponent
yeah it wasn't of course 100 that Jan
would would win after the first half but
for example we knew that uh ding lyron
didn't have a very good chance right
because he was in a minor score seven
rounds in yeah so there were there was
some information there which is most
likely held to Magnus yeah okay well
amazing amazing stuff already great
insights from Fabiano and on that note
we're gonna announce for the first time
that we have something super special
coming your way more opportunities to
get insights for Fabiano for 10 lucky
fans we will be debuting our new feature
classroom on December 13th uh still in
still in beta right now it's a tool that
will be connecting coaches and students
forever more on the interwebs we can't
wait for everyone to get their hands on
it and the first person to get his hands
on it and give 10 lucky people a chance
for a private group lesson I will be
there with Fabiano all you have to do is
solve at least one video Lesson in his
new video series that's on chess.com
tweet or or share on Instagram proof of
it with the hashtag learned with Bobby
all you got to do again take a lesson
get better take a screenshot use the
hashtag you will be entered to win and
10 people are going to get a lesson with
Fabiano on December 13th I absolutely
cannot wait for that all right when we
come back we are going to have well look
at that we have we have Jan sitting at
the board right there just doing his
he's a little early huh a little little
early early bird gets the worm as they
say right maybe he's still not sure what
he's going to play on move one but we'll
we'll come back to that when we come
back as well Jonathan corbla will be
bringing us a trivia question every day
uh Jonathan corbla is an amazing a bit
of a renaissance man for chess uh he's
been on Jeopardy if you didn't know that
that now you know Jonathan corbla uh is
the voice of chess.com's new documentary
coming your way chess a reflection of us
and every day he will be bringing us a
rather difficult trivia question I
looked at today's I don't know the
answer I don't know the answer this this
is these are going to be fun and tough
so make sure that you play along with
that all you got to do is uh tweet your
answer with hashtag FWC trivia and you
will be entered to win every day someone
gets a one year Diamond membership not a
one month a one-year Diamond membership
is going to be given away all right when
we come back we're going to be we're
going to be giving our predictions we're
going to talk about what we think we're
going to see on the board we're going to
be diving into it all so don't go
anywhere the fide World Chess
Championship day one of that event and
chess.com's coverage brought to you by
coinbase continues in just a few
[Music]
chest outcomes coverage of the 2021
v-day World Championship is brought to
you by coinbase whether you're an
experienced Trader or just looking to
make your first crypto purchase coinbase
has you covered visit coinbase.com chess
to get five dollars in a free Bitcoin
just for verifying your account today
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
crushed through the top of the show
[Music]
all right
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
chess online or learn how to improve
join us at the number one chess
destination in the world chess.com with
thousands of people playing at any
moment you'll quickly find a game with
someone at your level whether you're a
beginner or a Grandmaster test.com makes
learning fun and easy sharpen your
tactics with puzzles and enhance your
strategy with our lessons by top Masters
learn from your own games with our easy
to use analysis tool chess.com has
everything you need to take your game to
the next level signing up is free and
easy join chess.com today
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
in case you didn't see our partners at
coinbase are sponsoring chess.com's
coverage of the 2021 v-day world
championship and boy are we thankful
whether you're an experienced Trader
been doing this for years or just
thinking about making your first crypto
purchase coinbase is the place to go
visit coinbase.com chess and get five
dollars in free Bitcoin when you sign up
and verify your account today
foreign
[Music]
thank you
want to hold a massive chess tournament
with dozens of clubs or hundreds of
players or maybe a small chess
tournament with local but competitive
clubs with Club Arenas you can
Club Arenas allow for tournaments of any
size with any number of clubs and
players customize the arena with any
time control with standard chess or mini
chest variants and with any starting
position you want Club Arenas are the
most flexible tournament format on
chess.com try one out today
[Music]
foreign
from Expo 2020 in Dubai matches are the
order of the day for World Championship
crowns however two world champions won
their titles in tournaments who are they
[Music]
[Music]
and we are back here day one of the feed
day World Chess Championship
chess.com's coverage brought to you by
coinbase and that that question there on
chess.com about what two world champions
two two world champions first won their
title via tournament right and we were
discussing it at the break so I do now
know the answer because Fabiana knew it
and he and he told me so but it's
actually the interesting one there's
some there's some controversy we'll get
into later because there's a maybe one
or even maybe okay we'll talk about it
we'll talk about it later in regards to
um what the answer could be it's a
little bit debatable but you can get
involved using the hashtag FWC trivia
you can also use the official hashtag to
get more notice Carlson nepo hashtag but
definitely use the FWC hashtag in order
to get involved and once again we will
be giving away a one-year Diamond
membership furry Day Diamonds Are every
day all right every day we got to get
into this guys so let's on the on the
first day we haven't seen anything yet
right so a lot of times in the next day
we're going to be talking about what
happened in day one how's someone going
to recover first day you know we were
talking about this match all week we've
been hanging out and you know we
inevitably get into discussions about
what's at stake on a bigger picture
level for both of these guys right I
think when we talk about Magnus you
think about his legacy when you think
about yawn you think about the
opportunity right so Robert let me let
me start with you and ask about magnus's
Legacy do you how important do you think
this match is is fifth world
championship match and and it would be a
big upset if you lost this in many
people's eyes right yeah it's not as
important as the first world
championship match he played in when he
beat viciana and Vichy himself said
maybe the light you know the fire isn't
burning as much right and Magnus said
that fires me up yeah so for Magnus you
know he's not etching his name into the
history books he's already part of the
lore of Chess Jana palmchi on the other
hand this is his opportunity to take the
world championship title and it's
important that he is nervous because he
cares and not nervous because he's
scared yeah no first of all that was a
hot line right there have you been
hanging out with Harry Mack uh no but I
did watch the freestyle okay that was
that was nice well yeah and going to not
being nervous because you're scared
right I mean you played in a World Chess
Championship Match right so as a
challenger to the throne what's at stake
for yon here did you were you just not
thinking about that at all is it just
like hey I gotta focus on what's in
front of me what I can control but what
do you think about as a top level chess
player who wants to cement his legacy
and by earning the the you know the
biggest title in the game and what do
you think is going through Jan's head
what's at stake for him besides just
wanting wanting to win the title well I
think it's ideal in general to get
results out of your head and just think
about the chess yeah but that's very
difficult practically and so I don't
think that either player can fully dis
distance themselves from thinking about
their legacy what they have at stake
yeah um Freon obviously it's much
greater this is his first time this is
his chance to to Really etch himself
into history books yeah Magnus uh has
already been here and done this before
but of course he still wants to keep his
title and he has that internal
motivation that always keeps him going
that's kept him number one for for a
decade now yep
um so yeah they they both will be
extremely motivated I think the more
interesting thing is uh how much nervous
will come into play and will they find
that healthy balance of nerves because
you need you need nerves you need to
have some butterflies in your belly you
can't just be there like
you know I don't I don't care about the
result because obviously they both care
a lot and they both need that but they
don't want that to become overpowering
to the point where
where it chokes up their decisions well
how was it for you you you had the first
game in fact that first game was one
where maybe you faced some of the the
most trouble you would face in hindsight
throughout the entire classical match
were you were you nervous because you
cared or nervous because you were scared
according to Robert's prime time uh I I
didn't feel scared but I I definitely
cared a lot and I was very nervous yeah
um and I think the nerves showed in the
first game for both of us because I
didn't play well I I got into a losing
position and then Magnus did something
extremely uncharacteristic where he had
a position which was easily one and I
would say that on a normal day for
Magnus he would have won that 99 times
out of 100 maybe even 100 times out of
100 yeah but that particular day he
messed it up
um so I don't think that was normal I
think the nerves were involved yeah the
first game is always the nerviest except
maybe for for the last game or the tie
breaks because you're still settling in
yeah um Brian it's a totally new
experience he's never been here before
he doesn't know the feeling well now he
does I'm sitting down at the board and
for the first time but for Magnus it's
still been a long break he hasn't done
this in years yeah and it's it's not
like any other event yeah
well one of the other things we of
course were talking about a lot of our
preview uh discussions around the dinner
table was what color they would have and
how that changes things and of course
now we know that right this was this was
video from the opening ceremony kind of
a fun video for those of you who maybe
haven't seen it yet on social media I'm
not gonna I'm not gonna pop your balloon
or burst your bubble about what's about
to happen here but this was when the
players found out their color Robert why
didn't Magnus just lean over and pop the
balloon in front of yawn you know I I
thought this was a little unfair in fact
because you're not going to stab across
from you in front of yawn space so of
course you're gonna pick the balloon
that's in front of you and so he starts
here with the black pieces the black
pieces and you know he's proven to be
quite good in game one yeah the black
pieces but the thing is getting good
positions is enough and yeah in the past
two World Championship matches against
Fabiano against kayaking you know not to
burst his bubble as you would say yeah
he didn't convert in the positions that
otherwise he normally would yeah and but
again Bobby you were saying that Magnus
has said he prefers white yet he's had
black as Robert just said and now he is
black again for his for the first game
for the third world championship match
in a row
um
maybe he's feeling a little more
comfortable with the second move at this
point I was actually a bit surprised
when I I saw him I read him uh that he
that he said that he prefers white in
the first game yeah because I have a
slightly different feeling of course
this is very subjective everyone will
have their preference but I feel like
with black it's easier to get into it
yeah because you you can more control
what will happen in the start you have
your defenses there's there's less that
your opponent can surprise you with
um especially in the opening yeah uh and
you more know what you're playing for
yeah a draw is a good result in the
first game with black in the match well
with white you want to press but you
don't want to overpress right it's
difficult to find that balance it's
interesting because yeah I I tend to
agree with you and obviously he is not
that he hasn't had winning Chances with
black so I'm also surprised to hear that
he prefers white but speaking of
surprises Robert what do we expect here
right we know that you and I were
sitting together when Magnus debuted the
Sicilian the the opening that in
hindsight would be a major talking point
of the 2018 match and and and almost
almost threw off his opponent enough to
win that first game right what surprises
do you think will be in store here for
today I think Jan was surprised for this
first move really yeah okay
okay well let's come back to that so
hold on we'll we'll come back to that in
in a minute because we are going to get
into our predictions here both with the
results we're going to tell you our
first move predictions
I don't know what move Robert thinks
we're gonna surprise but I think he's
going to be wrong so you know we'll get
into that but okay uh what won't be
wrong is is uh the time you're going to
be spending with us the moment the game
is over here on chess.com throughout
this entire event when the game ends
that's really when the Party begins
we're gonna have so many amazing guests
lined up we're going to give you full
game recaps with me and Fabiano and
Robert we're gonna be doing so much at
the top of the show today's first guess
will be Maxine Bache the grav he is the
Frenchman with three names formerly the
French number one there's there's a new
kid in town as they say uh in France
who's now number one known as far Asia
but Maxine still number one in your
hearts uh the three-time French Champion
will be joining us also talking a little
bit about his match on Monday versus
Fabiano caruana in our speeches
Championship we'll see what kind of
trash trash talk you guys get into uh
after after Maxine we will have the one
and only Levy Rosman known to the world
as Gotham chess
chess.com's new documentary coming out
is titled Gotham chess how Levy Rosman
became the chess teacher to the internet
uh our own videographer uh is putting
together some amazing stuff and we have
a documentary you are not going to want
to miss in fact I think we have a teaser
on that yeah right now so don't don't go
anywhere for those who just can't wait
here is a quick video teaser on the
documentary that will be World
premiering at the end of our show today
[Music]
oh
[Music]
I met Lucy for the first time in
November 2015 actually and the story is
that I I met her she was the suite Maid
of someone I had gone in a couple dates
with
our first date in 2015 went so poorly
because I didn't understand it or a
sense of humor and I thought it was
great I thought it was a fun date in
Nova in November December 2015 and she
hated me
so that was very inconvenient
and we ended up not seeing each other
again
um fast forward a couple years you know
on these on these apps that people meet
themselves uh meet each other on now and
um in 2017 and I saw her and I still had
her phone number so I texted her and he
goes do you think after three years four
years I don't know I can finally get
that second date
um
and I think I just responded why do you
still have my number
[Laughter]
but I still had your number so so what
the [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
well as we as we were getting set here
to make our predictions Robert was going
to make his prediction of the first move
looks like we're live gentlemen so we're
going to have to make our predictions on
top of the game because E4 is on the
board Robert was that going to be your
move prediction not at all so I'm glad
the move was made before I could guess
and usually the person who makes the
first move not the chess player but
there's a special guest who comes in to
make the first move they usually make a
move they want to play not necessarily
the one the player wants I was expecting
C4 on move one Jan used that mechanics
he played it against Garrett Kasparov
and hey fobby does this surprise you E5
from Magnus
um
no this doesn't surprise me at all I I
really expected that E4 would happen
um Jan is a naturally four player he's
played it all his life he feels most
comfortable in these types of positions
and also it's the easiest way or not the
easiest but the best way to put pressure
on Magnus in the opening and I think Jan
feels like
um
like he needs to put pressure on Magnus
in the opening
yeah that definitely makes sense and
yeah I'm looking pretty comfortable I
mean I don't know how to read his body
language it's his first go-around in the
world championship
he does make those faces though
yeah he makes a lot of faces as he
always does we see multiple moves being
made on the board
remember everybody you can cast your
vote if you go to chess.com events and
vote in real time we have ten thousand
dollars in prizes going on we're uh
we're kind of bouncing around here this
game started so fast the uh
yeah the uh well then who do you think's
gonna win I mean okay so we we have our
match predictions that we're going to be
making here so
well we'll just do them right now and
then later on we'll bring it up so
Robert you go first what was your what
was your prediction
well I'm on the spot I guess I was gonna
say a draw even before I saw the opening
moves I think that we have a measured
Yonder palmshi who looked like a
different player in the second half of
the candidates versus what we've seen
from him traditionally so I do think the
game will end in a draw okay and uh
Fabiano
so I think between two players of this
caliber it's always extremely likely
that a game wanted to draw but my
prediction is that Magnus will take the
first game with black
and wow that is a bold prediction
you got you got magnets with black in
game one is that a little bit of you
know Deja Vu given uh given that that
was almost your experience a little bit
of a confirmation bias there
I might maybe completely off of course
but my feeling is that the nerves might
come into play okay but Danny do you
remember we were speaking last night and
I made an opening prediction you sure
did
uh the Marshall
yeah indeed and we're going to get into
that right now I'm going to quickly make
my prediction and say I think I think
you know what let's go let's go all in
I'm gonna go with Jan Jan is gonna get
game one
you know initially I was actually with
you I almost envisioned Jan nervously
pushing through time pressure and
blowing the advantage but I'm gonna I'm
gonna say that uh I'm gonna say that
John actually gets it
that John John takes day one and the
Challenger puts the uh the champion on
his heels and we are talking all drama
for the next few weeks so there you go
everybody you can cast your vote if you
go to chess.com events we are
experiencing a lot of traffic I don't
even know
um what's happening right now at
just.com events so we're gonna we're
gonna keep on the uh keep on the uh the
game here keep on the cams
um of the players someone is standing in
front of the playing Hall camera this is
hilarious that is a human being standing
in front of the camera right there I
thought it was Casper the Friendly Ghost
yeah well we've got we've got also as we
said they're a vote chess event going on
if you go to chess.com events uh you can
vote although I think we just sent
literally tens of thousands of people to
our site that don't normally go there
and if you're having any difficulty
voting that is why um so we will come
back to you on that for now we're going
to get into the chess and uh Fabiano you
were right
talk a little bit about why you
predicted uh this this variation of the
Lopez
I I feel like and this is from some
recent work also that the Marshall is is
a great place where you can be flexible
with black you have a lot of options
with black and you also have that
solidity and that's exactly what Magnus
wants a positional game
where he can stay very flexible so he
probably won't get caught out in very
direct preparation
which I think is magnus's main worrying
General in the opening that his opponent
simply uh catches him with some
computer-generated prep and in the
Marshall that's very very difficult to
uh
for that to happen okay
that's interesting
um I don't know that I I didn't predict
anything like this now Robert you were
going to predict C4 tell everybody why
you thought that was going to be what
John played well I thought for no less a
reason than the virtue of surprise that
Jan did play in the cabinets he also
played against Garrick is Barb in a
rapid game but we all expected Jan to
play E4 so it's not like I see E4 and
what is yon doing of course that's his
main repertoire but because Magnus is so
good at surprising his opponents I
thought maybe Jan would land the first
surprise yeah in game one and of course
I was wrong okay well hey we're here to
be wrong so Fabiano can be right
Bobby by the way you're looking you're
looking fresh by the way just wanted to
tell you like saying something
all right leave me out of it
um all right well there we go everybody
we are off the action is rolling here if
you're just tuning in where have you
been this is the 2021 feed a World Chess
Championship chess.com's coverage
brought to you by coinbase we are so
excited to be here and uh the just the
the first game getting underway has
everyone excited
and look at that so we've got Knight A5
on the board
for uh for for black this is an
interesting moment because the most
common move is D6
yeah because Magnus is sacrificing a
pawn with Knight A5 yeah in order to
gain the two Bishops
so this move is is known it's on an
unknown move but it's not the most
common move so the interesting thing
will be to see
um
how Yan's reaction to it will be will he
play immediately I assume he will
because he probably knows something
about it uh or will he be kind of cut
off guard right
and it was interesting probably that
Magnus spent some time after H3 so do
you think that he was surprised by
John's Choice was he trying to remember
something or was he just trying to
settle down get into the rhythm of the
game because if you move too quickly
sometimes you continue doing that right
well I think that in general he probably
prepared the opening as a whole for the
match and when you prepare an entire
opening you uh you're going to check
let's say a main move like H3 and you're
going to check it totally so you're
going to analyze D6 and Knight A5 and
all these possible options that you have
and your opponent has so that you really
immerse yourself into the position uh so
I think he was just considering his
options because he can't predict that
Jon will play H3 or C3 or A4 or any of
these uh extremely popular moves so he
was just considering his options at that
point that's that's my best guess
yeah that makes sense and John has
indeed already taken the pawn
and uh Magnus has already responded by
capturing V3
so we see a position where white is up a
pawn black secures the pair of Bishops
and that E4 Pawn does look loose so
black can go about and take that we're
going to refresh the board refresh the
mini board because actually white has
already castled so the uh the moves
coming in really fast there white is
actually already castled in the
and The Rook is on E1 actually
so we'll uh well just so everyone sees
the the live cam and the mini board
we're gonna sync that up here in just a
sec but go ahead Robert finish your
point no I just think it's an
interesting decision here by magnets in
the opening and well I want to know from
fabiana's point of view somebody who
played against Magnus for the world
championship is Matt is going for a
certain style against Yan because we
know how tactically alert yon is and
people talk about that non-stop they're
mentioning the super computers that he's
working with so many articles about that
so do you think we're seeing a style for
the rest of the Metro Banks or it's just
game one and he's just choosing well
this is he's moving fast here
aggressively has already played D5 so go
ahead Bobby I I don't think that style
really comes into play because both of
these players are are Universal Players
um there are some stereotypes about
you know yarn style Magnuson style but
the truth is that they're good in all
sorts of positions so I think Magnus is
simply playing the line which he
believes in
um
yeah Jan is obviously also ready for it
and they're going to trade Queens
um
they're going to trade queens now it
looks like
um yeah the but actually I do want to
say one thing about the position yeah
um
this this is a very short blind it's
actually also possible that they won't
trade Queens Magnus has a choice now he
can either trade queens or he has Bishop
D6 and we might see an extremely
exciting line where Black's Queen ends
up on H2 uh White's King has to move to
the center but white wins upon we we may
see this line it is a sort of
um
theoretical possibility and now now
we're going to see it because Magnus
went for the
went for the line
yeah so he
gets it from the board he's moving
quickly Jan
still probably in his preparation
despite his look away from the board and
I mean at the start of this game at
least I've I I guess a different move
one so yeah I'm already surprised by the
first move the game and
and how many moves do you think they've
prepared because John and Max both
talked about the extreme preparation how
deep they have to go and how much more
do you think we'll see from their
engines and not their brands well it's
clear that they're both in their engine
prep yeah
um and yeah yeah now Magnus has a choice
he can play Queen takes E5 this forces
Queen takes B7 otherwise white loses a
piece and then black has to play Queen
H2 to justify this play and then we have
this extremely complicated fight or he
can make another move uh there are
various like Rook moves to force white
to trade Queens himself
and then we'll see an end game where
white is a pawn up and a far less
exciting affair
um
but
I guess it depends on how confident
Magnus is feeling about his prep if he
goes for the quid H2 line because there
he's taking a lot more risk
um but it's also if he's prepared it
super super well then maybe it's also a
better choice for him but he chooses
yeah Rook F to B8
um
and and now we will see a trade of
Queens
right and the white king is already
castled yeah yeah and so and there's a
rook on he wants that night is not
hanging on E5 so protecting the center
and still upon ahead for white for Yana
palmshi but Magnus confidently playing
nonetheless
yeah yeah we'll we'll stay we'll stay
right here until we until we get the
board updated we'll commentate from our
from our bird's eye view here look at
the so the king is on F1
in the live position this is all this is
all still no no Fabi this is all
preparation it looks like so the
interesting thing about this position is
I don't know if the last move came as a
surprise Dion because
um the stockfish engine shows Queen
takes E5 as a move Queen B7 Queen H2 and
and an engine like Lilo shows work fb8
because it's happy to play a pawn down
in the end game
so it's a neural neural net action on
the board already right as far as the
preparation goes yeah so so it looks
like Jan maybe that came as a surprise
to him so he it's clear he's looked at
the line but not in extreme depth he's
looked at it more from the point of view
of the most forcing option for black but
not the more positional options okay
well we're gonna we're gonna keep tuned
in everyone you will be able to see the
live playing cams and everybody as well
as as well as the live feed as it comes
in though we're going to take a very
short break when we come back we will
continue to dive into all of the action
on the board get more of Bobby's
thoughts I want to unpack this whole uh
this whole difference between how you
said Leela evaluates this versus the
other engines I think that that's a
fascinating point because one of the
things we're all going to be learning is
how how the players prepared for these
games and maybe getting more and more
insight into into what they're doing at
home in the kitchen so all right you're
going to get everything you need at the
break so don't go anywhere we will be
right back
chess.com's coverage of the 2021 v-day
World Championship is brought to you by
coinbase whether you're an experienced
Trader or just looking to make your
first crypto purchase coinbase has you
covered visit coinbase.com chess to get
five dollars in free Bitcoin just for
verifying your account today
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
first game of the 2021 video World
Championship
[Music]
Emerald lighting and audio
we're gonna Crush through the top of the
show
[Music]
all right
thank you
[Music]
want to play chess online or learn how
to improve join us at the number one
chess destination in the world chess.com
with thousands of people playing at any
moment you'll quickly find a game with
someone at your level whether you're a
beginner or Grandmaster chess.com makes
learning fun and easy sharpen your
tactics with puzzles and enhance your
strategy with our lessons by top Masters
learn from your own games with our easy
to use analysis tool chess.com has
everything you need to take your game to
the next level signing up is free and
easy join chess.com today
foreign
ERS at coinbase are sponsoring
chess.com's coverage of the 2021 v-day
world championship and boy are we
thankful whether you're an experienced
Trader been doing this for years or just
thinking about making your first crypto
purchase coinbase is the place to go
visit coinbase.com chess and get five
dollars in free Bitcoin when you sign up
and verify your account today
foreign
[Music]
want to hold a massive chess tournament
with dozens of clubs or hundreds of
players or maybe a small chess
tournament with local but competitive
clubs with Club Arenas you can
Club Arenas allow for tournaments of any
size with any number of clubs and
players customize the arena with any
time control with standard chess or mini
chest variants and with any starting
position you want Club Arenas are the
most flexible tournament format on
chess.com try one out today
[Music]
foreign
am I supposed to feel ready but
I guess
when you prepare for such a major event
you always
feel like you could could do more but I
guess we are doing some insane amount of
works
I hope we we get to be you know
ready enough
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
uh it's you know it's I mean if trying
to be serious it's hard to evaluate
because
um I think in modern chairs you got to
be
very Universal player if you want to be
successful and so you can't rely on the
intuition alone
so it's
they would like to you know to say that
for example a player a royal Chamberlain
would be the best intuition ever is
Mikhail child but
I guess he also had
see you have to calculate a lot here and
for example today if you you could try
to to stick to his playing style
sometimes it will be very costly to to
your performance I think yeah the
intuition is always good but
I mean sometimes you basically can't
choose the move
because of your calculation or
evaluation and you need to for example
sometimes you are given like two similar
opportunities you you you got to pick
one and okay probably here inclusion
comes
[Music]
thank you foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
and we are back day one of the feed a
World Chess Championship is underway and
uh we have action guys we have a lot of
moves on the board to unpack this is uh
this is going to be
gonna be quite the game here I think I
think the prep is is being revealed
right now it looks like Magnus might be
a little a little bit deeper down his
prep than yawn given we don't normally
see Nippon Mishi take take a second to
think unless he really needs to so Fabi
let's talk about this live position real
quick and then we'll have plenty of time
to back up and break down every single
ounce of how we got here yeah so so it's
clear that Magnus is still in prep and
this is
um
yeah this is not a position that Jan's
checked before but he did play the
correct move I think Bishop D2 yeah uh
it's just it's a somewhat subtle move
the point is that the Knight on B4 is
extremely annoying for what if we like
back up one move yep
and let's say white plays instead of
Bishop B2 Knight C3
which looks like you're developing the
Knight you're trying to trade off pieces
within your up material but the night
before it hits the pawn yeah and the
only way to defend that
is by rookie 2 but then the Rook gets
overloaded uh goes D2 and white can
sorry black just takes here yeah or
or on C2 immediately but yeah white
black is winning the pawn back okay and
so that's why uh Jan was not quick to
develop that Knight first he wants to
control the B4 Square
and uh and then he'll think about where
to put that Knight maybe C3 it could
even potentially go to A3 it looks like
a strange square and normally you say
Knight's on the rim or dim right but the
Knight also has some options of escaping
the A3 Square by plane let's say Knight
A3 C3 Knight C2 so the Knight has some
um
some possibilities there the important
thing is that why does a pawn so he
needs to try to get his development he
needs to get his last piece developed
the Knight on B1 and then he should be
better and while black will try to
um create as much let's say counter play
in that time that he can okay Robert the
the Practical the practical
things we're seeing on screen here right
that's a that's not not necessarily a
nervous yawn right but he's clearly
thinking like you and I have talked a
lot about you know the normal behavior
we see we see from him and and the way
he manages his time what are your
thoughts on on what's going through his
head right now or you think he's trying
to remember prep or you think he's he's
he's uh in the woods yeah Fabi and I
were talking about this uh during the
break and we think that Jan's probably
in New Territory for him and Magnus
playing very quickly yawn trying to
figure things out the board and you know
for these top level players of course
they have a sense of what's going on
they understand the game Super well so
he's trying to find the best
continuation in a position like this in
our current position it's not very easy
because that Bishop on B7 that's the
lone light score Bishop on the board and
if you look at as a full length of the
diagonal all the way down to G2 and if
you're ever going to block that Bishop
well preferably you'd have your knight
getting to E4 or something like that but
that's really difficult because it's 5
going to point out every time a knight
comes to C3 there are Knight B4 ideas
and that might be an issue for whites
have to do with that and so you know
dealing with that Bishop The Rook on B
looks awkward it was placed there
earlier for a specific purpose to defend
the bishop on B7 yep now it's going to
hurry right back to the center right no
that's super interesting because I think
okay so now now we'll have we'll have a
second to back up we see Magnus kind of
kind of looking around there and and
let's let's show everybody how we got
here
it was the move started coming in Rapid
Fire but it was indeed a Lopez as
predicted by Fabiano
main line with Bishop A4 Knight F6
castles and Bishop E7 rookie one really
the first move that kind of turned our
head here Bobby was after H3 by yawn
which is which is a specific move to
decline the Marshall for those who don't
know if you play C3 you are opening up
the possibility for black to play D5 and
go for a Mainline Marshall Gambit but H3
being met by Knight A5 Bobby this was
the first thing that kind of had you
taking pause right yeah this was the
first interesting moment yeah
um because normally black plays D6 yes
um I'm sorry normally black plays Bishop
to B7
um okay so to explain the line a little
bit if um black plays D6 instead of
Bishop instead of Bishop B7 okay which
is let's say the most normal developing
move okay white plays C3 yep and reaches
a classical RI Lopez right which is what
he wants he's avoided the Marshall he's
avoided c3d5 he's got what he wants yep
um so normally black plays Bishop B7
instead of D6 instead of D6 with the AIM
of playing D5 and sacrificing the E5
Pawn later on right for example after D3
black plays D5 it's an extremely sharp
variation where white often takes on E5
but then yeah black can take back or can
even put deny on D4 and then black has
all this pressure on the king side if
you the bishop at some point will come
to D6
um and and all the pieces will be aiming
at White's King and also black has an
id4 instead of Knight takes E5 instead
yeah yeah in this in this main line here
you have Knight to D4 which is
and this is actually very similar to the
game in some ways because black will
often take on B3 and then we'll have the
same position same type of position but
with the queen zone right so it's a bit
of a Twist okay but Knight A5 played
instead and
Robert this is a this is a sacrifice of
a pawn right the E5 Pawn now white
doesn't go for it right away necessarily
uh no white does go for it right away
sorry so we get caught up to the live
position here with D5 and you and Fabi
were talking a lot about this position
right here yes Queen F3 is such an
important move because we see the bishop
and queen lined up on the G2 Pawn
threatening Checkmate so Queen F3 is one
of these moves that forces the Queens
off the board black has no choice
because if wherever the queen goes the
bishop on B7 is hanging and you could
get crazy pieces of the queen takes E5
yeah I was gonna say what happens if we
get crazy so just to back up one one
moment because Queen F3 is the best move
uh but it's not the only move there's
also Knight F3 okay right uh but it's
clear that white would rather trade
Queens right and that's because you're
up upon because White's King is the one
that is potentially In Harm's Way
um so Knight F3 is not a bad move but
Queen F3 it's clear that yawn was ready
for this he knew about this line which
is a rare line but he had obviously
studied it he knew that Queen F3 is the
best move Bishop D6 is a good move
uh White doesn't want to trade on D5 yet
he wants to trade under more favorable
circumstances like we saw in the game
and why is it more favorable to play
King F1 and Rook Rook fv8 well because
in many lines The Rook will come back to
E8 well let's say let's say if white
doesn't play King F1 but takes on D5
okay Knight D5 and now if blackplayers
work fe8 or Rook A8 at some point right
The Rook on E1 is not defended which
means that white will be forced to
retreat with the Knight all the way to
the back Rank and there's one more
important move which Fabian had
referenced earlier and if we just go
back a step before Bishop D6 Queen takes
E5 is one of those moves where now both
Queens are under attack so it looks like
I'm giving up my queen but the bishop on
B7 hits the queen on F3 as well but then
after Rook takes E5
Bishop takes F3 it's a queen trade and
Rook takes E7 we see the problem that
white was up one Pawn to begin with now
the bishop on F3 is under attack the
second Pawn on C7 is under attack A6 is
threatened so white is clearly better in
such a position so if we go back to that
moment with Bishop D6
there's a really big threat now of Queen
takes E5 so if we make the move say
Knight C3 think oh you'll trade me on F3
my knight will just recapture no Queen
takes E5 Now is really good for black
because your Rook is loose on E1 if you
trade Queens in this matter now you
don't even get the piece because you're
Rooks under attack on E5 okay okay makes
a lot of sense and obviously as you said
this is a slightly rare line in this in
this version of the Lopez but one that
both of them seem well prepared to play
so after King F1 now we understand this
little inner inner missile kind of high
class waiting move if you will just to
make sure that you Force black to commit
all the way to guarding the bishop
otherwise the queen is frozen right but
once black does guard the bishop now
White's hand is forced and you have to
trade but there is a very interesting
moment after King F1 so King F1 had two
purposes one was as a slightly useful
move in the end game but the other one
is shown after Queen takes E5 Robert
referenced this move instead of Rook FBA
after the yeah Robert referenced this
move when white plays another move
besides kick up one but here it's very
different because after Queen takes B7
right White's Rook is defended but this
would still be super interesting because
black could play Queen H2 uh now that
would have been a spicy way for us to
start off the first game that would have
been the best world championship and and
this is some sort of position that I'm
sure they've both studied and I think
this is what Yan was expecting yeah uh
he wasn't expecting to move for Cafe but
he was ready for this okay and he
probably had some prep here so what what
makes you think that because you wreck
you mentioned as we went to the break
and we promised the fans you would
unpack it you mentioned that Rook fb8 is
a move that Leela suggests here so
oh to unpack what you're saying you're
saying the the move that you think you
almost expecting was Queen takes C5 and
is this because this is what the more
traditional engines would go for or this
is the most forcing way and it's if
you're preparing this for white and
let's say you think this is a sideline
this is not something where I want to
put all my effort in uh-huh so he's he's
looking at the most forcing and
dangerous option which is Queen E5 Queen
B7 Queen H2 right he has something ready
here
uh and engine engines show that this is
playable for black but he's he has some
some prep that probably goes quite deep
okay involving very very sharp lines
because white king will inevitably at
some point have to escape to E2 right
it'll just have to because after Queen
H1 check there's nowhere else to go do
you have a lot of prep in this line I
I've checked this line you don't have to
reveal it I mean you can if you want
because well the the funny thing is that
now that it's been played everyone's
going to check this line okay well
suddenly now you could start revealing
your prep because you know there goes
the uh right rabbits rabbits out of the
out of the Hat now yeah sorry I mean
this funny situation Fabi where I might
have to ask
you John of course he studied this line
and probably quite deeply do you think
he was hoping for this rather than
expecting right like there's this weird
balance between hope and expecting and
uh for him he wants a tactical position
he doesn't want to be in an end game I
presume because that's where Magnus is
really at his best yeah I think Jan
um was probably confident because he's
like
I've checked this line I know what to do
but he also knows that Magnus is
extremely well prepared uh well-prepared
player Magnus is very very smart in the
opening and in choosing his openings so
he knows that it's not going to be so
easy that Magnus is just going to go
directly into the line that he played
but but still that's fascinating and
it's already getting us a little more
insight right going into World
Championship matches you're wondering
who the team of seconds are how are they
using engines I I made a comment
recently to someone who I gave an
interview to I said well everyone has
the same second now which is a jet
engine packed with a neural net machine
learning and so the question is who are
you human who are your human seconds
unpacking that right and now we see
Magnus playing this move Rook Rook fv8
probably surprising Young
and now after Bishop D2 C5 just to
remind everybody again the live position
with the
with C5 on the board Jana's Jan is still
thinking and now only has an an hour and
30 minutes left he's more than 20
minutes down on the timer yeah so I just
want to explain the move Rook FBA a
little bit because it's such a weird
move it looks so unnatural usually you
hear that you put the Rooks in the
center yep and you don't put your Rooks
side by side on Aid and B8 that's soup
that's just very strange yeah
um so the point the first point is if
white plays Knight C3 let's say or some
some move like that then now to Queen
takes E5
if white plays Queen takes B7 yeah the
bishop is protected and black queen
takes you one yeah Queen E1 Rook B7
black ends up upper Rook right so that's
why Rook FBA it happened and why didn't
Rook aviate happen is other questions I
knew I knew exactly where you were going
with that so now the point is if Queen
takes D5
and black wants to play Knight takes D5
put the Knight on the center like he did
in the game Fork down but then comes a
fork Knight D7 and black loses an
exchange
and of course Bishop takes D5 instead of
Knight takes D5 hangs the pawn Ace right
so that pawn being a backward Pawn is
going to be a Target throughout the
current position but also in all these
variations you have to look out for the
pawn A6 as soon as you play B5 you know
that's where you're looking at man you
know what makes world championship games
easy to understand having two grand
Masters directly to your left this is
some awesome stuff guys so yeah now now
everybody in chat no matter where you
are watching from thanks for being with
us you understand fully this very unique
was it officially a novelty is this
actually a move that has never been
played before I think about this already
after King F1 there are no games uh I I
could be wrong but at least there are no
high level games in this line right so
which made which made your prep and
everyone else's secret prep really
valuable until about five minutes ago
when it was all played so now now
everybody is going to be looking into
this line Grand Masters everywhere unite
and Bishop to D2 C5 again this is still
this is still the live position for
those of you keeping track at home right
white has a tiny Edge as you can see via
the evaluation bar that's because of the
pawn but from a practical perspective
Magnus clearly in the driver's seat a
little bit right
yeah I think that this is not a great
outcome for yawn okay
um he has a decent position he's
objectively slightly better he's the one
who can press this position rather than
Magnus yeah but Magnus knows the
position yeah he has knowledge that you
can't figure out over the board you can
figure out a lot if you're a player as
strong as he on but you can't figure out
computer analysis that's done over hours
and hours right it's just impossible
yeah um so now Jan
has a choice because his Bishop tuber
was super
um natural and good he wanted to control
that B4 square but now he has to decide
where to put that B1 Knight does he want
to play Knight C3 does he want to play
Knight A3 also legitimate Choice Knight
E3 might still be met by this Robert and
then is the difference now that you've
developed you can bring the Rook to C1
yeah you can play The Rook to C1 but
where your piece is going that's the
essential question is Knight on E5 it
looks well placed but it requires
defense because the bishop 1 D6
attacking it and you would love to play
the move at some point Knight C3 to E4
you can't get away with that because
that cuts off The Rook on E1 from the
95. so even though white has some pieces
that look good they're not able to be
improved and that's a frustrating thing
in chess right you're like peace is
great I should have a good position I'm
up a Pawn Yeah blacks pieces are
actually better and and can keep going
so I liked Bobby's idea by the way these
Knight A3 ideas because at some point if
you're not careful from Black's
perspective the move C2 to C4 could be
on the docket like just it's kind of
surprising we're especially with the
Rook on B8 it would allow it to maybe
barrel down the B file if there are some
trades but C4 could be forcing and in
that instance like you're left with some
difficult decisions for black right
whether to leave the pawn whether the
trade and how do you preempt that
because if C4 is an option for white how
should I be best prepared to meet it
right
well good points and obviously uh
like you said not all about looking good
though you look good by the way on on
camera there we were uh just uh just I
just want to say that sweater that's
what um it's not but seriously I think
the more the more you guys are
explaining this the more it's it's I'm
starting to understand that white
White's position is it's weird the
engine is going to continue to say
White's a little better but it's hard to
find a useful plan here for white that
doesn't make your position worse yeah I
think Robert uh points out a extremely
uh logical idea to play C2 to C4 okay
because so let's go into that so Knight
E3 first
um well this was this was generally
speaking because after Knight A3 I think
black will probably play rookie eight
okay and then things will get a bit more
forcing because white will be forced to
drop the Knight back to F3 right okay so
let's look at C4 now then uh yeah C4 now
is is an option uh it kicks the Knight
out of the center
but it also damages the structure
somewhat yeah yeah you you have those
backward pawns on B2 and B3 so you don't
have that structural Advantage
um that comes with an extra Pawn that
you normally do it looks like we have
had a move we saw Jan just played The
Retreat from E5 to three this this makes
sense based on a lot of the things
Robert was highlighting that you're kind
of you're kind of stuck having to
protect that centralized Knight as long
as he's there so getting bringing him
back frees up your options a little bit
I I think that Magnus is prepared for
this move
um it's it's it's a very logical move
because the knight at some point will
Retreat black wants to play rookie eight
or even F6 in some cases to kick that
Knight back so it's going to go to F3
one way no matter what right so I don't
think that this comes as a surprise for
Magnus
um the question is now he has a lot of
options he's made the most logical moves
up to this point but now with the play
is no longer forcing
um and and he has to decide where to put
his Rooks does he want them on d8 and C8
for example does he want them on E8 to
trade off Rooks
um and he could also even consider a
move like F6 at some point to play King
F7 and just do the thing you do in end
games but it's not even just to get your
Kingston there could be a good time in
G5 like a G5 H5 because black is very
stable on the king side and we keep
talking about the bishop B7
don't lose track of that Bishop because
if black and push pawns forward over
there maybe the bishop will have the
full scope of the diagonal once more and
I don't know if Bobby when I'm looking
at this you know the 95 like I want it
there but I also want to move it at some
point and white wants to develop the
knight from B1 likely to C3 and now the
E4 square is possible but you also don't
want allow the Knights of B4 so it feels
like a weird waiting game yeah so if
white plays Knight C3 the the play will
become a lot more uh forcing and
concrete
um because let's let's say black makes a
move like Rook to d8 knew you were gonna
say that and white plays Knight to C3
black will play Knight to B4
white will almost be forced to play Rook
ac1 Rook ec1 is an option but it looks a
bit strange to lose that opening file
and then white black will have to decide
how to deal with this idea of Knight to
E4
uh and one surprising way of doing it
is actually to capture on F3 yeah I was
just about to say are you ever we know
you know we black has the bishop pair
and in the long run the open board will
favor them but are you when are you
giving up that Bishop to permanently
damage white structure everywhere yeah
it's it's it's a difficult question do
you value the bishop pair more highly
than the damage structure on the king
side uh normally I would say that you
don't
but in this case I I kind of know that
this is an idea
um and and after Bishop F3 gf3 black
often plays a slightly unusual move
because normally you think I shouldn't
be damaging my kingside Pawn structure I
should keep those Pawns in line or maybe
play H6 to make some loot but in this
case uh a typical idea is to play F5
so you're kind of opening up the king a
bit but it's an end game so you can you
kind of do that without risking King
safety the main point is to keep this
Knight out of E4 you mainly want to stop
94 and where else does that Knight go it
doesn't have many other good places to
go Robert you were going to say
something on that yeah for sure because
the move F5 if you go back before
capturing on F3 you have to worry about
things maybe the Knight Will hop to G5
maybe then it will go back to E5 and you
can't kick it out with a pawn so uh
Bishop takes F3 is committal for sure
but it does remove some options for
white and actually fobby made a really
interesting point when Rook a to C1 is
the natural move right you already have
a rook on E1 an open file and we tend to
bring our Rooks towards the center
because that's how we think we develop
them The Rook on A1 is developed here
yeah because there is a Target on A6 so
in this moment if you go to that
variation with Rook e to C1
so you bring the Rook to protect the
pawn on the E to C1 and we go through
this lining in Bishop F3 G takes F3
we see a position where the Rook on A1
is targeting the pawn on A6 so White's
idea as we talked about is Knight E4 and
if we can move that Knight we are
actually threatening at some point to
remove the Knight on B4 and then double
up Rooks in the a file so The Rook on A1
is well positioned even though
principles of Chess your coaches tell
you put your Rooks in the center that's
not always the case no that's a that's a
really good point actually and and you
can see that
the keeping the Rook there also makes
you think twice about parting ways with
that Bishop because doing so makes that
pawn even even weaker right so Magnus
now you said father you expect that he
is prepared for this move but this is
the first time for the record that we
have seen the world champion really go
into any kind of thing in this in this
uh this current World Chess Championship
so if you're just tuning in thanks for
being here and uh Magnus Magnus either
trying to remember all the things that
his team of seconds and Leela said about
this position or he's um or he's uh
regretting those uh those eggs he had
for breakfast so go ahead Bobby well I I
think it's possible that he knows a
position uh this concrete position and
he's deciding between various options
because it's not like there's one clear
best move here yeah the other thing is
that he may not entirely remember the
details because a lot of these positions
look very much alike right so it's not
entirely clear if this is the exact
position or if it's just a similar
position right you've seen before it
feels like this is early enough that
Pro probably he he would still know it
right or what do you think am I I mean
you you've been there well it gets a bit
less concrete here so early on it's
super concrete you can basically figure
out the options because the line is just
it's just straightforward right here
white has you know Knight F3 Knight C3
Knight A3 Bishop D2 is also not a force
move so white had like three four
options there right
um so when you have three four options
each move the branches just grow out
exponentially and you can't really keep
it right um all analyzed right you more
or less so you're saying chess is hard
chess is very same chest at a high level
is hard okay that makes sense Robert I
think in the position position like this
in particular excuse me that you see a
very unclear situation both players they
can visualize six moves in all different
directions but evaluating that position
is extremely difficult when there's a
material imbalance they know both sides
know black has compensation of course
they don't know right a quantitatively
unless they have this position at home
which doesn't seem like they do so they
don't know oh is it half a pawn better
for white right is it closer to
completely level is it closer to really
being a pawn for White and the answer to
that they are aware that it's less of an
advantage you know a smaller side but
when you start just making moves all
these options look reasonable you get
careless you have to be objective every
turn and you need to be skeptical about
the decisions that's being made because
Knight F3 looks like a move that you
would play regardless father and I've
been talking moves like F6 to kick the
Knight rookie eight but maybe you make
that move too soon and you're not
developing here it's perfectly
reasonable to make the move Knight F3
but when something is familiar to you we
often take it for granted that we should
actually continue calculating right
no it makes a lot of sense and
and if I'm correct that it may not even
be that he doesn't know a move here or
an idea but you're trying to do
everything you guys just described in
positions that are four moves down the
road five moves down the road trying to
remember why did why did we want the
Rooks here in that line again because in
some deep variation I it's critical that
I'm still guarding that pawn right and
and that sort of stuff and I think so
when we see the players they're uh
they're thinking about a lot more than
meets the eye yeah well Magnus uh has in
general a very good positional feeling
one would say the best positional
feeling among players
um so
of course he can navigate this position
although he he doesn't do it the way a
computer would do it by just crunching
through all the numbers yeah and coming
up with an evaluation he more or less
can see which moves of his
um
have less reasonable options for his
opponent if that makes sense yeah that
he makes a move and it looks like it's
harder for Yan to uh to find an easy
boost so he's trying to cut across his
opponent's plans in a way
um
but yeah here here is just a very
difficult decision because black has so
many options and none of them lead to a
queer conclusion yeah and after that
white will have so many options none of
them leading to a clear conclusion so he
more or less just has to feel his way
through to to the move he feels is right
and question for you Fabi because I
mentioned off-handedly F6 G5 H5 you know
with the King on F7
do you think that Magnus at some point
can say I've stabilized let me try to
play for more and maybe that's even just
playing the natural and good moves but
is that an idea that comes to mind of
playing on the king side just expanding
on that front yeah I I think that this
is definitely a position that one day
black could get a get an advantage maybe
it wouldn't be nothing of an advantage
to win but this black has potential here
things could go slightly wrong for white
to the point where white is slightly
worse but at the moment white is a bit
better so his first thought should be
um how do I neutralize white slide Edge
um so I I don't think he's thinking
about you know long term like winning
chances yet I might be winning this game
right I think first he's thinking
um let me consolidate my position
uh and then try to equalize this right I
guess I was asking in the sense of like
can you combine those things because
sometimes we equalize we trade all the
pieces it's just a draw other times we
make moves that are completely sound and
reasonable but give us that flexibility
to play for a win so you played Magnus
of course in the last World Championship
and he tends to like to play on he's the
type player who doesn't want to make a
quick draw so I'm just wondering you
know if he plays a move like F6 which
takes that nice jumps away from it and
we had mentioned as a move even before
Knight F3 what do you think Max's
mindset is at this moment you know of
course you said
equalizing First Step but can you
combine that I think if you were playing
a weaker player then he would try to
keep that tension in the position
without compromising his position but
here I think he doesn't want to take any
extra risks like that it's the first
game of a world championship match he's
plain black
um for him and for anyone a draw is a
good result in this situation the result
I predicted so he wants to make me happy
exactly that both that's main what's
mainly on his mind right now
well Bobby another thing I'm thinking
about here is in general the side that
controls the pawn breaks is the happier
side but white is up a pawn so we
mentioned C4 I'm still looking at that
not necessarily on this turn but
combined with Knight A3
is there any future in C4 or is that too
ambitious
I don't really see C4 happening but but
it is definitely an option yeah let's
let's try this move let's your C4 for
black oh no yeah sorry I thought so when
you used I'm not entirely sure about uh
Rook d8 though because it's it's also
difficult to decide if black wants to
trade works that's a big question does
black want to play rookie eight yeah and
that's a difficult question too let's
let's look at that first then so Rook
it's a rookie eight okay what I think I
I didn't suggest the next move because I
have no idea what I should play you
pause it what are you are you guys are
the grand Masters rookie Aid definitely
suggests that white wants to connect his
Rooks yeah because he would rather
capture on E1 with a rook okay so Knight
A3 now Knight A3 definitely makes a lot
of sense yes okay
is there a possibility if we just go
back a half seven can I trade on E8 I'm
just wondering if we get a bit forcing
so trade and then I play Knight C3
because we keep talking about how black
wants to play Knight B4 but I'm
wondering white has Knight E4 as a
response I knew you were going there
that is a spicy idea in fact after
Bishop takes Eve just Pawn takes E4 and
if you take on C2 I take on A6 if you
take on e4 I get rid of your knight and
A6 is loose and we keep talking about
this Pawn on A6 and this is I think a
clear illustration of how things can go
wrong for black Robert that was a great
flight I haven't seen the eval bar agree
with Robert Hess this much since uh 2018
World Chess Championship were you there
Fabi yeah I actually think this is an
excellent idea Robert
um but after 94 black is not forced to
take that's true okay so Knight B4
Knight E4 obviously you can protect the
bishop even a move like Bishop f8 yeah I
would say that the best move is probably
Bishop f8 here okay but this does give
white the option of further changing the
pawn structure Bishop takes B4 yeah and
then we have a super weird Pawn
structure black has these three pawns
which actually can create a past Pawn
someday that's true they that's and
that's an important thing those pawns
are potentially past Pawn if all the
pieces were off the board
like let's say the Rooks are off the
board yeah yeah and that a pawn starts
to go down the board right it's actually
very dangerous that's actually a
fascinating idea to see the to see the
double pawns and the potential for the
eight Pawn to run now on the flip side
with the Rooks on the board you're not
getting to White's Pawn because right
pawns you look at the base Pawn the pawn
C2 you can attack it once with your Rook
I can bring my knight to E1 or you know
play Rook C1 or something like that and
then determine how to play from there so
this kind of position and I'm not saying
it's like a huge advance for white or
anything but it seems like white is the
only one who can mess around for now I I
do like this chain I was wondering about
this change of structure I do kind of
like it for black because whites white
has only a few options here yeah in
terms of improving the position the
d-pawn isn't really going anywhere
though because the Knight only four is
awkward and that d-pawn is actually
defending White's Knights otherwise
Knights need outposts right yep without
that pawn the knights will just get
kicked back and and who knows where
they're going to end up the other option
for white is to play C3 at some point
but
um I don't even want to do that it just
feels wrong
yeah it feels wrong because it opens up
the Bishops and we know that Bishops
like to be
um like open lines yeah uh and the other
thing about this is that black is not
forced to take right it's true black
black can also wait and say well if you
take on B4 and you end up with a erect
Pawn structure well and I keep thinking
that black has long-term ideas to kick
the Knight rather than take it right
whether whether you need to play H6 or
not I don't know but kicking the Knight
opens up the bishop on B7 it forces it
or it allows the king to have an
entryway this is a very double-edged
position yeah and white is up that pawn
so even in the event of a rook trade I
like your 0.5 because I wasn't thinking
about that the outside pass Pawn
potential for black but if the Rooks
just disappeared white could push that c
Pawn without any repercussions right
then The Rook can't go attack the
remaining pawns there so it's a really
interesting Dynamic uh to have and this
is the thing right they see that as a
possibility and people at home of course
when you're commentating you can make
mistakes and then take it back and they
keep going the players have one
opportunity right you make a mistake you
lose the game against
Magnus so they have to visualize it and
have to accurately assess that position
right here where we're not even certain
and we see it's slightly better for
white but we get to make the moves on
the board see the eval bar and all those
things right this is uh probably
maybe next time you play the world
championship you know we'll uh we'll try
to I don't know actually we can't no
you'll never you won't have any of this
stuff you won't have uh any any of the
fun tools we have here so um okay just
remind everybody we got to this line
because of Robert's suggestion on the
Move Rook to E8 to actually trade the
Rooks and then aggressively bring this
Knight into E4 which the more we're
looking at this guys this is seeming
like a critical idea that could happen
right and perhaps something that Magnus
is thinking about right now as we can
see he is still on the clock yeah the
the thing is that all the lines that
we've just looked at yeah are only some
of the lines that are going through
Magnus and Beyond yes uh mind right now
and even though Jan is not the board
I'm pretty sure he's still thinking
about the position right probably right
he's he's probably still thinking about
the position in his uh rest area or
wherever he goes yeah by the way he has
not been at the board since he made his
move it's interesting he's been he's
been gone for for quite a while so
Robert I see you're deep in thought over
there I love it when the uh
the man the man whose name is a part of
part of Chess is thinking what will line
you got for us no I'm just trying to
figure out what white should do here
because yeah of course it's Black's turn
and
there's many options I see for black I'm
just trying to come with a concrete plan
for that why like ideas come more
naturally to me this position from black
side yeah right we know the Knight wants
to go to B4 we know we can take on F3 at
some point we can play Rook d8 so I see
all these options and I'm trying to
figure out if I do nothing right if I
just pass the turn what exactly is
White's Planet we've talked about Knight
C3 to E4 and we've also talked about
ideas
where the rook and E1 goes to C1 or the
A1 so it feels like a very complicated
position despite the Queens being off
there are no checkmates it's one of
these really richly complex situations
where you need to find a legitimate plan
not just make moves and hope that it
works out right I think that White's all
of White's pieces are perfectly placed
except for one yes we have that Knight
on B1 so White's plan is easy it is
really funny you say that because if we
could just grab that Knight and put it
on e4 right much better like white is
just much better so that's a really
fascinating point of all the struggles
that white has so sorry continue so so
white has basically two approaches here
let's say after Magnus makes a move yeah
we'll go back we'll go back to this line
with Brook da just yeah just to have
something
um white either plays an ic3 and
calculates the consequences of Knight
c3904 like we were just doing yeah in a
similar position or why it goes for a
long-term plan and says the onus is on
you with black to come up with something
before I play C3 Knight C2 eventually D4
try to gain some uh some squares for my
knights in the center yeah uh the
downside of course is that C3 is a very
weakening move of the B3 and the D3
pawns since black has a light Square
bishop and in this case also Rook on d8
that barrels down on potentially on the
D3 Pawn
that is a double-edged sword the other
downside of this maybe is that after
Knight A3 maybe black has Knight B4
yeah you're constantly considering what
what happens in a position like this
right where the bishop pair versus the
knights and you can see the computer
likes it just based on the fact that
probably why he's losing a ton of time
and C2 is about to come under Fire or or
even A5 I would I would definitely
consider A5 here just great pass Pawn as
as fast as you can okay yeah this Knight
on B1 in the game you know it's a
struggle for it because at Knight A3
it's a long journey to play that pawn
push and then bring the Knight back to
C2 so as I look at this I really want to
play Knight C3 is the principal way to
play but with Knight B4 as the immediate
response you come up with uh an exact
plan well what about that idea you guys
were mentioning earlier the idea of of
C4 is it was it dismissed because after
Rook to d8 all the points you made about
the d-pawn being weak would mean that
let's say 93 and
well here I really do think black black
benefits from playing Knight before yes
the more we look at this the the harder
it seems not to just put the Knight on
B4 C3 is forever off the agenda because
D3 would fall anyway but one reason I
don't like this Rook d8 move I started
not to like it because it it gives the
white the option
um and this is specifically only after
Rook date of Bishop to A5
ah okay interesting and I don't like
that for Blackberry much because now
let's say the root goes to E8
uh and white plays let's say Knight B to
D2 so now why solved that issue of the
night yeah and now if black plays night
before it's still an option but it lost
time compared to the other versions We
saw where
um uh where white took on B4 here yeah
we can even get Robert's line here where
you're trading on EA putting the Knight
on e4 or or even taking here yeah yeah
definitely those those things are an
option
I mean if tonight gets out from B1 in
this kind of manner then it's clear that
white is doing well and it's funny
Bishop A5 such an awkward Square you
don't get a bishop there very often but
because of Black's Pawn structure A6 and
B5 those pawns are in light squares the
bishop needs to dive into the dark
squares so Bishop A5 actually might be
an idea for white at some point but if
it doesn't come with Tempo you may be
allowing Knight F4 something like that
and then white needs to keep an eye on
the king side that's a good point I'll
just show it on the board real quick not
because it's necessarily devastating but
Knight F4 does come with tactics on H3
with the bishop spying the F3 Knight so
let alone the the optical pressure you
can just see before you with the Knight
and Bishop maybe ganging up on G2 so
that's
that's a fun little idea to keep in mind
so again Magnus Magnus using his time
here almost almost level on the clock
they are thanks Yoda yeah one move which
I
I've come to like a little bit is the
move H6
little
uh well we're about to see something H6
a fancy little little waiting move
hold the G5 Square maybe prepare G5 yeah
it maybe prepares you five it gives the
king some lift potentially that's not
very relevant right now but you never
know when a background back rank issue
might come into play and it also would
fit in nicely with F5 someday if that
comes to be
um because F5 weakens G5 like Robert
pointed out earlier
it that's the downside of it but H6
covers G5 it felt like a Magnus move but
no he goes for Rook C8 Rook C8 okay well
it's clear that if and then I guess
captured on B4 ever The Rook on C8 will
be putting pressure on the C2 Pawn so
that's why Magnus he preamps it all
right yeah let's get this ready yeah
although Knight C3 does feel like it
should be Jan's Choice as a response and
after Knight to B4 white can continue by
defending this Pawn on C2
perhaps with rookie to C1 yeah Robert's
Rook where he likes it but I I don't
feel like this this Rook on A1 it is an
open file but that pawn on A6 is so well
protected I I think the e-file is a bit
more relevant than the a file because
the Rooks haven't been traded yeah yeah
interesting so here you would say Rook
ac1
and you're keeping the idea of Knight E4
aggressively on the table
this this is a very likely option it's
very logical for white
um the most concrete way and he actually
has a clear plan now Knight E4 and the
question is how does Magnus react to
this does he play F5 or does he drop the
bishop back to f8 right at some point
either before or after Knight to E4
um but I would be very tempted to to at
some point play F5 because I really
don't want that Knight coming to you in
in the center yeah yeah so let's say we
gave white a free turn and then I did
come to E4 right The Bishop's gonna drop
back we'll make this move or something
the bishop because the 94 Bishop f8 is
what's the exact plan for why is like a
follow-up
that's a good question I was going to
say we're back to the pieces looking
good but it's not all about looking good
unless we're talking about you guys well
part of the reason I ask is because you
know of course that's what's going
through heads 94 and we know that's what
white wants to accomplish and once white
accomplish that it should be good for
white yeah I'm just trying to figure out
the plan well should black be afraid of
anything like this I think it's
difficult to come up with a plan but
there is a move that certainly comes to
mind and the move is D4 right
um
which just concretely works out here
that after C takes D4
Knight takes D4 the C2 Pawn is defended
and white is very happy to have traded
off those problems because the C5 Pawn
is objectively more valuable upon than
D3 pawn it gives black more space and
here it feels like white has suddenly
some space for his Knights right
um
he might also now have the the plan of
taking on B4 I was just going to say
that you take you can't play C3 before
that because of the fork on D3 but you
can't take care and then play C3 and
it's sometimes it's a bit difficult to
decide if you want to give up the two
Bishops right um against two Knight's
advantage but here the Knight is so good
on B4 and so annoying to deal with yeah
that I think white is happy to get rid
of it to play C3 and then yeah the
knights in the center are actually very
very dangerous they can hop into the F5
D6 they're they control a lot of squares
centralized Knights typically can
can counterbalance the bishop pair
but the more we look at it more feels
like it's inevitable if that Knight
comes to B4 it's inevitable that white
will have to take it at some point
because it's too much of a unicorn most
likely to let it be there
yeah okay well we're still uh we're
still waiting for yawn to respond to his
move and uh we're
we're going to keep analyzing this
position the more I look at this the
more I'm I'm with you guys that feels
like aggressively going for this plan is
going to force
Force the lines the way the white wants
I think there's at least a
small chance that we see the line that
we were sort of mentioning before in a
similar position with Knight C3 Knight
B4 Rook ac1 right Bishop takes F3
G takes F3 F5 I think there's at least
some chance that this happens
yeah we looked at this line
more than more than 15 minutes ago so if
it happens on the board you saw it here
first
um
but uh
how would you evaluate the long-term
chances for both sides in the same game
it feels like
feels like a win for white to me that
the bishop pairs off the board despite
the double pawns but maybe you disagree
sorry I was just looking at the board I
was wondering if the Rook is on d8
rather than C8 because uh is Uncle enemy
of Magnus left that on the d8 Square
like we were talking about oh it is on
d8 actually the the ggt so this happens
actually from time to time when you
slide the pieces
the sensor
makes you think it's on a different
square but that Rook is actually on d8
okay well back to the drawing board
everybody now we're thinking about
Bobby's Bishop A5 idea again yeah
um yeah that's an interesting turn of
events
well um Brooke is on deal well the thing
is that at least some of the positions
we analyzed are quite similar and
relevant even yeah in this the ideas are
quite similar yep but yeah now white has
a very obvious choice of Bishop A5 as
well as Knight C3 both those moves uh
are the first ones to to jump out in my
mind you know a move I almost played
when you first suggested this was Rook
D7 and I'm aware of the the potential
drawbacks of disconnecting the Rooks in
the back rank but the reason I did is
because I wanted to avoid any other
forcing lines because the moment you put
the bishop there now your knight F4
ideas is a real is a real issue right
and I can't prevent that with G3 without
this Knight becoming tender to tactics
on F3 so yeah is there anything to that
this was the move I wanted to play I
think that that might be better no it's
not um it's definitely an option I'm not
sure how I feel about the Knight F4 idea
because let's say white plays Knight B
to D2 yeah this was your move and Knight
F4 certainly comes to mind yeah but
there are this is more of a move trying
to control white rather than trying to
threaten white because there are no
threats here okay
um night the knights defend each other
so there is no Knight takes H3 Bishop
takes everything stuff right
um but you can't really play G3 you
can't kick the Knight out so easily
because Knight takes H3 yep at least so
easily there is certainly an option and
I would be very worried with black
um after Knight E4
okay yeah interesting because the bishop
really has to drawback you don't want to
let white capture that Bishop okay
Robert what were you about to add to
them no I was looking at this position
and seeing that once that Knight
established stuff on e4 the Knight F4 it
looks good but it's not threatening
anything and I'm going back to those
ideas with H6 F5 and maybe we can expand
on the kickstand what I love about The
Rook being on D7 is that Rook could end
up on say G7 or absolutely if we start
pushing those pawns forward and I'm not
really doing it with the intent of a
purely attacking yeah but I'm just
trying to kick your pieces out of the
center yeah and then say well now that
I've played H6 and F5 maybe G5 is next
and my 9 F4 can't help in an attack yeah
I like that I like that I have I have a
very weird feeling and usually my
feeling about this is wrong but Bobby's
Bobby Bobby's got feelings what are your
what are your spiders I have a weird
feeling that I've seen that position
that we just had on the board before
really but usually I'm usually I'm just
wrong about this in my we just got a
little bit of revealing into fabi's prep
um foreign
because it looks very familiar after 95
Black's Rook naturally has to go to E7
there and
not not here but in the line at the end
of the line where we okay so hold on
I'll get there with Knight bd2 and
Knight F4 Knight E4 Bishop Cafe Bishop
Jeff fade because it's it's what Robert
said is true if you give black time h6f5
is coming
and and that's going to be annoying
white doesn't want that Knight Kickback
again yeah it just got to the center it
wants to stay there uh the question is
what can white do in the meantime
um why there's a few options one is 95
attack The Rook but that suddenly
becomes super concrete Rook E7 and
things are hanging for both sides yeah
and now F5 is even more of a threat
because G2 is hanging at the end of
these lines and C5 looks like it's
unprotected and it can be captured but
then G2 can be taken right back and you
see the evaluation dip because this is
not a good look for White's King yeah
wow okay so
the more I'm looking at that line the
less I want to play Bishop A5 and that's
just me
um
I kind of want to go back to testing out
Robert's initial aggressive intent to go
for a knight to C3 Knight to B4 and find
some way to get this guy to E4 once I
decide how we're protecting this guy but
this is why it's important for black to
keep both Rooks on the board in
particular The Rook on A8 because in
these series events we've been
discussing right the bishop takes an F3
the Knight is trying to take on C2 and
then the A6 pawns left undefended but
with that Rook still on A8 then it's
like this the whole point is you you
have these options now because the the
pawn is still protected yes and yeah
yeah I probably wouldn't rush the
capture on F3 but it is available as
probably what I was saying earlier so
I I like the decision to keep the Rooks
on the board rookie 8 very tempting to
go the fully open file but it's good
restraint to stick to d8 and leave the
decision making up to Young yeah
yeah this is this is a difficult choice
for young
um because Rook data is a provocation of
Bishop egg five Magnus definitely
uh thought about this move calculated it
um
it is along with Knight C3 the most
natural way for white to proceed here
right
uh I and I don't think I see any other
moves which I like besides Bishop 5 or
Knight C3 because if white plays Knight
A3 we mentioned this idea before yep I
don't think there's a good response to
an id4 yeah this just feels so good the
more we looked at the transition here
for those who might have missed that
analysis earlier the more we just love
this for black this one is even better
yeah now after Knight B1
um black and play Rook ac8 along with
the A5 idea which I I feel you I was
just gonna say I feel like you're an
original idea of just push them baby but
even Rook ac8 of course hitting C2 is
enough to convince us that this is ugly
so
so I think I think Knight A3 is off of
our candidate moves list
um I'm I'm kind of expecting that he'll
play Bishop A5 because I don't think
that he will feel like there's any
advantage to be found after an ic39
before
and here this is the most ambitious way
um it's hard to say what magnus's uh
intentions after that Rook D7 rookie
eight both moves yeah both are possible
are extremely sensible I mean I think I
think this one's a little better but
sorry just kidding I actually do like
rookie seven I mean we've talked about
this a lot right and Fabiano explained
it in his video series which I watched
by the way you watched our video series
his videos here now don't don't our this
if you ever if you ever watch content
that I do I just go nuts yeah you were
there I muted all the parts where you
were talking you did a great series but
the point I was going to make was you
talked about you know genuinely excited
I was yeah he's watching the video sorry
now you're fine go ahead the one that's
gonna make us you talked about sometimes
you know there's decisions to be made
yeah leaving your opponent with the most
challenges is even if objectively the
other move is better right if they're
relatively close in strength leave your
opponent with more options especially as
the clock starts ticking that's where
you know you really make your mark and
you try to win games so I think in a
position like this not letting the
position become clear does play to
Black's favorite in this particular
position because white is up a pawn has
some squares that the pieces want to go
to yeah but even once you're there in
that Rook D7 line so what we're looking
at with H6 F5 G5 available at some point
I think it leaves white with more to
think about in terms of danger even if
white for the moment might be slightly
better according to the end well and I
remember that discussion we had in the
video and probably you said I mean as
far as that that theme that Robert
started with creating more opportunities
for your opponent to go wrong or out
think themselves you said probably
Nobody Does that better in the world
than Magnus Carlson right as far as
allowing his opponents the opportunity
to maybe misstep right I think the
question is here Rook D7 is a more risky
move at least riskier looking yeah and
there's more for black to consider if he
chooses this move yeah so does Magnus
really want to
start such a sharp fight in the first
game with the black pieces in a position
where he knows he's certainly not better
right he's the one who has to equalize
this we have action we have action by
the way for those who are wondering yeah
we have a super sexy monitor behind us
it's awesome it allows us to see things
instantly and so sorry just love it okay
we're going to bring it back up here
let's do it Knight to C3 Knight to C3
not
Bishop A5 wow okay well
all right we obviously have to unpa
unpack that I'm being told that we are
we are due for a very quick break so
obviously Magnus Carlson will be will be
taking a think on how he wants to deal
with Knight to C3 all of you will be
eagerly rushing to get whatever snacks
whatever you need at the break because
you don't want to miss a single moment
of the action especially with Robert and
Bobby breaking things down like they are
so Chestnut comes coverage of the 2021
feed a World Chess Championship which is
brought to you by coinbase continues
when we return
[Music]
yeah yeah ah one two one two chess.com
y'all know what we do Harry Matt come on
up top come on turn me up come on check
it on Yo every time I rhyme you see my
swag evolving we bout to send this one
out to Magnus Carlson I'm spitting
lyrics and I'm blessing your air sign
became a grab Master for 13 years young
four months and 27 days if we be getting
exact I break it down with the freeze
the rats uh second youngest GM ever at
that time so Imma have to explain while
kicking these rap rhymes ah I see me
going wild for days most known for his
position no style of play getting pieces
in position and then he's taking strong
aim grinding competitors down up in them
long games a pragmatic player who always
managed to win without a significant
opening advantage and with these raps
I'll be spitting strong on the song
defeating Reign the champion If This
Were Nothing and all the scary man I'm
here to get props on the word scene but
came the world champion in 2013 yeah and
y'all know he's about to do it again
foreign
number one in the world since June 2011.
I mean to say his chess game is heaven
uh and I'll be spitting the fiery lyrics
Just to skull mines the highest chest
rating of all time
2881 wait a minute hold on no that's
crazy sign hmac I'm a penny they fearing
my flow defending this title so many
years in a row uh every time I'm ripping
people know I spit the sickest sound
2014 yo that's when they won the Triple
Crown and imma break it down now while I
speak got classical lyrics I spit it
rapid it's a mental Blitz ah I'm the
witness for y'all you know the reason
125 games he's been unbeaten yeah for
2018 the 2020 going peep the streak and
know that he's not weak I'm about to do
it for y'all with the strongest freeze
these other rappers in the game just won
the bees and when they rapping I'll be
laughing cause it's comedy so check
Magnus against Yonder Palm to chase
let's go
yeah yeah come on come on let's go
[Music]
chess.com's coverage of the 2021 v-day
World Championship is brought to you by
coinbase whether you're an experienced
Trader or just looking to make your
first crypto purchase coinbase has you
covered visit coinbase.com chess to get
five dollars in free Bitcoin just for
verifying your account today
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
lighting and audio
crushed through the top of the show
all right
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
want to play chess online or learn how
to improve join us at the number one
chess destination in the world chess.com
with thousands of people playing at any
moment you'll quickly find a game with
someone at your level whether you're a
beginner or a Grandmaster chess.com
makes learning fun and easy sharpen your
tactics with puzzles and enhance your
strategy with our lessons by top Masters
learn from your own games with our easy
to use analysis tool chess.com has
everything you need to take your game to
the next level signing up is free and
easy join chess.com today
[Music]
in case you didn't see our partners at
coinbase are sponsoring chess.com's
coverage of the 2021 v-day world
championship and boy are we thankful
whether you're an experienced Trader
been doing this for years or just
thinking about making your first crypto
purchase coinbase is the place to go
visit coinbase.com chess and get five
dollars in free Bitcoin when you sign up
and verify your account today
thank you
[Music]
want to hold a massive chess tournament
with dozens of clubs or hundreds of
players or maybe a small chess
tournament with local but competitive
clubs with Club Arenas you can
Club Arenas allow for tournaments of any
size with any number of clubs and
players customize the arena with any
time control with standard chess or mini
chest variants and with any starting
position you want Club Arenas are the
most flexible tournament format on
chess.com try one out today
[Music]
foreign
am I supposed to feel ready but
I guess
when you prepare for such a major event
you always
feel like you could could do more but I
guess we are doing some insane amount of
work
I hope we we get to be you know
ready enough
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
very Universal player if you want to be
successful and you can't rely on the
information alone
so it's
they would like to you know to say that
for example a player a royal Chamberlain
would be the best intuition ever is
speak hello child but
I guess he also had you know
he he had to calculate a lot yeah and
for example today
you could try to just playing his style
sometimes it will be very costly to to
your performance I think yeah the
intuition is always good but
I mean sometimes you basically can't
choose the move
because of your calculation or
evaluation and you need to for example
sometimes you are giving like two
similar opportunities you you you get to
pick one and okay probably hear the
intuition comes
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
chess.com's coverage of the 2021 v-day
World Championship is brought to you by
our partners at coinbase whether you're
just thinking about making your first
crypto purchase just wanting to learn a
little bit more about the crypto
industry or if you've been doing this
thing for years and you're an
experienced Trader coinbase is the place
to be visit coinbase.com chess and get
five dollars in free Bitcoin just for
signing up and verifying your account
today we really encourage you to do so
go check them out at coinbase.com
foreign
[Music]
welcome back everybody this is day one
of the 2021 fide World Chess
Championship thank you for being with us
here no matter where you are tuning in
from on the world wide web chess is uh
chess is where it's at for the next few
weeks and we're happy that you're that
you're with us here so guys we've had
we've had several moves made on our
break when we when we first
left it Knight to C3 was on the board
Magnus didn't take too long to play
night before which was this was the line
we've been analyzing so we'll continue
to go there just makes a lot of sense
Rook e to C1 that was the big moment
which had been Robert's suggestion right
to keep the Rook on A1 and sacrifice
controller with the e-file for that
long-term pressure there your thoughts
Bobby because you had highlighted you
felt that at this stage in the game it
might have been more critical to keep
fighting for the e-files so your initial
your initial reaction to that yeah I
still feel that way but there is
definitely a point to be made for The
Rook on A1
um right you can't get rid of it
so blacks work will most likely be
stayed on A8 for a while right stuck
um well actually we've seen the game
that he played Rook a to C8 so so I was
gonna say it's supposed to be stuck but
on that cue it well so let's remind
everybody the line one of the lines we
looked a lot at was this idea of taking
on F3 right and then playing and then
playing F5 which was a possibility for
black even still it takes away the E4
Square there is no Rook on the E file so
you don't have to worry about that so
that was an option but not one that
Magnus wanted instead he keeps the
bishop and plays Rook ac-8 Robert well
first of all I agree with mag's decision
to keep the bishop on the board yes
leaves things more complicated because
if you take an F3 now Jan knows exactly
what the dynamic is going to be right
it's clarified there's always the option
to take on F3 unless that Knight moves
out the way so right it's a good
decision to keep that now Knight E2
caught me by surprise because we kept
talking about bringing the knight from
B1 to E4 yep but he brings the Knight
back to E2 and it's not entirely clear
what his initial plan is yeah but the
Knight can swing to G3 and maybe into F5
at some point I'm
thinking that goes for an attack but the
move 92 itself is curious to me my first
thought when I saw it was Fabiano's
mentioning earlier of the move d4 right
because we talked about we obviously
looked at Knight E4 in a lot of
variations it's the most centralized
position but you guys both on separate
occasions made the point that once you
put the Knight there where are we going
now right and it looks good but what's
next and Fabiano's idea of D4 is
completely off the agenda as long as the
Knight would be loose there so my first
thought when I saw it was maybe young
once wants your D4 idea I don't feel
like D4 is going to work out okay
um
like let's say black makes a passing
move like H6 okay which might actually
be a good move right and uh White plays
D4 right
and
maybe you take first I actually I would
like to keep that Bishop because the
Rook The Rook moved from A8 so if blood
Bishop captures F3 then A6 is very
likely to fall because white can always
capture
although I think if we go through the
line directly right it doesn't black at
the C2 Pawn so if you play Bishop F3
takes C takes D4 uh are you gonna start
with Knight takes D4 I think Knight
takes before yeah well Bishop B4 that's
where I was going oh you're a bishop D2
exactly okay so I don't see the move
after Knight takes D4
I don't see an obvious move for black
and pretty much regardless of what black
does why he's going to take on B4 play
C3 and try to Target that a pawn and and
remember white is white is up upon and
if that a pawn Falls then that could
already be be game over yeah um there
there might still be some tactical
issues because there works on C8 and d8
are there's some pins there so there's
some Rook takes D4 tactics right uh but
in any case I don't feel like like
taking on F3 is what black wants so
after h64 let's I was just about to pop
it Magnus has played the move Knight to
C6 by the way
um so we can go back to your line I just
wanted to make it known that there is a
move on the board and this idea so we're
seeing curious night moves right they
always talk about the mysterious Rook
moves guys some mysterious this is a
very a very interesting move yeah it
means that either Magnus was avoiding D4
right or or avoiding Bishop takes B4 but
I don't think he was avoiding Bishop
takes before so probably he saw D4 in
some lines and didn't quite like it the
question is where is the Knight going
from C6 because the Knight blocks the
bishop it's not ideally placed there so
it obviously is temporary you're saying
has another destination routing station
maybe maybe he actually wants to trade
knights with Knight to E5 that's that's
my my thought now and I was about to say
actually if Knight G3 which is a movie
talk about like why isn't that going to
E2 then Knight E5 it actually could
force an opposite colored Bishop
position after trading on D5 because
Japan on B2 is loose and if you play
Bishop C3 to challenge the bishop on E5
then I could take on G3 get to an
opposite colored bishop and which
doesn't mean a draw necessarily but they
have the tendency to be uh holdable even
down upon or two yeah that would be an
extremely drawish end game so uh that
would probably be a safe haven for
Magnus I I just want to mention that
after Knight G3 the line that Robert
just
uh told us 95 1965 Bishops 85 it's not
forced to play Bishop C3 there's the
move Knight F5 Ah that's 1400 but that
might that might just lead to another
type of obscillary Bishop end game
because after Bishop takes it was gonna
say there's double Forks here yeah
that's 97 King to let's say f8 Knight
takes C8 and even if just Rook takes C8
that fork is not going away that Bishop
will will win one of the Rooks and
that's a good lesson by the way because
if you take on A1 or C1 right away which
is still fine in this position you give
white a free move next so leaving that
fork on both Rooks means you're going to
take that next regardless and that
limits whites options yeah it's a
fantastic point and although again I
thought you were gonna highlight another
idea to guard it is also Rook 82 at some
point you don't you don't you can keep
the Rook on the a file hold the pawn
right if you're just but there it's
looking better and better for black I
feel like Rook A2 would be met by C4 or
something and yeah here here black might
actually think about starting to play
for an adventure because the All Blacks
pieces just look so good C4 the pin on
the the pawn the bishop on D2 hanging
right uh white cells Bishop A5 but
regardless this is not what white wants
black yeah uh black is certainly not
going to be worse in this case
yeah makes sense
um so the question is what will white do
now and one move which kind of jumped to
mind for me is Bishop to F4
because when you have that two Bishop's
advantage
um your opponent wants to get rid of one
of the Bishops so in this case black
would I think be obligated to put that
move that Bishop back probably to f8 to
avoid a trade of Bishops because a trait
of Bishops would would mean a certain
Advantage for white maybe not a huge
Advantage but some sort of edge yeah and
it looks like Jan put his Bishop in E3
so he's as he moved playing with more
restraint and plays Bishop E3 around the
watch about four offices interesting we
have a we have another move good call
and both sides are kind of doing this
right they're avoiding trades supporting
conflict yeah and they're not trying to
make this position liquidate and that
leaves difficult decisions for both
players and Bishop E3 there is pressure
on the C5 Pawn which is well defended
for now I think most importantly the
bishop leaves the D file because you
were just talking about a variation with
move C4 now there are no concerns about
C4 winning any material in fact C4 would
just give away a pawn right now well and
again it's also renewing the idea of D4
and the reason I was on that idea
earlier is because of what Bobby said
that you know just key to the structure
in general is blacks sorry White's extra
Pawn but White's inability to use that
pawn right so I don't think it's it's uh
an accident that a lot of attention
being centered around white changing
that trading off this Pawn would would
free up the idea that Robert mentioned
very early on in the show which is to
use the extra Palm with the c Pawn Yeah
that's a good point the D3 Pawn is
actually a sort of weakness right right
it doesn't look like it because it's
well defended but if white structure
changes in any way with the c Pawn that
d-pawn becomes a weakness so I also see
some sort of idea I wanted to mention
with the move Bishop E3 I think that
eon's idea is after Knight E5
uh if Magnus were to play 95.
a trade would be good for for black not
good in the sense that black is better
or anything but I think the bishop to
the center I think black would equalize
pretty comfortably after a trade
um but this opens up the idea of an id2
yeah and this is a very harmonious setup
the Knight could come to E4 but it might
not want to yet and he still has that
idea of D4 that you mentioned so the 985
is sort of it looks active it's in the
center it's not really hitting anything
it's not right putting any pressure on
White's position it's a day of of
looking good both for both you guys you
guys look great but also for the knights
they're in the center they look good but
you can't do anything with them right
it's a very interesting rerouting in the
pieces yeah Beyond because we were often
and players generally do this they take
the most active approach right A5
attacking The Rook then I get the night
out to a square like C3 but he brought
his Knight on C3 back to E2 and then
played Bishop E3 so he's just keeping
his options open and and I really like
that and if D4 happens then that feels
like a more real extra Pawn because uh
the pawn A6 is going to be a Target the
bishop 1 B7 of course will stay there
and it's hard to pile up more pressure
on that side of the board but the more
squares you can get for your knight yep
that favorable for white
yeah I like the way that Yawn is I agree
I'm feeling better about White's
position but I I also think that is a
result of magnus's last move which
doesn't look like a great move to me
Knight to C6 yeah
that was surprising it's both a bit
unnatural and I feel in this case not
that good
um I think he had a clear idea play 95
to trade off some pieces right and get
closer to equality but it feels like
it's just artificial to take that night
from an active position where it doesn't
obstruct a bishop and put it into a
slightly less less active position where
it blocks Black's Bishop
it'll be interesting to see whether we
get this lined as well I know sometimes
we talk The Meta of the match Beyond
just the X's and O's of this game be
curious because like you said this is
something that both sides seem prepared
to play even though it's a unique line
and maybe maybe uh Magnus isn't getting
what he wanted won't be going back for
it
so
Knight C6 Bishop B3 the only other
outside idea I thought about this Knight
coming back was is there a weird idea of
the night going all the way back to ba
to make sure that A6 is held I don't
think it stops D4 so yeah probably not
but it doesn't stop D4 and no yeah black
Black's compensation was based okay
someone on the his two Bishops but also
on the activity of his pieces right you
take that knight from D5 where it was
and you put it on B8 and you lose half
of your compensation right right and and
concretely deformed don't undevelop your
pieces that's what you're trying to
don't undevelop your pieces generally I
really didn't like the move Knight to C6
Yeah the more we look at it
it's as you were saying you take away
your activity here now you have to find
another rebuttal to this move here so so
funny question yeah what if black plays
Knight B4 yeah right back I was gonna
ask it I I was gonna say I'll go for the
move I've wanted I I want to make it
work so let's let's try it but now I
haven't I have two ideas one is Bishop
E4 I don't know if this works concretely
but it's certainly an idea and the other
one is simply to play C4 yeah I thought
C4 would have been a good counter shot
the question is B Tech C4 wide world
play Rook takes C4 so now C2 is hanging
but C3
C3 and there's not a fork on on D3
because you moved the correct Rook yes
it comes back to Robert's point that
another advantage of not having the
Rooks on E1 and C1 is that C3 is an
opportunity on these lines this is and
if you put the Knight on D3 it looks
like it's active it's attacking stuff
Rook C2 that Knight is yes it's active
it's also getting trapped
actively trapped it has to go back to B4
but it's part of my life if you're
retreating here then of course black is
not doing so well so yeah C4 it's a
movie you want to play but considering
your Pawn down and then it becomes uh a
pawn that's unopposed for white that
will make the advantage felt so
I'm feeling I'm feeling uh well the
question is after D4 I'm still
interested in this position okay so
night before D4 so let's say we do your
Bishop E4 idea yeah so this is a huge
threat suddenly on the board Knight Tech
C2
um but there's dtec C5 and I I don't
know if that quite works out for black
Bishop takes C5
Bishop takes C5 Rook takes C5 and after
simply C3 Oh I thought I could just put
a knight on D4 but well C2 might drop oh
okay CD drops about A6 drops but yeah
okay here's is a big problem right if
you go Knight C2 you're only attacking
my Rook or welcoming it to capture the
pawn on Ace and if you go to D3 there's
even Rook D1 ideas because your back
rank is not protected very well so you
get out of the immediate attack now the
Knight can't capture on B2 A6 is still a
Target if I can attack your Bishop your
knight feels stranded on D3 and could be
lost so this would be a terrible turn of
events for Magnus of course we don't
expect that to happen it's unraveling
Bobby just sat up a little bit you get
excited over here how you doing over
here yeah oh I'm always excited
so but I still feel like that night
before move is is an interesting one it
might I just keep coming back to it in
my mind that maybe there's something
after D4 I feel like there's some way
that black can get a decent playable
position there
um maybe maybe black just takes on D4
there but regardless Knight before is
not the only option black has here it's
it's just something that it's kind of a
funny thing you know you yeah move the
night back and you go right back right
sometimes yeah one thing worth exploring
after Knight to B4 in this line we're
just talking about D4 is what if I now
take on F3 like it's available and after
you take back and I take on D4 Knight
takes D4 it's like I'm one move away
from by kicking your knight out of D4
and then winning the C2 Pawn Yeah but I
guess Bishop E5 can met exactly by C3
this move is coming every time too slow
yeah this is this is a really
really you know if we really back up and
appreciate how we got here right because
we're learning along with everybody else
that it makes you it makes you look at
rookie to C1 with a little more depth to
it right Robert in terms of not just the
idea you pointed out fundamentally
keeping the Rook on the a file but
it's a really key point being made here
right in a lot of these critical lines
that white has the ability to push the C
Pawn Magnus made a move he played Knight
to E7 Knight to E7 I'm trying to
compliment you Robert but you're looking
to be stone-faced oh I was calculating
okay sometimes you have that look where
you're looking at me but you're not
looking at me I'm looking through you
okay 97. I'm so glad we have Favi in the
middle of us this time you know I feel a
little more protected from the
the glare okay
it's not there's no bad intentions here
bad all right 97 so Bobby what's your
what's your thought seeing another
another mysterious night maneuver well
this one is is a bit less mysterious the
night has a lot of nice squares it can
jump to one is F5
I was going to say one is D5 but it did
kind of come from there right three
moves
you went from D5 to B4 to C6 to E7 there
you go I like it we dancing just trying
to finish the nice tour finish the night
store right he's Magnus is playing a
different game with his head someone
challenged him it's like one of those
things where you say hey slip meow into
the sentence Magnus if you slip a
night's tour into one of your games it's
another million dollars I do like the
boat though because D4 now you have to
think about that for quite a while with
your movement F5 D4 definitely you have
to consider Knight F5 I think it might
just directly run into it and might not
be a good move for that reason right
um because now you don't want to lose
the bishop
uh in this version where you have to
also play F Type c3m yeah just to show
mess up your watch you can't take his
black takes would check inner inner miso
and and that would be bad so so white
doesn't really want to do this but a
move which another funny move that comes
to mind after 97 is Bishop F4 I know I
keep saying the same move and so instead
of uh instead of D4 but here here can't
we take F3 right instead of deep instead
of D oh I'm sorry okay
okay I like I said this previous move
and you haven't played Bishop E3 which
is probably a better move but maybe now
the bishop can't Retreat so this force
is a trans really good point just to
show everybody what Bobby's talking
about he mentioned Bishop F4 instead of
Bishop E3 but the big difference is that
black could save the bishop opening the
rook and actually this bishop under four
where's his future so that's actually a
really a really good point that although
there's something interesting in that
line for black so if we go which line uh
the line we're just looking at with
Bishop report here yeah Bishop E3 okay
in the game yeah 97 and Bishop before I
can take on F3
I can then take on F4
and then I could put a rook on the sixth
rank because my Knight's not in the way
so I protect A6 and then I'm swinging
over to F6 or H6 and now it's clear that
your king side pollens are a problem
earlier it wasn't such a big deal
because it's hard for black to get to
those pawns yeah now I'm going right
there and that Knight on E7 could end up
going H4 if you're not careful and there
are many options for the E7 to a D4 to
H4 and so on so I think that black has
very good compensation there right this
is one of those weird positions where
White's up a pawn but you wouldn't know
it by looking at the board it looks like
black is up a bullet yeah I think I
think that's entirely correct that
this material balance is good for white
yep
um but the piece placement and the pawn
structure that happened on the king side
is definitely not good for white if
things were a bit different if that and
I don't have four
or somewhere else because now it's
extremely misplaced it has nowhere to go
and it's also donkey yeah
so if it were somewhere else I would say
maybe white would have good chances for
an advantage but here that and also what
Robert mentioned the Knight on E7 is
coming to F5 maybe to H4 maybe it's D4
but in any case it's going to start
attacking a lot of stuff yeah so yeah
black should be
black should have compensation enough
for equality in this position what's so
interesting is it's all about this A6
Pawn yeah a lot of these decisions from
both sides The Rook staying on A1 this
move Knight C60 E7 yes the Knight can
reach out to F5 but in what's critical
is that you can protect that A6 Pawn
because the rook in A1 is active on a
starting square a working eight would
just be passively defending so if you
could lift The Rook to the sixth Rank
and just keep control of the entire rank
yep that would be a very good turn of
events for Magnus
so fascinating yep um
well John's on the clock again uh
going going back back into a deep think
I I do think Knight D2 is also a
sensible move here it looks a bit
passive you're kind of moving on your
last three rounds your initial that was
your initial thought after after 95 it
it's it's certainly the most sensible
move here doesn't make quite as much
sense because black can you know do nine
to five but here Knight of five Bishop
F4 was I still saved that Bishop so well
I like this because I think it avoids
Roberts Robert's key line where the
bishop was taking on F3 which I think
the more we looked at that position I
feel like 97
is has a sneaky idea right you almost
you almost are thinking when the Rooks
are gone you're never going to take away
the protection of the A6 Pawn but not
not in a line like right Robert just
showed where the Rook comes to the sixth
ring although Knight D2 you can play
Knight D5 we were joking about the
nightstore lives but I think I take away
your Bishop's options right you can't go
to F4 now I have two pieces you don't
take away all my options you can go up
there but then you're you're asking me
to play F6 and G4 at some point you know
you're you're welcome it's actually it
actually could happen that way because
the bishop does have the potential here
and yeah no you're right you're right
that that is one one downside is 95.
um another downside potential of 92 is
also Bishop to E5 is pretty annoying to
deal with
because
now the E5 square is no longer protected
so white has to make some slightly
awkward Rook move yeah probably Rook A2
but it's a bit awkward to do this and
now like Robert mentioned Knight D5 is
an option Knight D5 and Knight B4 is
even stronger now because you have the
Rook here wow what a what a funny turn
of events it would be just to to see
that night
bouncing around the board and ultimately
end up on its Square B4
um
okay so so we're not we're not thrilled
about this move back detail a funny idea
again this uh this is probably two
clever for its own good but if white
were to play Bishop G5 here
and if black plays F6 then Bishop F4 is
a slightly better version because the
Rook can't come right over there just to
show everyone the line that line that
Robert gave earlier
was critical well okay like still
possible for black but critical not just
that the Rook defended the pawn but that
The Rook had potential to put pressure
on these newly weak pawns so this would
not be the same in fact now maybe white
can get a little more aggressive because
this is the idea we didn't get into if
if white has the initiative we were
quickly doubling Brooks and the a pawn
becomes the the story yeah it's such a
good like demonstration of having a free
move isn't always a good thing yeah
especially with pawns right because
pawns can't move backwards so the F3
Pawn becomes safe when the black pawn is
on F6 that's
the how hard I try can never get those
pawns to move backwards the only
downside of Bishop G5
is that well black doesn't have to fall
into this idea I can play let's say H6
right and it's not really clear if you
gained anything from this whole maneuver
at all yeah maybe you should page four
we commit to this idea it's it's a bit
artificial but that doesn't mean it's
bad sometimes sometimes artificial is a
very bad thing right sometimes it's it's
not so bad but generally speaking I
don't think I would approach it like
this because it kind of feels like
like you're just spreading your pieces
too in too many random positions
to give the educational point on the
bishop hair Dynamic versus the two
knights is there is there ever a
scenario I'll start with you Robert
where white is just going to capture
here and try to try to get rid of the
Knight because this bishop can't seem to
find a home right so rather than trying
to re-maneuver it everywhere you make
the trade and and then try to centralize
your nights it just feels like you don't
have really good outposts for your
nights and if you try to so is that like
a factor you would weigh in your head
before you would support the bishop I
mean looking for where my Knights can go
right what weaknesses are on the board
and the weakness we keep talking about
with respect to Black's position is the
A6 Pawn right look look at that's the
pawn is on the rim of the board so there
are fewer options for the Knight to even
attack the pawn right and there's
nowhere you can feasibly go right so
where you make progress from there it
seems a little bit difficult and the
Bishops are actually pretty strong in
the position and then if I get the
bishop pair I keep mentioning this idea
of the F6 G5 and so on right give me
both Bishops right I'm pushing my pawns
right because Bishops Love Open Space
they can throw much more of the board
than Knights do and upon three squares
away from a knight dominates that Knight
so upon F6 against the nine F3 is
typically a good thing yeah it's an
educational point right weighing the
criteria of how would you when would you
go into an end game with Knights versus
Bishop one of them is do your Knights
have good Outpost squares do they have
permanent homes they can they can sink
themselves to but you don't really have
that in this structure if anything like
this happens you even if you got the
Knight to E4 he's not permanent there
because of all the things Robert's
talking about the aggressive intentions
that black has so sorry just snuck in a
free a free tip from Robert Hess right I
asked for a friend but secretly you know
educational the D4 move that's really
what it comes down yeah it will white be
able to get the D4 move in because then
maybe you do something that jurassicas
give up the bishop pair for against two
knights but I don't think you're going
to get D4 and Black's Rooks are so
perfectly situated in the event of a D4
move yeah
okay yeah I don't think that white wants
to give up that Bishop for the night uh
also because I mean Black's Bishops will
just tear across the board if that
Bishop gets to F6 for example this
bishop yeah like let's say Bishop G5 H6
the line that we just showed Bishop
takes E7 Bishop takes E7 that Bishop is
going to F6 a rook will be tied down to
it and you don't want to start tying
down your pieces to defense when you're
up a pawn so I think in this scenario
black is for sure not any worse right
um
but the question is what does white do
it's it's not an easy question to answer
yeah one other move which is maybe a
pretty natural move that came to mind
was Knight G3
um the Knight has to go somewhere and
maybe don't stop Knight F5 yeah stop
sign at five and maybe it'll go to E4 it
still has that option available to it
both of these Knights are hilarious all
right the night was on B4 which I'm
coming to D5 via E7 right and this
Knight is trying to go to E4 but it was
on B1 and then went to C3 could have
gone to E4 it said drops back to E2 and
it is a situation where you're waiting
to see what your opponent does because
you may make a decision trying to
counteract something and then you're
like that makes another weakness so it
is really interesting that both sides
have the ability to sit and wait because
there's no tension yeah no pawns are
attacking each other nothing's hanging
so Knight G3 looks perfectly reasonable
to me yeah that's that's the interesting
thing about well chess as a whole is
that when you look at all of whites
movies and all of blacks moves as a
singular thing
they look strange but they're not part
white is not just play in a game himself
he's playing against black so they're
both reacting to their to each other's
moves so although White's moves looks
look weird they all have a particular
particular idea on that move which was a
a reaction to What black did the
previous move right
so although it's like why would you play
Knight C3 E2 G3 to go to E4 well it's
because now Black Knight is on E7 versus
over it was so if a knight comes to E4
Black's Bishop can't drop back to f8
it's it's kind of minor
adjustments like that in each in the
position
the footwork of 2800 plus chess so glad
we have a guy like Fabiano with us to
make sure that uh to make sure that we
we get all that insight and uh
yeah this is this is awesome if you're
just tuning in Where Have You Been we
are in the middle of game one this is
the start of the 2021 v-day World Chess
Championship this is chess.com's
coverage it is brought to you by
coinbase we're going to be here every
day
um for the rest of our lives Bobby
doesn't know he's never going home we're
going to be doing this forever so okay
um just kidding we'll let you go with
something
um all right well uh 97 still has yawn
in a think he's he's twiddling his other
Black Knight he won a night he's
twiddling it
I just I'm just making an observation
well where are we going chess players do
tend to play with pieces and some are
off the board off the board yeah you
can't touch well there is a story yeah
who's the most irritating I want to ask
with the pieces off the board but no
one's watching the show so you can say
whatever you want go ahead there is a
story about Bobby Fischer who intended
to fiddle with a pawn
on the side of the board but he was once
playing a game in Sicilian and he didn't
realize that the pawn he was fiddling
with was actually his h-pawn
it wasn't on the sideboard he was
absent-mindedly thinking about the
position he was actually fiddling with
his h-pod and he realized at that point
that he had to make a move that was
catastrophic to his position when you're
castled in the Sicilian and your
opponent's pawns are on G4 F4 you start
playing like H6 or H5 right not a good
idea you open up the king side you get
made it yeah but he had to and uh and
that was that for that game wow that's a
fascinating story
I never knew that one I've never heard
that story so of the top players you
play be honest like I said there's
there's not tens of thousands of people
watching this who's the most irritating
body language just you know you don't
have to answer this question oh I'll
answer it oh here we go go for it a body
language yeah specifically body language
or like you know the little things like
what John's doing would you get
irritated if if you're sitting across
and trying to think on your turn if
someone's doing that I I mean I
I tried not to get irritated by some
players you get used to it at some point
but having played dozens of games
against Hikaru okay and Anish yeah oh
Anish I know that they
they have a lot of body language okay
sometimes it can get to you but you try
to block that photo block it out okay so
there you go you have it on record
Hikaru in a niche are uh are you know
body language that can get to you all
right there you go well I mean I love
how Robert tried to protect you there
you don't have to answer questions like
you don't have to answer Danny's
questions but you know I'm used to
contenting with you so I know that you
asked ridiculous things that one wasn't
that ridiculous no no it makes sense I
mean honestly it's I we've all played
over the board chess I've never played
your level or your level right but it's
you know you get nervous so sometimes
players do develop habits and ticks
sometimes you think it's intention they
do it sometimes they do it and like
people just have ticks right they're
they're expounding nervous energy so do
you have anything to do with the board
to kind of
I don't think I have too many things
um speaking of Peace spinning the most
impressive I've ever seen was by Boris
girlfriend oh okay spins it oh like it's
like we can talk about revolutions per
minute okay well you know Spinners and
all the kids have these yeah yeah the
scale fans invention okay wow wow okay
well all right this is uh we're having a
lot of fun we're diving in we're gonna
be here for a long time I got a feeling
this is an end game the queens were
traded long ago uh but
but I think that this is going to be one
where we're seeing maneuvering
maneuvering for quite some time to come
so
um
what is John thinking about he's the
first one under an hour so the candidate
moves we've discussed have been many
two
Bishop F4 oops Bishops don't move like
that Dan Knight D2 Bishop F4 Bishop G5
D4
and Knight G3 was one and Knight G3 was
the most recent one
one of the more logical ones I I feel
because it it really it's one of the
moves which threatens something very
directly yeah after Knight G3 black has
to deal with the threat of 94. you can't
play tonight you deal with that Knight
D5 comes to mind and the bishop goes
back to D2 yes just like right this is
exactly where we were we we actually
might have just moved the knight from C3
to G3 right seriously everything else
staying the same no for those of you
just tuning in if this line happens just
take a quick peek this was the position
a little bit ago that would be quite
funny
if in the end we're looking at this
position so sorry Robert I cut you off
no I was to say of course then white
snacks was Rook back to E1 and we're
going to three times position three-time
repetition in the old-fashioned way uh
but the thing is it's not clear to see
where white pushes forward so Knight G3
makes sense from a practical point of
view in addition to being an objectively
good mood because
every single big decision you make can
really backfire of course that's true of
any position but in particular when
you're facing Bishops and he did just
play Bishop he did we have it on the the
monitor right behind us
Bishop to F4 is on the board and I think
this is news that we'll see trades in F3
trades in F4 and a rook on the sixth
Rank and I don't really see a way that
Magnus could be in danger there and
Fabia as I think about this position can
we just trait make those trades uh Danny
yeah yeah this is uh if you're just
tuning in everybody we we looked at this
line
about 15 minutes ago and this was
Robert's key point to guard the pawn and
to bring the Rook into a very dynamic
position over here yeah so we have
aggressive intentions but even if the
knights get traded and white remains up
a pawn
doesn't really look like a position that
white should have too many chances to
win right
um
I if the knights are traded it's it's
going to most likely be a draw because I
don't see why it's pawns Pawn breaks and
the king-sized punks are very damaged
but I don't know if black wants that
because you think black you still have
to play a long game right a long
defensive game while here you don't
necessarily have to defend you can play
it and but white also has has some risk
and actually we see the moves on the
board happy Bishop just took an F3 here
we go he's Robert Robert Hess
the question is will it be Rook D6 or
Rook C6 yeah I was once this is a
difficult question yeah so Bishop takes
F3 has been played
now it's absolutely four we're gonna CG
takes F3 it's the only move so this will
be the position and so so fabi's Point
hasn't come in yet but the sequence that
we undoubtedly will see after Bishop F4
knife or Rook C6 or Rook D6 and we've
been defaulting to Rook D6 but there is
some benefit to playing Rook C6 namely
that you Rook them to D4 and right your
Rook on the C file isn't active in the
initial position whereas The Rook on
default has more spaces in front of it
so it can play Move Like Rook D4 or you
can play Knight D5 and once the trade
happens A6 is still defended so you just
have more options available to you in
many of these variations so Rook C6
makes sense even though at first it
feels a little uh well we're seeing the
moves come in now in rapid rapid fire
fashion we are already in the position
right here that we predicted
uh several minutes ago Magnus has
already given this position a fair
amount of thought yeah because John was
thinking about the position before
Bishop F4 and Bishop before was one of
like let's say three or four right
extremely logical candid moves and the
most forcing ones so so Magnus has given
this thought he's going to decide now
between Rook C6 and Rook D6 he might
give some thought to a move like G5 or
something like that there are there are
some other
potential options but Rook C6 or Rook D6
feel like
the most natural and probably the best
moves and it is a position where you
could just make a move with your hand
rather than with your brain and then
regret it so thinking about the
difference between Rook C and Rook D6 is
really important at this moment because
it's about the trajectory of the game
not just the currencies we know the Rook
wants to protect A6 and go over to F6 go
over to H6 but there may be small
details in some of the variations say
with a white Rook going to E1 or
potentially doubling on the a file where
by playing The Rook to C6 you get that
activity for black in time to say you're
not going to attack my A6 Pawn you don't
have the availability
no it's a really critical point and
it'll it'll seem mysterious in some ways
we always joke about mysterious Rook
moves But whichever Rook comes to the
sixth rank the the concepts behind it
are will be very deep for sure
um and just one quick thing if you say
do you want to play Rook D6 maybe you
want to throw Rook D4 first I don't
think you do but there are times where
you throw in a move the night the night
Retreats and then you go back to D6 I
don't like that here because it sort of
provokes uh White's night back to E2 and
one of the benefits of Black's Rook the
sixth string is going Rook upstick with
Tempo yeah kicking the Knight and then
winning the pawn F3 behind it yep plus
the probably White's most misplaced
piece in this position is the Knight
right I mean if you could just put this
Knight on e4 I know we've been doing
that all day the position this is a very
different yeah it's a very different
position but
yeah now it's going to be well Magnus
have plenty of time but he moved rather
quickly anyway
um and here the most logical move of the
movie which comes to mind to me is
rookie one I don't actually see another
move which makes sense
um because you want to get your Rooks
active you can't really push your pawns
at the moment you're not on F4 yeah you
can move it around but you'd rather
black First kicks it back before you
decide to move it around
um and rookie one makes a lot of sense
of course it's also provoking Knight to
five that's true then I does want
because that's kind of where the Knight
wants to be that's where the Knight
wants to be but it's not an ideal moment
because black still has that back rank
issue yeah and you know he it's not like
um black is the only one having all the
fun here he also has to worry about his
weak pawns his back Rank and the fact
that he's down upon and a rook on e4 is
pretty well placed because you're
defending the net an F4 and if black
wants to kick that Rook the only news
was putting the pawn F5 and we talked
about the pawn doesn't really want to be
there because the pawn F5 makes the F5
close right double pawns are happy when
there are Pawns in front of it you
double pawns don't want to be facing an
open file
all right well like uh Bobby said black
is not the only one having fun here
white is two and we are having a ton of
fun we are going to take a very quick
break and for the first time uh we will
be joined by the three-time world
champion hoey fun she'll be joining us
every day in our check in with the
champion segment the only guess we will
likely have in the middle of our
commentary will be if on a daily basis
but remember we have tons of guests as
soon as the game ends the show is really
beginning every single day so so make
sure you Mark Mark your plans for that
don't plan on getting up when the game
is over we're gonna have so many
interesting breakdowns and right now
we're going to take a very quick break
so that when we come back Yvonne can
give us her interesting breakdown it's
chess.com's coverage of the 2021 fee day
World Chess Championship I'm so excited
that we're here don't go anywhere
because we will be right back
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
the 2021 feet a World Chess Championship
continues here on chess.com brought to
you by coinbase and now we are joined by
a an amazing wonderful guest hoey fun
three-time world champion and uh I think
it's fair to say Robert she literally
stole the show in 2018 she's right
behind us here joining us became a
regular thing because her commentary and
insights were so amazing Yvonne
thank you for being here once again
uh hello Danny hello robots yeah yeah
I'm very happy
well we're excited to have you agree she
stole the show right absolutely yeah and
you never give me any credit but I'm
glad at least you give somebody the
credit there and this is your father's
probably any fun okay uh Yvonne we can't
wait to hear your thoughts on on what's
going down in the game currently we've
had one move since we went to a break
everybody uh thank you for sticking with
us and being here we see that C3 was
played on the board by yawn so
um of course we like to get all your
thoughts on on what's going on how we
got here Yvonne and and get your Insight
on where you think the match might be
going on on a day in and day out basis
but let's start with the live position
C3 what are your current thoughts on the
winning chances slipping a little bit to
magnus's favor and uh where is this
thing going
uh yeah well so for this end game I
think after this couple of exchange like
uh the bishop and the bishop for the
nights yeah after one called this Pawn
structure I thought black at least
wouldn't worry for any let's say bad
Resort but the question is the advantage
for black could still be like very tiny
but we all know that magnets are pretty
good at this so we'll see that whether
Neville would be uh let's say strong
enough to defend this easily I think it
should be wrong equal to be honest about
uh I wouldn't expect that white could
get so much chances under this current
position absolutely fun and to take us
back to the start of the game it's a
question general question for you you
played in a number of world championship
matches I was predicting that Jan might
play the move C4 and move one he's
played in the candidates he played in
some rapid events including against
Kasparov were you surprised at all that
he continued with E4 or do people you
recommend that people stick to the their
main repertoire
well I think it's really hard to expect
for
top of the top of toddlers what they
might choose for this very important
match because basically they're
Universal both let's say the opening
repetual and also playing style so it's
very hard to expect and also uh actually
Magnus faced quite a lot of E4 games in
his let's say world championship match
right and last time was very the mainly
his Sicilian this time you switch back
to this E4 E5 so I guess that both
players Double T and their team of
course have uh let's say well rounded
preparation for different possibilities
as we can also see that I think after
your FBA is still like the home
preparation for black I guess foreign
feature for example E4 to C4 like you
mentioned or maybe
E5 to C5 things like that you still you
stole my my follow-up question I was
just going to ask and so I'll adjust it
to say having played in so many matches
yourself is there something you look for
in regards to when you're going to go
away are you are you trying out of the
gate to try different things to maybe
poke at some at some you know poke and
prod to see if you can reveal where you
might be better prepared or do you like
to just stick with something until it's
broken what is the match strategy in
that regard
well uh from my own experience I I
didn't really think about this question
but I would say that I had let's say a
main Direction so for example uh with
white pieces what should be my main
focus and those black pieces because
both like the E4 and D4 what should I
play as the main weapon but of course
there will be some backups let's say if
plan a suddenly doesn't work at least we
should have a plan B and that should
plan Bishop uh be prepared as well maybe
not as
active as the plan a but it's not like
okay we're playing a round-robing event
or we're playing a Swiss German and
tomorrow I face this opponent check the
game suddenly decide that I want to go
for another Direction no that's not the
case yeah uh but it's also very hard if
we prepare both let's say different
major lines against the same opponent
because that battle takes so much energy
and also I think could that say your
opponent anywhere will be ready for
different options so it will be better
okay for most of the players I guess to
focus on one main interaction but also
could be expanded a bit
that makes perfect sense and Yvonne
before we get to the chessboard I have
one more question you mentioned
differences between matches and Round
Robin the Swiss Germans so how much
stock do you put in Jan's overall
head-to-head record against Magnus
because that was the talk of you know
every single news article an interview
oh man has a losing record against Yan
but those weren't in matches so do you
think that the headset record mattered
coming into this match
um to be honest I don't think that
really matters a lot because we should
also consider when these games has been
played and under which situation because
sometimes when a player is under
different German situation it might
affect his play a lot and for magnets
it's the same because I still have uh
let's say um deep impression about how
he played a couple of years ago in some
Invitational events like I think
2019 was last time they played class or
last decisive classical game they had
sorry
yeah so I mean Magnus for example
would you try to play completely
different things or when determine the
situation or let's say the series of the
events are different so if we wanted to
use that data to show some evidence
let's say uh let's say never is very
even or might even have more confidence
against the magnets now we need to check
uh and consider all these factors like
why it has been planned under which
situation and what about the mindset for
both the players and this and that even
when we did all that it doesn't
um prove let's say prove that in this
match one player who got higher score
would have let's say more chances to win
the event is completed the foreign
depends on let's say the the preparation
right the team and most importantly the
strengths and the energy physical
situation mindset and all these factors
combined together we'll see how things
go ill
makes sense that's uh
a lot a lot of thought going into it and
okay let's let's put some thought into
the current position because in some
ways I feel like Rook E3
is a bit of a draw offer in some ways
because of the potential to repeat
should black choose to go back to F5 and
continue to Target the F3 Pawn
um
disagreements thoughts on that he fun or
will white play rookie five on Knight F5
perhaps I'm wrong on that
wow okay history I guess it's not
exactly a draw over because that also
seems like a very logical move to
predict the point also strengthen the
this report but on the other sense
probably it's a little bit passive
because if let's say we could try to
develop well it's hard to say how to
develop but if we could bring the pieces
to the better squares and trying to
clarify with to not mine if we have the
phone F3 or not right right okay they
can easily get it back so the main issue
is about whether this Rook history is a
draw over or it's a bit passive let's
say because this type of position I
guess Magnus would be more sophisticated
compared to never somehow well
yeah I agree with you that this
definitely seems like a position that is
far more a magnus's alley and this is
not what Jan wanted stemming from the
opening but now that we're here and
white is up upon of course the pawns
aren't going anywhere Black's pieces are
perfectly placed but if I'm trying to
figure out like how how does black play
for more the eval bar slightly in
Black's favor at this moment for the
first real time of the game and Magnus
is the best in the world at just getting
victories out of position like this so
how do you see Magnus continue here from
the black side
well it is actually hard to suggest a
plan I guess if he wants to play the
pressure the first of all trying to
solve the problem of the background
where I push maybe goh pull at first and
then maybe one day to play your cap six
and uh
you know keep the flexibility of noise
to take that three or return to F5 but
in the meantime we should pay attention
to the K5 like you mentioned before
right yeah because actually we shouldn't
forget the pawn side no no no the poems
for black in the queen size is actually
very weak for both C5 and A6
that's right and I guess oh sorry you
find one of the things I mean all right
just I just want to add that the problem
for white is only actually the keys of
the beaker compared to black skin I
guess that's the only thing that I could
hope for because as I see magic if the
position is completely open and black
could use oh let's say coordinate both
of the rocks at night trying to uh
threat to the white skin in the meantime
capturing points I guess that would be a
fantastic plan but hard to accomplish
their phone yeah and you mentioned how
White's king is not quite that safe and
well one problem for black is that
there's nowhere for this King to go
right because the pawns are all in the
squares where the king would run away to
so the move Rook F6 would be the most
natural looking move to attack the
Knight on uh F4 and attack the pawn
behind it but because of the back rank
issues we see the eval bar go up so high
I move like Knight to D5 is available
because you can't take on D5 otherwise
there's a Checkmate on the back
oh
right so I guess the question I'm asking
while showing that variation is how
should black make Luft for the king
because you could play G6 to protect the
F5 square or maybe at some point you
want to have G5 available so what would
you choose at this moment
I guess G6 because G5 seems to me like
it's option for black he could choose to
play now or later so maybe no sense to
make it to push it immediately yep I
like G6 for sure
and I mean 95 is a much more serious
threat at the right moment because the
Knight is protected so rookie five
doesn't come with a Tempo against the
Knight
I keep I keep wondering whether white
can or wants to try to play a move like
King E2 at some point to guard both F3
and D3 but so risky because the white
Rook on E3 running out of squares there
because of Knight F5 so what I I would
ask the same question then uh to UE Fawn
for for white side we asked maybe maybe
how black might be able to push what do
you think the ideal setup is for White's
pieces here
because I was actually thinking before
you mentioned King to like what it would
be an ideal setup I thought it would be
much comfortable for why they if the
night could be traded off right
because F4 Trader with h4y therefore has
no let's say uh risks at all but the
point is it's very hard because when
you're not moving away from F4 it will
be Knight F5 and D3 is telling me so uh
we cannot train the night we cannot
train the drug and
hmm
maybe King too is not that bad
Danny you heard that your move
suggestion not that bad but okay you
might have to right that's the best
that's the best content that I can ever
get around here is not that bad you did
nothing I just like to mock Danny you're
not good but I mean the G6 move it looks
very reasonable and even coming up with
individual moves for white is not that
easy at this point because as you were
mentioning you found ideally the knights
are traded off right but Knight G2 well
it's very clear you want me to take I'll
just go back right to F5 and then this
D3 Pawn is lost because your Rook has to
move out the way
so I mean yeah exactly so maybe we
should
well protect the poem first but then you
need to either can you do or move the
other Rock but the local A1 is still
like you know making sense
yeah right The Rook to D1 it just looks
like it's very one-dimensional right
you're protecting the pawn but maybe at
some point you could even consider
pushing it I don't know is that too
brazen
oh wow maybe it's possible but I thought
that is actually opening the files for
black because then 905 and then maybe
Roxy too
oh you're saying once we trade on the D4
Square this Rook can yeah
plus the moment you're not putting
pressure on the A6 Pawn that black Rook
is looking for all kinds of ways to be
more aggressive
and the other plan for white may be
trying to grow your ke wire okay it's
trade off wire rugs to release the
tension a little bit
but a list of that can try clean
King method or even King King G7 just to
avoid the immediate you know what one
idea you just gave me Yvonne because of
something you mentioned earlier that
maybe there's a way at some point for
white to give up the F3 Pawn started
making me think I wonder if there's some
idea eventually of playing rookie seven
to go to A7 even with the F3 Pawn
falling if it meant that you could win
the A6 pawn and break through I'm not
sure if you think there's any maybe not
right away maybe after King E2
um but even right away it's something
that white might be looking for to be
aggressive any
is there any equity in that idea
right because otherwise it will be Rook
F6 and The Rook D3 black is so fast but
if you play immediately
then maybe G5 I mean your Q7 instead of
rock history because there's no sense
the waste this Temple right right so
saying rookie seven immediately
would have served that purpose and yeah
actually that's a really good idea to
try to get around to this Pond just
active defense rather than trying to
defend the ugly Pawn on F3
how about G5 here ah so now we don't
have to wait exactly but uh yeah right
away okay so Yvonne of course trying to
win this D3 pawn and then if the Knight
goes over to H5 you can't take on D3
just to show everybody that not all
pawns that look free are free because
that's a Checkmate in one on the back
rank the Knight covers the square so
um yeah G5 Knight H5 what was your
intend to follow up here you find
uh well my intention was something like
your cage six or maybe nine to five
first ah
yeah maybe Rock H6 because neither five
euro key five right yeah but now now the
Knight could go to G3 which would stop
Knight F5
right and I think yeah
[Music]
but no there's oh no you can't that's
right you also guard at five I was
thinking there was rookie a check and
then a fork on F5 but no that would be a
brutal way to lose the game but yeah
tonight on H4 covering the square so
just to show what we're discussing there
is no Fork on F5 because the Knight
covers the square the White Knight wants
to jump to so back to the idea would be
maybe maybe I don't know whether you
throw King E2 in or not after Rook D3 or
whether you would just play Rook A7 but
but okay
um yeah yeah but taking after taking
these three maybe one has zero P5 or
something like that because now both G5
and C5 under attack and I can oh that's
a nice thing
yeah we don't want to Tunnel because our
deal was to go Rook A7 to go for this
Pawn but now that you play G5 yep we're
happy to slide that Rook back right
there to E5 hitting C5 hitting G5 with
check and that will win at least one of
those Pawns
yep
taking a bigger a bigger step back back
asking a question here if
if this first game is a draw if on
obviously from Black's perspective
magnus's perspective a draw is a good
result generally the high levels of
Chess but having played in so many world
championship matches you were at one
point the Challenger right at one point
you were the playing in your first to
win the title is it good to get to get a
game out out of the way right to get one
under your belt and just draw the first
game to ease some of the nerves how
would yawn be feeling after a draw here
oh well I think it's too uh let's say
too early to say about anything I mean
any result I wouldn't imagine that it
could affect a lot for both Players
let's say uh psychological mindset
because you know any results is possible
and from my personal experience actually
I also didn't think too much about the
weather you know I should make use of
this first round let's say as white
pieces I should win I mean try to win
and as black pieces a drawer is a
victory no never I mean for me basically
uh when I play the the the world
championship match I was just trying to
uh let's say play regularly for every
game and talking about
these past matches I think uh some of
them or most of them I actually did you
my first game
I mean not all but more than half of
them I actually draw the first games and
I I had a white piece and I also got
black pieces so that really doesn't
matter I mean I think the creeper point
should be somewhere went towards the
middle of the match
okay and in those couple of games if
there's any decisive resource that would
affect the strategy of the forthcoming
games because uh when you had more games
played there were less chances less
opportunities for both players to try
harder right
that's right okay that makes sense
that's
good I didn't have any stats prepared I
should have known how you did in all of
your first games of every world
championship match not just first every
single game every single game but um but
okay it's good good insights there and
now we see King f8 having been played
maybe to stop this idea of rookie seven
eventually right
yeah it's an interesting yeah it could
be so you go first you find
uh yes I just want to say it could be
and also maybe I'm preparing for drug F6
sooner or later because actually he's
not worried about the move like Knight
H5 so kf8 equals two three six but uh
away your p7 also all the way the Rocky
one or p8 right so what you found
discussing is we were talking about
Knight D5 as a response to Rook F6
earlier but let's say in this variation
with King E2 Rook F6 just to put this on
table here Knight D5 no longer works
because you could take there's no back
rank Checkmate it's covered by the king
yay defends himself now who needs help
yeah helping himself for a change yeah
king of Fate is a multi-purpose move
defend z7 and is an is actually an
aggressive move it's funny when you play
a move like King f8 and it's actually an
aggressive move because now now the
Rooks can both get active
and I wonder because the Rooker A1 does
look well positioned to hit the A6 Pawn
but Rook a to E1
does make sense ifan mentioned that idea
earlier but this F3 Pawn always an issue
for white to deal with so it's not
always easy to figure out do I put my
king on E2 to preemptively defend a
second time do I bring my Rook to E1 to
then allow for Knight D5 ideas later in
the game so it's a choice that yarn is
going to really think on he's not going
to take it lightly but I I wonder what's
going through their heads because right
now we see the eval bar off inside it's
pretty level close to equal yeah it's
going slight better black slight bet for
whites moving around a little bit but
ifan you know you said this is More
Magazine style than yawn style of course
he's an objective player do you think
that at this point he's still searching
for opportunities to win or is he just
recognizing the position shouldn't have
too many chances for white
well in general I thought they were just
making the most reasonable moves and I
guess both of the players realize a draw
is acceptable and could be most likely
the resort for today but uh I think
while actually uh the strong point the
special ability for top players is
actually they're very let's say alert
for any tiny chances so for example it
looks like a very drawish position right
and they just keep playing normal moves
but suddenly if you made a tiny let's
say mistake and they're they could
change their mindset and deploying from
a situation to draw uh to a way by the
way it's 92.2 was just played and also
played rather quickly that was going to
be my next question for you if one is
we see John is picking up the pace a
little bit he actually has about a eight
minute time advantage on the clock and
we know how fast he can be uh your
thoughts on whether that's an indicator
of confidence for Jan here and in
general as they approach time pressure
maybe young Phil
's not not about the block because I
think the time still enough for both of
the players by the way how many moves
they've played like um that was move 28
Knight to G2 okay
oh wow then more than enough I guess
uh talking from time wise but this 92 is
interesting it's actually very concrete
because now if neither fiber K5 match
shows the disadvantage of the move king
of f8 compared to G6
well so if black plays G6 now though
and then white is time to defend this
Pawn whereas if the pawn we're on G6 and
the King on G8 then 92 would not have
been an option so magnets essentially
allowed Knight G2 to be played yeah with
this move King f8
very interesting
any any chance you would go for The Rook
ending here I think the Rook ending most
likely a draw but who has better chances
if should that trade happen
probably could be white
yeah
yeah I mean if you get a trade on G2
like we can just put a board here then
our only point of attack for black is
going after this D3 Pawn white can bring
this Rook to D1 bring the King right
back around to E2 and then it's a real
extra Pawn because you make sure you
don't lose D3 eventually you'll try to
push this Pawn or go after some of
blacks Pawn so this would only have
opportunities to win for white but still
black should hold with proper play yeah
[Music]
these three
but here
so it should be way more way more
drawish yeah chances are certainly worse
for white with his double F ponzer King
won't find uh true safety I'm not going
to Checkmate but it can be checked away
from the other pawns uh so Yampa is
Knight G2 he played it very quickly and
now for Magnus he's probably thinking do
I just take on G2 and
hold the balance or do I move my knight
back and if he if he keeps the knights
on the board you fun
we see the eval bar slightly better for
white of course it's not too much at
risk right now
but do you think that white could be in
more trouble with the nightstand or
would black be asking for danger himself
uh uh wow it's hard to say I I mean I I
think the next couple moves would be
important that I'm here for example is a
decisive decision for Magnus if we
traded the Knight it shows that probably
he's had before drawer under this
position but if he plays back to I mean
Retreat the Knight to F5
um though I felt that it should be the
move Knight F5 because I don't think
that this Knight G2 should
should be tried but it depends I mean
whether he wants to secure a drawer or
he wants some real play because even
after rookie 5G sets like what we
discussed before it's not so clear
what's next
I mean the position structure is still
very similar okay you you kick this
Knight away from H4 but then what else
because you still need to defend the D3
you ask a great question what else and I
was about to say the one piece for white
that isn't really doing its best job is
this Knight on G2 so can this Knight
find a square to go to find something to
attack or maybe it's headed to the
center at some point to offer another
trade maybe the knights are just gonna
be dancing away from each other well
it's yeah like he 293 but then the
stroking E5 could always be a bit tricky
right
it gets wrapped
no it just seem like you know white
shouldn't really ever be in any trouble
so you can sort of push in different
directions without any real
repercussions but at the same time where
black has control the D4 square with how
many of the pieces you have the Knight
The Rook and the pause the three pieces
covering the square and that's the only
way to make use of your extra Pawn is
trying to create a pass Pawn that's not
happening anytime soon
well he fun uh
obviously we will we will we will have
this result come to a close and uh
and be talking about what what
ultimately happened tomorrow when you're
joining us every day
um any final thoughts want to make a
joint join the commentary crew and make
a prediction we all made our predictions
before the game now you have a big
advantage to predict the results because
you actually see the position here so go
ahead what's your prediction
yeah for today's Resort
uh drawer most likely to agree with well
I mean okay draw yes someone had to
agree with you you agree you agree with
Robert it'll be a draw like I said you
have a you have a big Advantage if we're
gonna ask you every day what the result
will be because you'll get to see the
position but anyway we are going to be
checking in with you every day and um
right as we see Knight F5 on the board
we will we will say thank you so much
for for being here everyone don't go
anywhere we are going to take a very
short break and when we return Fabiano
caruana rejoins rejoins the set we dive
into this end game with some moves being
played rapidly and our coverage of the
2021 World Chess Championship continues
[Music]
chest outcomes coverage of the 2021
v-day World Championship is brought to
you by coinbase whether you're an
experienced Trader or just looking to
make your first crypto purchase coinbase
has you covered visit coinbase.com chess
to get five dollars in free Bitcoin just
for verifying your account today
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
lighting and audio
crushed through the top of the show
all right
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
chess online or learn how to improve
join us at the number one chess
destination in the world chess.com with
thousands of people playing at any
moment you'll quickly find a game with
someone at your level whether you're a
beginner or a Grandmaster test.com makes
learning fun and easy sharpen your
tactics with puzzles and enhance your
strategy with our lessons by top Masters
learn from your own games with our easy
to use analysis tool chess.com has
everything you need to take your game to
the next level signing up is free and
easy join chess.com today
thank you
[Music]
in case you didn't see our partners at
coinbase are sponsoring chess.com's
coverage of the 2021 v-day world
championship and boy are we thankful
whether you're an experienced Trader
been doing this for years or just
thinking about making your first crypto
purchase coinbase is the place to go
visit coinbase.com chess and get five
dollars in free Bitcoin when you sign up
and verify your account today
foreign
[Music]
want to hold a massive chess tournament
with dozens of clubs or hundreds of
players or maybe a small chess
tournament with local but competitive
clubs with Club Arenas you can
Club Arenas allow for tournaments of any
size with any number of clubs and
players customize the arena with any
time control with standard chess or mini
chest variants and with any starting
position you want Club Arenas are the
most flexible tournament format on
chess.com try one out today
[Music]
am I supposed to feel ready but
I guess
when you prepare for such a major event
you always
feel like you could could do more but I
guess we are doing some insane amount of
work soon
I hope we we get to be you know
ready enough
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
to be serious it's hard to evaluate
because I think in modern Church you got
to be
very Universal player if you want to be
successful and so you can't rely on the
education alone
so it's
they would like to you know to say that
for example a player a royal Chamberlain
would be the best intuition ever is
speak Health child but
I guess he also had you know he he had
to calculate a lot yeah and for example
today if you you could try to to stick
to his playing style
sometimes it will be very costly to to
your performance I think yeah the
intuition is always good but
I mean sometimes you basically can't
choose the move
because of your calculation or
evaluation and you need to for example
sometimes you are giving like two
similar opportunities you you you got to
pick one and okay probably Here Comes
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
the game continues here in the first
round of the 2021 vide World Chess
Championship and we we have a few moves
so we're gonna we're gonna get into it
as ifan left us and Fabiano returns here
we had multiple things happen black
retreated the Knight to F5 to attack The
Rook
white played Rook E5 as predicted Robert
and on G6 we see the Knight complete its
tour to E1 so it was interesting because
the night was first was first on G2
offering The Rook ending that Magnus
declined and now that now the Knight
ends up on E1 which is got to be a big
Improvement for for yawn just from the
perspective that at least D3 is no
longer a headache but with black playing
the move Knight to G7 the question is
who's
who's playing for a win here is anybody
playing for a win it's funny because
we've seen so many retreats in this game
right yeah earlier in the game the night
went out from B1 to C3 and then back to
E2 yeah and then the Knight just went
from F4 to G2 to E1 the black knight
from H4 to F5 to G7 so it does feel to
me like Magnus is trying to keep some
hope alive because he could have traded
Knights he would have been on the worst
side of the Rook end game but he's never
winning that here at least he has some
sliver of Hope and and father and I were
discussing just briefly a moment ago and
I think we still agree that it is
dangerous for anyone right now with the
Knights on it's white
your thoughts yeah I I definitely agree
that at this point Magnus is keeping
some hopes alive I think that of course
this is like a 90 draw position right
it's not only is it basically level even
if someone gets the edge it's very
likely to liquidate right but white has
some problems I I didn't quite like his
last move 91 okay because he needs to
get that Knight to C2 obviously he wants
to at some point so it made more sense
to play King E2 here I feel
and then then I can more naturally go to
E3 the only downside I think of this is
that black and play F6
rookie 496. but at the very least
after rookie three black has nothing
better than to repeat
and maybe white has something more
putting the Rook
on H4 for example or something like that
which of course I understand he didn't
want to do
but that doesn't necessarily mean it's
bad
um while 91 feels like
I would at this point already rather
prefer black slightly okay especially
because Black Knight is coming to E6 and
I really like that square
that's really interesting the uh the
computer tended to agree with you as
well that that King E2 a little bit
better for white and you make a really
great point that it's all about this
Knight coming to E3 I want to make one
great Point real quick because not a
great Point not complimenting my own
point but I forgot to make a point which
is that we are debuting our first
episode of the chess of reflection of us
documentary it was supposed to happen at
the last break but because the action is
so intense we don't want to leave it but
stick around uh toward the end of the
show today for the world premiere of a
number of things from a documentary
about Levy Rosman as well as the first
episode of Chess a reflection of us many
of you saw the preview to that on
Twitter uh just a couple days ago so all
right nailed that point now we're back
now we're back here and and talk about
why you like the night on E6 so much
Bobby
well there's a few things so
first I'd like to try to understand his
move rookie for because the move
doesn't prepare the night moving from E1
but it does sort of prepare B4
okay maybe D4 but more likely B4 because
he would rather get rid of those doubled
pawns yeah if you let's say we took the
B and C pawns off the board magically
yeah I'm just gonna make some I'll just
make this move but what we'll do before
just to show it because this would be a
huge a huge turn of events for white
yeah then white can play D4 without
trading pawns and then the Knight can
free itself to D3 and White's Pawn
Advantage may start to make itself felt
the problem is of course that after B4
black has a lot of moves that are not
taking
um let's start with F5 is a is a big
consideration
um
of course here here you really have to
consider Rook takes I was just about to
say can we do it please Robert knows how
frisky I get for exchange sex this looks
fantastic this is so good two connected
past Parts oh oh the C5 pawn and the D3
Pawn going to D4 these are very
dangerous pawns but at least it's it's
clear that black has some options and
also there is my G5 after B4
yeah okay so we'll we'll assume that F5
probably won't be played on B4 so that's
not a move because of the exchange stack
but Knight G5 to 5 minutes Point that's
what I was thinking about because now
you're attacking the rook and if you
take on C5 you're giving up your rook
and fixing your Pawn structure but
you're not getting two pawns yeah for
the exchange you're only getting one so
White's pawns are great in the center if
you had one more turn you would play D4
B4 and white would just but even this is
a possibility right because if C5 has
taken then A6 Falls but I think there's
something much better than this after
Knight G5 the reason I don't quite like
Knight G5 is because of the move Rook E5
that attacks two things and actually
forces black to go back with the Knight
so that already shows the failure of the
movement ig5 the reason why
it shouldn't be a good move so black has
to consider this B4 idea it's clear that
this is what Yan is going for and Magnus
will find a way to cut into his plans
the question is how how
is pacing by the way in the uh the glass
box feels like a bit of a metaphor what
if this is a bit of a stranger but can
you play Knight E8 potentially the
Knights of him retreating all games so
so let's keep it going if I go to E8 and
you try B4
then I can play Knight F6
and
if we get here can I play G5 oh man or
an id5 or an idea better
um 98 makes a lot of sense I also wanted
to point out a logical move with a funny
Point okay
um move F5 is very direct
it's also very logical it's clear what's
white and it's all it's also exactly and
the point is if white plays Rook H4
let's say then that's that's a very bad
move this is the fact that black plays
G5 take and King G8 and The Rook is
rather comically trapped and this is not
a good exchange though not a good
exchange stack this is not the one
you're looking for if you're young we
see F5 has been played on the board
um and Rook E3 immediately immediately
Retreat so Jan backing up that Rook like
he knew this was coming like he provoked
the F Pawn moving forward Robert your
thoughts on that well of course when you
push upon you leave the squares it was
previously covering behind so E6 he has
the Knight there now and he can play
King F7 to back the night up but if
white were able to double Brooks earlier
then you wouldn't have the same kind of
solid Outpost for the night so uh this
to my eyes looks really good for black
the Knight can go to C2 for white but
then you have to watch out is F4 coming
because the right now two pieces defend
the D3 Pawn and you can see that F5 to
F4 will kick The Rook out so if the
Knight moves you might just drop D3 if
the Knight doesn't move well your
Knight's on E1 it's a very passive piece
it's simply defending D3 and F3 but
you'd prefer your knight to go to C2 so
you can play fabiana's Move B4
yeah I don't really like what Jana's
done because as Robert mentioned Knight
C2 at at the very least black can grab a
pawn without four
um might even have another four is also
gravity yeah that's so it can be seen
that the D3 Pawn is hanging at the end
of that line I wanted to point out a
funny variation of the elliptics D3 yeah
not very relevant but anyway it's kind
of funny if King E2
and if black were to make a very serious
blunder Rook C to D6 of course he should
just back up The Rook somewhere but if
he were to do that Rook takes C6 and
then he had this clever Rook D2 he's
like oh I have a check but after King E1
yep you still have that problem of two
Rooks hanging and uh White ends up up a
piece right uh but of course that's out
Force black can just drop the Rook back
to any Square he wants
um or as Robert mentioned Knight F4 is
an excellent move as well we continue to
see moves coming in Fast and the reason
I want to draw attention to that is
because we knew this was going to be a
storyline coming in we didn't know when
we'd be talking about it Robert but Yon
he has a reputation he has a history of
at times in his career playing too fast
in critical moments and when we see
the night Maneuvers that are on the
board criticism from a fellow 2800 right
it's not not just me and you saying
maybe it's not good anymore we've got a
guy who you know he's pretty good at
chess right I have to draw questions so
Robert like or I mean is yon playing too
fast here does he need to slow down and
think about think about the greater
setup
well I think right now he has everything
under control but that there is a
problem if you continue to move quickly
and you stop really diving deep into the
position right you're not calculating
you're just moving big difference right
chess isn't a game of moves it's a game
of ideas and strategies right so you
can't just play single moves and hope
they work out you make sure that you
have your bases covered because what
Magnus has done is push forward right he
has moved his Knight a bunch of times it
went from H4 to E6 here and it backed up
to go forward and the pawn goes up to F5
so the structure is worse for white the
material is good for white and for Jan I
think he has everything here he's fine
with it but I don't think he's happy
with the game as a whole and that's
maybe in part why he's moving so quickly
because that's not the position he
wanted yeah he came in today for a fight
and perhaps to press for an advantage
and now he's here where he's has no real
winning chance against Magnus let me uh
you were about to say so maybe I'll just
ask kind of the same question to you you
played John of course and your thoughts
on how he's managing the time yeah I
don't fully agree that he has things
under control here I feel like he's
playing quickly out of nervousness okay
um out of the fact that he doesn't like
his position very much uh he's clearly
coming under pressure he has basically
zero chances to win this game at this
point he's he's adopting a defensive
stance the Knight on G2 yeah doesn't go
anywhere from there it can maybe prepare
F4 and then maybe the king coming to F3
and that's what he's hoping for that
someday he like gained some space and
his King gets to a nice square and then
the Knight will eventually get freed
that seems a bit optimistic to me that
all of that works out for him
[Music]
um
and like now he's holding things
together tactically right F4 rookie four
he doesn't lose D3 because there's F4
hanging things like that or even Rook
takes E6 as a as a tactic if the Rook
comes to D3
but but that's it tactically it's
working out for now
but slowly black and I think black has
like King F7 has a decent move and he
probably wants to play F4 that's the
only idea I can see for white now play
F4 get the king to E2 and say you're not
attacking anything oh wow look at that
oh B4 but that's a move that's
that that says something which is I
think there's more than let me see I and
I'm glad you brought up about you
thought you felt like it was nervousness
because he doesn't like the position
because I wanted to say the thing that
prompted the question and I know this is
body language but I've watched these
guys play chess a lot you've played you
are these guys that play I've watched
you play chess more than you watched
yourself and I'm telling you Robert John
had that look like it was like the um
okay show me what's got what's going on
here and I feel like people
underestimate the winning chances that
Magnus will get or or that he's not
gonna stop trying to win so if John
thinks he's already in a blockadeable
setup with the knight move moving back
and forth from E1 to G2 I think he has
another thing coming oh absolutely yeah
and what I meant is he has things under
control for now objectively speaking
Yeah but I completely agree the
strategory of the game is in magnus's
favor there's no denying that the
opening may have intended to be somewhat
of a surprise it looked like Jan was the
one who started thinking at least more
spend more time o'clock earlier than
Magnus did and now we're at this stage
of the game where black is pressing
forward F5 B4 and white is the one up a
pawn but is on the defense so it could
be a situation where perhaps Jan has to
just jettison upon and say take your
Pawn back yeah I'm going to neutralize
the rest of your advantage and maybe
liquidate in a way that even if he goes
down upon he can still hold but it's not
easy to see that future right now and at
the very least he has time to sit and
suffer in the position but right now
it's clear that Magnus is on pressing
forward and in his element yeah yeah I I
really like the B4 move I think that if
white let's say makes a passing movement
out or a semi-useful move like F4 then
black has Rook B8 coming
and it's really awkward to defend that
pawn on B3 you know you could play Rook
B1 you don't want to but you can do it
uh there's no other clear way you don't
want to play C4
C4 would be I mean it would just destroy
your position we'll just highlight the
moment you play C4 you can you can kiss
any happiness goodbye this Knight comes
to D4 and it's more of a beast than a
pony yeah I think here black is already
in basically I'm going to win territory
yeah if I play C4 of course we're we're
probably still healthily in the range of
an objective draw
um but this is this is pressure this is
not
um I would feel under pressure with
white here I wouldn't feel
um I didn't like that my G2 move I
really feel like the Knight doesn't
belong there at all
um the night belonged on C2 it belonged
on E2 let's say or any other square but
G2 it has no future where is it going to
yeah it's only there in the defensive
task to stop Knight F4
uh maybe to stop F4 from black right but
that's it that's all it's going to be
doing there no I'm with you and again
that was what I was nervous about when I
saw yum play quickly put the Knight
right back as if he's saying well show
me in the moment you get that show me
attitude against Magnus he tends to show
you exactly what he's playing for you
know and uh that that's what we have now
Black is Black is pushing
my other concern is I don't see a
comfortable move for white I think like
Rook A4 comes to mind because I want to
kind of force the issue on the queen
side but after Rook A4 black will play
Rook B8 still with threat of taking on
C3 taking on B3
and then the question is what how does
white solve this issue is I mentioned
this as a possibility and I don't think
it's going to work out very well but is
there a possibility that white at some
point could play D4 giving back the pawn
to alleviate the immediate pressure and
what I would like to do is you mentioned
the Knight on G2 being bad
I want my knight to go to C4 at some
point I don't know if I'm going to be
able to get there but I would love to be
able to route my night at least it
doesn't work I tried it doesn't work
Robert right that would be ideal if you
could do that no but I I was thinking
about this D4 ideal I think it's
definitely a tool why it has to keep uh
in his kit yeah an idea for the future
but I didn't see how he makes it work
for example if we go back
here's one way I was thinking it could
work like let's say we just play H4 and
and and you go for this line where
you're you're losing the pawn but if you
finish with this dude am I able am I
taking everything off the board when
Robert first mentioned it this was what
I visualized is that now if you take on
D4 I'm probably taking off a pair of
Rooks and if this Rook ever leaves I
have a six so possibility this is where
white tries to liquidate everything it
this is possible this actually looks
like it might be trade enough trading
off enough pieces yeah to secure a
drawing actually I like to move H4
because it's a good positional move it
stops Knight G5 it kind of controls some
important squares you're saying I
accidentally contributed and I should
stop that H4 is a generally useful
but I we are also in the territory where
white has to start
um basically try to liquidate in a way
which is gets concrete right so he's the
one who has to calculate black can can
go into it thinking okay I I I'm no
longer in Risk I have a safety net uh
whenever y plays D4 obviously white is
the one who's just saying I'm trying to
make a draw here so so the onus is on
white all the pressure is on white now I
we should note too that Robert's idea of
D4 should never really be played until
this exchange happens right you don't
ever want to put the pawn on D4 if the
exchange leaves these pawns doubled then
didn't really provide enough relief
right and uh here here Blackwood for
example win the pawn and you still have
the weaknesses or even here I think Rook
takes because you don't want to to allow
that
um that pin okay yeah so Rook takes D4
here black has domination so D4 is
definitely not
um currently a very good move okay
maybe maybe H4 is the move I mean the
more we look at it it's hard to I think
Robert's initial or was it fobby
suggesting a brook A4 as well well we
were saying Rook a forward be at H4 that
was okay yeah yeah specific I don't know
if that's the right way to do it but
it's
okay it looks like a a plausible way to
continue actually
and even in those positions that we're
talking about if you trade on C3 and
lose the B3 pawn and get your D4 move in
excuse me
commentary you know no it's okay it
takes daddy
black has the outside Pawn whereas why
is the Central Pawn okay
yeah so we'll let Robert have the tea so
yeah here black white is an ideal
position because the Rook on A4 does
attack that pawn it's an outside pass
Pawn but for the Moment The Rook is on
the side of it not behind it so it can't
push forward very easily but if I were
black I would consider rather than
taking on C3 capturing that pawn
um if we go back a few moves because we
played that semi-useful move H4 right
and black so it's not doing anything
it's not threatening anything so black
can make a semi-useful move in return
King F7 um protects the E6 Knight which
was loose maybe King F6 will come so the
question is again well I didn't do
anything with black but you also didn't
really do anything with white you just
made a move which is kind of improving
your position a bit yeah so you still
have to be in those difficult moves
right no it's a great point and
makes it even harder to find a clear
plan for for Jana this is funny because
you want to do things to improve your
position in a game like this right but
bringing the king in actually might walk
you into more tactical problems and so
you have to be it's very difficult when
you can't improve what you know you need
to do in the end game activate your king
and let's just show because if this King
comes in now okay already you can just
see the potential but the concrete line
go ahead for black yeah actually it's
funny you you pointed out an id4 that
would be a great move if the king were
on F6 because the rookies would be
trapped right oh what a line so here it
doesn't work out because the E5 square
is available but imagine I'm just gonna
do something random just to show how
cool this line is this oh maybe it
doesn't work but no it does why it
doesn't have to play CD4 but yeah it's
an idea it's a potential idea which
could come into play cool idea and we
were nervous about that earlier that
that Brook has the potential to get
trapped there but more specifically if
we go back to that position Rook A4
Rook to B8 H4
King F7 and we were showing why King E2
is not a very good move
now let's say black takes on C3 yep
takes Rook B3
D4
and now it's a much worse version
because let's say CD4
CD4 Rook B2 oh King has to go back to F1
most likely Rook C2
I mean actually the king shouldn't go
back to F1 because of this so this is
just a disaster the king probably has to
go to D3 or something but it's like I
have my own little engine here
explaining every time the e-ball bar
slides his name is Fabiano uh yeah I
love you very much
you know the email bar goes up and down
and we have it there because we all like
to see you know we want to understand
and have the engine as a guide but we
don't have any engine moves in front of
us in case anyone's wondering but we do
have Fabiano so that that helps
um
okay well Jan is
there he is he's thinking and this is
this is exactly the type of moment I was
nervous about Bobby when when we when I
asked that
question to you and Robert both about
how he was managing his clock because I
could see it coming you know those quick
moves and now now you recognize just how
much your opponent is going to push this
position and
I think it might be a slight lack of
experience because he he feels generally
that the position should be level yeah
because it's it's kind of been level for
most of the right more or less and he
from the opening obviously he was
slightly better so he might still have
those emotions of well I was better so
it's hard to imagine that now I have to
kind of right pull the brakes right try
to find a liquidation and so he was
playing these quick moves like okay I'm
a pawn
you have compensation but you're not you
can't actually do anything right
um and that's not quite the case black
as Magnus just showed can do something
this this is a dangerous idea
um how dangerous is that you know
obviously in a match setting we talk
about not letting the previous game
affect the next game you really have to
avoid the emotional hangover right and
you and I talked about that in the video
series we did but in in a re in real
time
in a game that's even harder to do
because there's no rest day
there's no there's no seconds talking to
you right how what do you do to keep
yourself emotionally unbiased if you
will
um
well is that a situation after the game
is finished or during I'm saying during
the game how do you avoid that where you
previously were better and now that's
that's jading your perspective this is a
difficult situation yes
um this will be very difficult for you
on I think at this point he realizes he
needs to find a concrete way he can't
keep playing around with his position he
needs to find a concrete way to get to
something where the drawish nature of
the position will allow him to hold even
though he's on the worst side of it
right if he just shuffles his pieces
around the pressure will remain right
and he needs to release that quickly so
I I think at this point he's trying to
find a way to do that
um even though the the position is
objectively
uh not in that super dangerous territory
um practically
because it's not concrete white doesn't
have like a very obvious concrete way of
releasing the tension
that makes it dangerous I was actually
thinking about a funny move here rookie
five okay
um
the point is if black at any point takes
on D3
white takes on E6 plays Knight F4 and a
rook ending will be a draw it's just
it's just a dead draw defensive Forks
you don't see him that often anymore huh
you know it's not often enough and
rookie five sort of suggests that maybe
why we'll play 90 it puts pressure on C5
maybe Knight E3 is coming right you know
maybe some active stuff is coming okay I
don't know if it's good because well
black can maybe play King F7
uh black has options here
but I I do kind of like this move it it
it's nice that black can't take and it's
an active move so from White's point of
view it feels sort of
sort of useful
um is the Knight stuck to G2 because as
soon as that Knight leaves in general is
then Black Knight coming into F4 well we
could play rookie one here
so putting trying to keep putting
pressure but you can't really capitalize
on that pressure right you're just
putting it there because it stops
rotates D3 so the question is can white
black do something useful there
um it's not entirely easy because if he
plays Rook V8 at some point
which line are we in sorry yeah yeah
this position okay
if like at some point plays Rook B8
white by the way has been played in the
real game not not in this exact moment
but Rook B8 is on the board go ahead
oh so what did white play that go ahead
so yeah John played King to E2 Rook to
B8 okay Rook to B8 is blade this was the
line I was afraid of he probably wants
King to D2
I'm guessing and if take Pawn takes Rook
B3 King C2 he's happy to get his King to
that side of the board
oh he's fulfilling the Robert has
prophecies
the same issue exists if Rook C6 to B6
this roof takes E6 again because at the
Rook B2 check King C1 the same exact
thing on a different file yeah
so I guess that's his idea because the
King on E2 by itself is terribly placed
it's in the way of all sorts of checks
and things
so I guess King D2 is idea
um it's a pawn sack but on the other
hand he does Stop The Rook from activity
on on that B3 square right the road is
stifled there it's what you guys said
needs to happen when you're in this sort
of defensive position there's pressure
you don't want to keep a new ring you
just made those comments right because
they'll keep improving you have to find
a concrete way which is good advice for
all the chess playing Chatters who are
watching this right because because
that's how you that's how you get
yourself out of out of a bad situation
you have to find something concrete and
this might be the sacrifice that
improves white position enough to draw
but oh sorry Danny just one thing that
you'll like
um getting back to that Knight D4 idea
if Black's Rook drops back okay Knight
D4 is very much on the cards yep because
well with the Rook on E3 specifically
with the Rook on let's say E5 there's no
id4 but in this specific position Knight
D4 becomes if not a threat at least I'll
just show it just so that everyone can
see Booyah yeah
discover check
Rook A3 really is asking for an idea
would have been a bad move I hear you
okay Robert go ahead I mean Jan doesn't
look pleased and he shouldn't be pleased
with this position but he's doing the
right thing something that players who
are newer or even quite experienced
players who are trying to improve they
they know their position isn't great
because their pieces can't find any good
squares but then they're materialistic
they think I'm up a pawn and that's
what's keeping me in the game right
whereas actually maintaining the pawn is
keeping white out of the game because
the Knight on G2 is not helping the King
was on over on F1 by giving up B3 in
this manner and getting the king over to
the queen side you lost one Pawn but you
make sure that the rest of your problems
are at least fixed for the time being so
I really like this idea from Jan I don't
think it's just you know he is not he's
not out of the woods raw yeah but he is
making his life a lot easier because a
few moves you know he can get his pieces
forward then he's feeling much better
about his chances yeah I think the
question is really because this is very
likely to happen black is very likely to
take I don't really see other logic if
you don't I mean just to remind
everybody if you don't then the King
goes to sleep not we're not right now
but it's not clear what else black does
here maybe king of seven king of seven
is is a very clever move
um in this situation because why can't
play King C2
so black is asking why like what do you
want next
um
but
but at some point Black's gonna take on
C3 and B3 right
it seems like that's that's at some
point going to be the only way it has
been played Magnus has indeed taken and
which means we know that
we know that
John's going to take back with the pawn
so yeah Pawn takes is necessary
um King takes saves the pawn but you
could see how bad it is after Knight T4
yeah this would be frailed upon in most
chest circles to take with the King not
if you're not if you're Magnus but most
most just circles you don't take there
you get you take with the pawn and and
we see John has indeed done so so Rook
B3 and King C2 will likely happen
and Rook it's hard to say where B7 or B8
most likely I was thinking is there any
utility in B6 just in terms of
protecting the Knight twice although
that that I know it looks ugly coming to
B7 makes a lot more sense because we can
get behind the pawn yeah well I think
black's idea is to play at some point
works cb6 and the Knight only six can
get defended by the King on F7 oh that's
a very nice idea so you don't want to
place your Rooks on the side you want to
double them so that they can infiltrate
um
y'all continuing to give he's a very
emotive player his facial expression
that's uh yonda pomdishi catalog number
13 where he kind of says well I know I'm
worse but I don't think you have enough
to win
yeah I wonder what his I guess his idea
is that let's say Rook B7 or Rook B8
um I don't know which is let's go let's
go to B7 but he's probably going to play
Rook A2 at some point first I think he's
gonna move his E3 Rook to deal with that
Knight D4 idea
um like to E5 maybe or something that
looks very logical yep
um I don't think black wants to try to
grab a form of Knight G5 it it grabs
upon I don't feel like that's your
Black's priority here yeah
um
and specifically after like F4 Knight H3
the Knight gets kind of marooned yeah
you don't want that it's not worth a
pawn to let that over here in fact it's
all it's also not worth letting this
Knight back in the game really I mean
that's one of White's biggest problems
is that the donkey on on G2 but
if it wasn't for the fact that I have to
deal with Knight D4 I would love to play
them with Rook A5 if I could at some
point but maybe rookie five rookie five
yeah and if Rook cb6 he'll play Rook A2
it's a bit of a passive way of doing it
but it's effective at stopping her B2
right okay yeah and then he's ready for
Knight E3 Knight C4 once the Knight gets
in the game it also has some some good
squares now yeah Robert Mitch and
getting the Knight to C4 right this
would be
I mean obviously that would be huge for
white if you put the Knight on C4 we
might be back to a three result
potential position that I don't see four
is super effective and not just
offending but also really causing some
tactical issues it's a black setup right
um
yeah black also has to be careful here
because
um his Advantage could dissipate in an
instant if White Knight gets active
again and as you said it could
potentially it's unlikely but it could
potentially uh turn into a bit of a
white Edge if the right were magically
transported to C4 no exactly yeah we we
teased Robert it was magic and I no
matter what I try I can't seem to move
my knight that far but yeah no jokes
aside that's a really important way to
approach these positions anyway just as
a chess player to you always want to
know where your pieces would be happiest
whether you can achieve those goals or
not is is the Second Step because it
gives you it gives you the guide the
North Star for all the chaos you're
dealing with so really important that
that we know White's goal
yeah so this next move it's hard for me
to tell I I have a feeling
that Rook B7 is better because it
controls the seventh rank yeah that's
like far into the future that why would
ever use a seventh rank
um but the downside maybe is that if a
knight were to come to C4 Knight A5 yeah
but that's also another thing to think
about in the future is the potential
tactical consequences like you said of
where you put your pieces so sorry go
ahead no it's just a very difficult
decision yeah the witch Square the for
The Rook it's it's a long-term thing and
you can't really judge these things
because both squares have some pluses
and minuses
um
but he will probably choose one of them
unless Rook B5 actually also makes sense
it maybe prepares A5
A5 and then Rook A6 and start pushing
that pawn down the board oh you get the
other Rook behind the pawn that was that
was the other reason I liked Rook B7 was
to threaten Rook A7 but perhaps Rook B5
does that okay now he does go for B7 and
I think I think this makes the most
sense in the sense that not we you kept
highlighting one point which of course
was the double but the other Point again
was just a very clear idea
of trying to advance the a pawn I guess
the moment you do that you would argue
Jan's gonna play Rook A5 right yeah I
don't think that Rook A7 will have the
desired effect okay
um Black's play should be more around
um either something on the king side
king of seven King F6 and then trying to
maybe push some pawns or attack some
pawns on the queen on on the king side
for white yep or Rook cb6 but Rook cb6 I
don't really see the continuation after
rotate too yeah it looks good sort of a
dead end yeah we've had a lot a lot of
moments today where certain things look
good but there there wasn't a lot of all
talk no action I saw several people in
chat asking the move number it is move
37 so only three moves remaining and
they will get additional time added back
onto their clock
um in a second we'll we'll maybe bring
up and remind everybody what the time
control is because we are nearing time
control
again on move 40 everybody gets more
time so that that 17 minutes you see for
yawn 18 minutes for Magnus is not the
end of the game and I would be
I would be surprised if this game ended
at any time soon I think that this is
going to be continuing for a while I'm
looking at fava you can't see me but
Bobby gave me the Fabi nod I just got
the Fabi nod this will be a long game
and also H4 is interesting he played
this quickly and confidently yeah but it
does allow Knight D4
94 forces can do one any other move
loses a rook
um and so obviously he's judged that
this is not a worry for him right but it
is still interesting that he played
quickly I guess the Knight B5 he can
still defend his C3 Pawn with like King
C2 King D2 okay um I don't expect a draw
to be like this it would be a funny draw
but that would be a funny draw with
Knight D4 and King to D1 but let's come
back to H4 because one of the next
educational nuggets I was going to try
to draw out of you was we talked about
the active defense y'all needed to play
he did that he has now given back his
pawn and improved his King position what
do you do next when you have a worse
structure we see H4 played is is the
idea like hey I need to try to play H5
and and liquidate the King side if I can
like what are you doing here is white to
hold effectively I think the idea of H4
is purely to stop Knight G5 okay or in
the future Knight F4 doesn't attack H3
right okay I think it's just a useful
move generally he doesn't know exactly
where his other pieces want to be
um so he's playing H4 and I suspect
black will play King of seven here
that's that's my but I was gonna say if
he doesn't play King of seven you don't
give any Credence to my H5 idea because
you can't really take it can you F5
becomes a little too weak I don't think
H5 is the idea and maybe if White's it
was White's move here because if it was
white he can play rookie five right uh
but but black Black's gonna play King of
seven years black will most likely play
King of seven okay and if he doesn't
he's probably gonna play Rook cb6
uh yeah in both cases White
yeah I don't think H5 is really an idea
but it could be an option at some point
that it's always an option to liquidate
either liquidate the pawns or we can F5
because black has to either trade or
take or push G5 okay
well Magnus is uh
thinking it over
it's it's kind of a safe position for
him right I mean there's he can play
several moves here he could play Knight
D4 to have a little fun little tickle if
he's into that but likely king of seven
king of seven feels very natural yeah a
slightly strange looking move but one
which
makes some sense to me is H5
um I know it looks funny but you're
creating these holes I I it doesn't look
like a move I want to play but go ahead
we started playing king of seven but
what was your idea here well the idea is
just long term at some point if I play
G5 uh let's say when the works come off
then the H1 might start to run you're a
wizard Harry house porn uh and white
can't really use the weakened squares F4
is covered G5 is covered and also okay
well I can't get there that's
interesting
um just just an idea but King F7 is
is the most natural most logical move
and he played it
bringing the king into the center that's
what you do in the end game
in case anyone case anyone missed that
memo
we have a lot of you with us thank you
for being here on day one of the 2021
feed a World Chess Championship our
coverage on chess.com is brought to you
by coinbase we have the one and only
Fabiano caruana in studio as you've as
you've been seeing he is the man who
last played Magnus Carlson for the world
championship title in 2018. uh many many
of you were probably watching that and
uh well even though fobby would rather
be in Dubai we're happy that he's here
and uh
and uh yeah so thank you for being here
everybody Robert Hess also with us
not in studio at this moment but also on
the show so all right rookie one Bobby
yeah not a move we predicted uh yeah
it's it's a very logical move if like
let's say Rook cb6 Rook A2
then well I just covered all the
potential entry squares
um
and then he's ready
or maybe 93 Knight C4 that becomes an
idea
um black has to contend with because in
C4 square that was the the downside of
B4 it was a good move it won a pawn but
it did weaken the black structure
considerably so at the moment white
actually obviously white structure on
the king side is wrecked but on the
queen side white has a better structure
if Black's A6 Pawn was transported let's
say
I accidentally saw myself
that's all right okay the joke with my
producer you continue go ahead sorry
continue
like let's say if we transported whites
Black's A6 Pawn to D5 or B5 or some
Square where it can kind of influence
action more right black would be
significantly better on A6 it doesn't do
anything it's a pass Pawn but it's a
weak past Pawn yep so the structure on
the queen size actually invite's favor
yeah and I like I like this move more
and more just just looking at it because
it like you said it it's the first real
direct threat Jan has had in quite some
time right to bring the Knight to E3 and
C4 yeah well
this is uh made Stronger by the fact
that we played Rook C to B6 I I suspect
black doesn't gain anything from that
and he probably won't be played
um
I'm like kind of wondering about F4 but
it doesn't quite I would love to play F4
and King F5 all in one move yeah but it
doesn't quite work out here because Rook
E4 comes and the pawn will fall that's a
good point though I'm going to show it
that if you could play a four and you
know white does something random or if
you were one tempo ahead suddenly black
is really in business here that opponent
of four restricts the donkey on G2 black
is in a position to also start
mobilizing the majority over here on the
king side but as Bobby said or even if
imagine that in the current position
in the real game yeah in the in the live
position yeah if Black's form was on H6
I think black would benefit from playing
F4 then rookie for G5 it looks like you
traded some puns off on the king side
but you're really restricting that night
yeah killing that night off well and
you're forever kind of stopping the
knight from getting to C4 right and that
we've established already that if we
could do anything magical for yawn's
position here it would be to take this
take this Knight and drop it on C4 and
everything changes in fact I think the
position becomes a three result three
Result One in that case but um I
actually do Wonder a little bit about
the previous Move If instead of King F7
maybe there was some argument for
playing H6 here with that exact point
that now F4 is always on the agenda
because it can be supported with G5 if
rookie1 then we we play it for you and
uh suddenly rookie four doesn't have the
same bite to it
and here why it's night it's not like
like it's necessarily better here
but why it's night is is something to
think about yeah it still can reroute
itself 91 and I'm slowly King D2 nicely
too so maybe it's not a big deal but it
could have been an option
yeah okay well maybe Magnus down
thinking and then regretting that it is
move 39 oh he has uh he has just played
the move King F6
were laid instantly in in real time and
Jan has has the ability to play Knight
E3 I think he should play yeah I think
he will play Knight E3 in fact let's go
right I mean don't ask me twice let's
get out of here let's get out of this
this freaking quarter I've been here
been in here this is this is not good I
guess Magnus is saying that you get the
C4 Square I get the F4 square and that's
a fair trade for us
um I I wouldn't be unhappy with that for
white because the the Knight on C4 is
extremely annoying to deal with so
you're saying what's your line you're
saying Knight F4 Knight C4 Knight C4 and
specifically I work on Rooks on B7 and
C6 they have to make a decision how to
deal with the threat of Knight A5
certainly it's not Rook D7 because that
would have a similar issue with Knight
E5 yeah you know I want to make a point
that my partner Robin Hess would make
because I know this is the kind of thing
he would say in this moment that for for
all the the fans watching you see this
eval bar at 50 50. but don't let that
don't let that blind you to just how
potentially critical this position is
right the computers
are going to continue to play it
perfectly and so it would stay 50 50
most likely but this is the type of
position where don't be surprised one
slip one decision of where that Knight
or Rook should belong can very quickly
turn turn that email bar upside down and
suddenly suddenly someone is busted So
speaking of the things Robert hussman
say he is now back and I think you I
think you would say something like that
that I think sometimes people look at
this and go oh this is boring this is
draw a chest like this position is
actually very critical right now and
could slip quickly yeah I didn't want to
be spoken for so I decided thank you
thank you but I agree completely because
as Fabiano was just mentioning the night
coming to A5 is a fork yeah one idea
that black has in the long term is King
G7 King H6 King H5 and that won't work
with the Rooks on the board because if
you take on H4 you might just get
checkmate over there but if you can
Envision a scenario where the Rooks are
coming off or maybe only one Rook is
there then that H4 Pawn it's isolated
can be a Target so I do see this
position as well with plenty of life
left and that C4 score is great for the
night but then what it's yeah have the
structural problems exist and they're
favoring black and it's just a situation
where you're creating proven moves but
you still are left to deal with other
struggles
oh sorry no you go ahead I I just wanted
to touch an important point that Robert
made which is the trade of Brooks
because in any Rook end game you always
have to consider what happens when the
Rooks are traded off in this case if we
just magically took all the works off
the board why resigns instantly you know
what's funny
that was the exact point I was going to
make we're not spending enough time
together we're completing each other's
sandwiches
we had a magical moment okay sorry that
was exactly what I was going to say
because Robert's Point made me want to
give that educational point which you
always have to imagine at any position
what happens if all the pieces are
traded and don't make a mistake in
evaluating Things based on that coming
opportunity so go ahead so
um a few reasons if we let's say we
imagine this position with no Rooks on
the board blacks outside a pawn outside
past Apon which at the moment is a
weakness becomes a strength because
White's King has to cover that for the
rest of the game or captured which will
take a lot of time but also Black's H
Pawn not currently passed but that's
just as much a past pawn and it's one
which white can't cover because white
doesn't have two kings on both sides of
the board to cover them so black has two
uh past uh past pawns on the edge of the
board a knight cannot handle past pawns
it just can't it's it's the worst piece
for handling past pawns especially in
this instance where like also has a
knight and king to help out yeah so if
we're wondering why why it's not playing
Rook e to B1 to trade Rooks that's why
Trader Rooks uh especially a trade of
all Rooks but even a trade of one Rook
will be helpful for black
that's right which is why the United C4
is so critical because it covers B2 so
and it prevents black from immediately
doubling the Brooks but where are those
double Brooks going hopefully to B2 if
you can't get there then wear the
inroads
for the record everyone saw the clock
change that was correct move 40 has been
made by janapamnishi which is why he now
has an hour and 14 minutes Magnus will
be making his 40th move and we will see
an hour added back to his clock in just
a moment so
big big moment here not necessarily
thinking about all these future
possibilities that that Fabiano and
Robert are highlighting and
and yeah this is uh
gonna be tough will it be enough to win
we don't know but let's remind you that
if somebody should win every single day
if there's ever a decisive result chess
kid is free for all for everyone uh
adults and kids though adults shouldn't
really be on chess kid unless you have
your kids using the site you have
chess.com for that but chess kid will be
unlocked premium all day anytime there's
a decisive result
shout out to our Scholastic
extensionsite chesskit.com so all right
um we're gonna we're gonna stay here
until move 40 is reached for sure
because we don't want to we don't want
to leave we don't want to leave that
moment the moment Magnus makes his 40th
move
we'll uh we'll take a very quick break
but what what do you think his 40th move
is likely to be Fabi I feel like Knight
F4 is the most logical I don't
see any other really logical move first
of all you don't want to deal with the
possibility of Knight D5 check my model
can go to C4 but also 95 is a
possibility so I suspect Knight F4
Knight C4 to be played more or less
instantly by on and now we can answer
that question of was the work better on
B7 or on B8 so you're saying you were
right I was wrong just say it well I
think I mentioned Rook B7 so uh in this
case I I we might both we were both
wrong okay well it doesn't matter
because it's magnus's Rook he's the one
who's got to change it
um
the question yeah uh maybe he'll play
rookie seven maybe in that case it
justifies the remover of B7 rookie seven
and if white trades Rooks there's
another one coming to the e-file take
take let's say Rook to V1 Rook to E1
would actually be I think a terrible
mistake because of rookie C6 yeah
okay Rook to B1
and well white has the B file black
maybe has an e file so we get
um an interesting position but
Flex we're coming to E2 is a potentially
very troubling for white because that's
two yeah four is a Monster yeah it also
protects G6 you get the base Pawn for
the second one's protected D3 F2 F3
everything
yeah this is 904 I mean so we were
initially sort of skeptical if you will
maybe not critical of magnus's decision
to allow the Knight to C4 but as you
pointed out right away Bobby he was
saying I'm trading F4 which is what it
may have been a donkey but it had a duty
[Laughter]
I look at you and then you laugh
it's the world championship every time
you have to pull yourself together all
right the Knight left its
responsibilities behind I will choose a
different word for the services it was
providing
all right Let's uh but so the point is
if if Magnus puts the Knight on F4 which
oh wait we have a move he has not he
played Rook D7 okay what a quick
thoughts on that move I don't understand
wow after Knight C4 he wants to play
Rook D5 or that is such a bizarre move I
don't get it
what is the point it's it's so strange I
was about to ask did he you know he's
moved the piece of dgt picks up a square
too soon but no well those numbers are
even worse on that yeah yeah yeah no it
obviously we had the camera so we saw we
saw him do it in real time but that was
I mean the eval agrees with you guys
that that gave the advantage however
slightly back to White and I think just
the obvious follow of Knight C4
has a threat what is that what is he
doing Rook D7 for I all right well I
don't know but I do know that we need to
take a very quick break this is a great
a great opportunity for everyone to take
a breath we now have an hour added back
onto both players clocks we're going to
be right back don't go anywhere promise
it'll be short and unpack all the
Mysteries behind this mysterious Rook D7
it's round one of the 2021 fide World
Chess Championship and our coverage on
chess.com continues when we return I
[Music]
peace
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
right
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
it's day one for the 2021 feed a World
Chess Championship our coverage
continues here on chess.com brought to
you by coinbase we have made time
control now now boys right and we now
also see another move has been made on
the board it was Knight to C4 Bobby you
were thinking that maybe Rook A4 was was
slightly more accurate one of the funny
reasons is that you actually keep C4
open for The Rook but okay nice C4 is on
the board it's the most forcing one your
thoughts
actually I just understood why he didn't
play Knight F4 why he played Rook D7
okay
um and there's only one possible reason
which is that he was worried about Rook
to A4
huh it's the only reason why this could
have been but there's a tactic here he
missed it Rook to B2 nice oh
oh Sheboygan
I think that's the only reason why you
wouldn't play Knight F4
um
but this actually wins
missed that idea yeah because if not for
Rook B2 check Rook A4 just kicks the
night out and so yeah it's a bad move
but for sure yeah at Knight F4 Brook A4
this would be great for white if not for
This brilliant tactic and it was move
40.
oh my gosh but he did have plenty of
time what he had plenty of time he had
about five minutes I think when he made
when he actually made the move it's just
one of those moves where you're not even
thinking about Rook to B2 and in most of
the lines you're calculating there's a
knight on C4 so the Knight wasn't C4 in
that position but when you're going
through all these different variations
sometimes you just make a mistake you
just mix them up and so Rook A4 looks
like such an obvious move as a reply to
Knight F4 and then you look for loose
pieces for tactics and Rook B2 check
Force the king into a night Fork it's
it's just surprising just because of you
know how good and who we know Magnus is
but you made a great practical point
with it that it was the 40th move
sometimes like sometimes like you said
you you maybe you even saw many moves
ago that Knight F4 could always be met
by Rook A4 and so you've kind of already
committed that to memory that I need to
deal with that and you don't recognize
that there's a new a new tax of
opportunity that maybe wasn't there many
moves ago right that happens even to the
best players yeah because otherwise the
move Rook D7 just doesn't it doesn't
make sense you're right because it's
basically what he did now in Rook G7
Knight C4 rookie seven is a Tempo down
compared to Knight F4 Knight C4 rookie
seven like we were discussing but yeah
and the computer agrees I mean now if
anyone it feels like white we
highlighted the magical journey of the
night while you were gone that Robert
stream could could not really come true
at least not at least not with allowing
consequences like Knight F4 or something
like that but here it is on the board
that Knight is on C4 and and I think I
think we're back to a potential three
result position here well why can uh
force a draw at will at the moment 95
Rook to D6 Knight to C4 or The Rook
can't abandon the sixth rank because of
the A6 Pawn
so it has to go either to B6 or to D6
and it can always get chased back and
forth okay so uh I suspect yawn will not
go for that
um
although it's not 100 maybe he'll look
through the position look through the
options and find no
other
option which satisfies him
um but it's also a little bit
unsatisfying
when he's finally gotten like a pretty
decent position right uh to immediately
just end the game and
I don't know he's probably not the
well okay well he has I was going to say
he's not the type of player to uh to
force a draw in this type of position
but it is a world championship match
uh he might feel like it's the best
strategic option for him plus he always
he wants Robert to be right in his
master go ahead Robert that's exactly it
well he doesn't have access to an eval
bar right right he doesn't know that
he's like lately better and he's been
worse for a number of moves right so yes
he feels better about his position but
does he feel good he may still think hey
if anyone's going to lose this game like
if you go to an odds maker and say
someone's going to lose this game I
think white is more likely to lose than
black even if white is starting to
become very active just look at the pawn
structure right as the game continues
the F3 F2 double isolated pawns the H4
Pawn they're all weaknesses so I do
think as John he repeats here body
language he is going to make this draw
and I definitely think so and it's
another opening game where Magnus
started off quite well
and then he didn't make the most of his
Advantage this was never winning never
anywhere close to winning but Magnus at
his best at his very best nerve-free
confident he puts that endless pressure
on you it's unrelenting you are not
making a draw until everything is off
the board but here he made that Rook D7
move uh which you know Fabiano
explained just why he ended up going for
that he missed a tactic and that
sometimes happens but Magnus doesn't
look thrilled either I'm I'm shocked I
was just getting ready for a long
winter's night
like at the break pretty much convinced
we would be here for for some time to
come but there it is before it very nice
let's make sure we tell everybody right
now don't go anywhere because when the
game ends that's when our post show
Party begins no day will come to a close
without special guests on the other side
of every game today we have Maxine
bashayla grav we have Levy Rosman coming
up and we also will always do a full
recap of the entire game because we have
more than 60 000 to be with us on Twitch
and tens of thousands everywhere else as
well we want to make sure that even if
you just tuned in you get to see the
full action from start to finish and
Fabiano caruana's opinion and Robert has
his opinion maybe mine too uh for for
what happened throughout the entire game
but here we see them shaking hands and
um
guys real real quick comments before we
before we dive in and do exactly that
recap
yeah I feel like neither of them can be
really satisfied or dissatisfied with
with this result
uh Magnus probably feels a bit
frustrated that he didn't make the most
of what was certainly a bit of an
advantage for him
uh I think Jan once he was gained into
that dangerous territory actually played
uh incredibly well I I really like this
King E2 King D2 King C2 plan that he had
in mind
it turned a position which was difficult
for him to play into a position where
black had to make some tough choices
yeah
um okay so that was very impressive
yeah Magnus probably could have put more
pressure but he a draw with black you
can't he can't really be upset with that
okay your quick thoughts before we do
our recap I would say there must be some
frustration because Magnus Drew all 12
games against this guy over here in the
last World Championship he's drawing
again and we know how much he likes to
win that said he has seven whites and
six blacks remaining of the 13 game so
mathematically speaking but white tends
to win more in high level chess and so
that's a good result you neutralize any
advantage Beyond hope to have and he
gets to play with the white pieces
tomorrow foreign
yeah and I
my thoughts are are just what's got to
be going through magnus's head right now
I think he I think I even saw him
gesturing to Rook B2 I think he saw
right afterwards that that he had missed
it and that this changed from a game
that he was maybe gonna happily press
for two hours and torture his new
Challenger right welcome welcome to the
world championship young fellow right
but uh instead instead that that one
blunder lets it slip well all right
and on that note every game ends with
our post show beginning and right at the
top of the hour is our coinbase rapid
recap we are going to back this thing up
and talk about the draw that just
occurred between yonda Palm Nashi and
Magnus Carlson
we had E4 despite predictions but we
might see something different yon plays
Beyond plays something that he's played
most of his career
the Roy Lopez
and after castles Bishop E7 rookie one
B5 Bishop B3 and then H3 this was the
first moment Fabi where where Magnus
showed a little something yeah I really
like magnus's opening choice I was
thinking uh last night of all the
possible openings against E4
um this one is probably the safest Haven
for him right I really feel like he both
knows the martial well he was a marshall
player for many years yep and if you
prepare this opening well and I'm sure
he has then it can almost be an
impenetrable Fortress
um I I don't
um I don't feel like although Jan played
H3 and he knew something about the line
I don't feel like his preparation was
really at a level where he can
consistently post problems against the
marshals so okay they'll have to cook
something up during the match okay which
is usually what happens you've been
there you know what that's like to have
to cook something up during a match a
lot of the work is on the spot he has
teams of seconds and I'm sure they'll
come up with something but it's really
tough at the Marshall so he'll have uh
he'll have his work cut out for him
jumping to the next critical moment
Robert after after the trade of B3
Bishop B7 again this is all Theory and
we'll we'll continue to break it down
but it was it was this position after
Queen takes D5 and queen F3 that that
you gave pause and we're just pointing
out how forget what the engine's saying
is close to equal this is already we're
in very critical territory here right
and you can get tactical in just a few
Moves In fact after this bishop D6
Choice from Magnus and King F1 we're
analyzing this idea with Queen takes E5
which forces Queen takes B7 Queen's
hanging everywhere they'll stay on the
board Queen H2 and nobody likes to get
checked on each one with the queen but
the king Ventures towards the center the
queen on B7 full range back to G2 keeps
that covered this is exactly what Jana
palmchi would have wanted a tactical
Affair that he had prepared Magnus says
not for you and and on that note every
one of you missed it and I don't need to
keep saying that because we're doing the
coinbase recap which I'm implying that
many of you weren't here in the live in
the live moment Magnus played this move
work F to B8 which uh as as Fabi pointed
out technically already this position
with king of one is kind of Novel
territory but as Fabi revealed he had
some preparation you knew this position
from preparation apparently just like
some of your 2800 Brethren did but Rook
fb8 was clearly something that John
didn't didn't know was coming based on
what went down
the uh the move Queen takes D5 is now
kind of forced the main idea of this
move is that you guard the bishop
freeing up the queen for for all kinds
of tactics just show one that you did in
the game for example if Knight C3 now
Queen E5 is devastating because Queen
takes B7 is met by Queen takes E1 with a
inner meso check and then you win the
queen back
yeah so this was obviously prepared for
Magnus aside yep but uh Jan reacted very
well I think he played correct moves
Bishop D2 and I have three leaders are
these are excellent moves yep um had an
understanding of a position even if he
didn't know it uh let's say from a
previous analysis he still had an
understanding of what he had to do and
he probably got a got a slight Edge at
some point
but
it quickly evaporated
Knight to C3 was played after Rook Rook
to d8 Robert uh I saw you look at me
point to add on this no it just has this
game continued I think almost a monster
could be Retreat doesn't necessarily
lead to defeat because both players were
making these moves where the black's
Knight went back from B4 to E7 White's
Knight jumped around the board back to
E2 and G3 yeah so the players were
leaving as many possibly as open as
possible giving their opponent room to
go wrong and neither side really
straight too far from the object the
best moves what happened over the next
few minutes too we were covering in real
time was really a struggle around
something that I think conceptually is a
good educational takeaway for the
viewers white is up a pawn here but the
the main problem is those pawns are well
they're all they're they're all stuck
you can't move the C Pawn without the
d-pawn hanging and you can't move the
d-pawn if it if the tactics don't work
out when the position opens up so a lot
of what was happening here with white
playing these moves Knight E2 the move
that followed with Bishop E3 was Jan
trying to do what he could do to use his
extra Pawn Advantage but
it just it never never quite worked out
now 97 came which renewed the threat of
capturing here because that night is
sort of critical to making D4 good it
still never happened right Bishop F4 I
think that this was a a questionable
decision Bishop before I think that
Bishop F4 was probably not the right
wave I feel like maybe move like Knight
G3 if white wants to press for an
advantage this was this was the one
another move was necessary and Knight G3
was my feeling during the game but was
that this was an excellent move of
course White's Edge if he has any is is
extremely minuscule yep but in the game
he had no Edge at all and he was quickly
uh you know he wasn't playing at all for
an advantage so if you wanted to play
for an advantage I think this was the
moment
um Maybe not ig3 maybe another move but
certainly not Bishop F4 yeah okay and
Robert yeah you you you highlighted that
point in real time uh recapping it here
for everyone because you said hey a
bishop before happens look for this
massive exchange right most of the
compensation in this line is based on
the dynamic of the bishop here versus
the knights the pressure but no here
here take us through what black does to
to exchange and transform the position
where he can press a little differently
and it's just a wonderful sequence where
you first give up your light score
Bishop then trade the dark Square
Bishops and most importantly black gets
to defend A6 from an active Square
rather than a passive one Rook A8 would
have been behind the pawn nowhere else
to go The Rook on C6 controls the entire
sixth rank that would Rook can go to F6
or H6 to attack some of White's loose
Pawn so I really love this decision from
mag's point of view I agree with Fabiano
that Bishop F4 did not feel like the
right decision and after rookie one this
was the position uh on the board for
those for those wondering this is
exactly what happened it was Robert
predicted it in real time and then it
happened when C3 was played I kept
wondering whether G5 could come at some
point because you just start staring at
D3 it never did happen right Robert take
us through y on that
anytime you put that pawn on G5 you're
putting away from your other Pawn so
first off Knight H5 doesn't allow you to
take on D3 because the back rank
Checkmate and even disregarding that
Checkmate for a second if that Rook
could stop on E5 your knight is
undefended and behind that Knight is an
undefended Pawn on G5 and of course the
C5 Pawn requires some defense all across
the board their issues so black should
not push too far because then white can
counter yep my apologies I accidentally
jumped to the end of the game I will I
will back up for for just a moment so
then so then Bobby after C3 Knight H4
Rook E3 we had a phone on at this time
you were you were observing as we saw
you over there in the corners just
watching watching the game King f8
Knight G2 you were you were critical of
yawn's Defense initially especially
because this Knight was so passive on G2
but what was the next critical moment I
think that 91 was a slightly dubious
decision right here I feel like this is
the moment where the position went from
level to a tiny bit better for white or
black uh sorry a tiny bit better for
black and King E2 felt like the most
natural move I'm sure that Jan had his
reason probably involving F6 and the
hurricane kicked around for why he
didn't choose this move but
um in the game after 91 his Knight
found it very difficult to get to a good
Square it eventually went back to G2
which shows that this was probably not
the best place pieces were sort of going
back and forth right
um
yeah no it's a great point now the
Knight has to be on YouTube to guard F4
and
where so things were traveling a road to
this moment where we we saw that after
B4 was played it was something like in
the room the body language was clear
Magnus suddenly had a little bit of that
pressing Poise right and and B4
ultimately wasn't enough but this the
show that he was playing for a win and
willing to he certainly was because
these double pawns on B2 and B3 yeah
they can't be defended that C3 Pawn
cannot go backwards is there just to
stop the knife and go to the D4 in the
first place but as we get to this point
the rook's coming to B8 those pawns are
loose and I simply love what Jan did at
this point because it's easy to be
materialistic say I'm going to keep my
extra pawn and then that's going to help
me survive and maybe even go on from
there but no it would you get too much
trouble your pieces are passive so
giving up the pawn to activate your many
pieces great decision yep well B4 you
did highlight right away that the one
drawback of B4 is the C4 Square could
this donkey of a knight somehow get over
there well we're gonna we're gonna go
forward here and see that John did
eventually find exactly how to do that
but it took a little bit of help from
Magnus this forcing sequence was the
right defense from Yun actively giving
back the pawn in order to improve the
king but it was it was H4 and then
rookie one this critical position where
again in hindsight
maybe maybe the position that got sorry
after king of six and 93 maybe this is
the position that that allowed the
chance for a victory to slip away Bobby
yeah I really like Jan's play starting
from a moment where he played King E2 I
think that was an excellent move yep up
to well basically the end of the game uh
he he really
caught his flow here he was also playing
very quickly and playing good moves and
that that is vintage great yeah uh
vintage yawn he when he finds that form
he's able to play intuitively extremely
good moves and here all those pieces
found the right squares it was extremely
harmonious
um how the Knight came to C4 the Rooks
came to places where they could
challenge the B file the pawn in H4
limiting Black's Knight a bit everything
was perfectly placed and here's where
Magnus made
what I feel is maybe not objectively a
serious mistake but certainly
practically a serious mistake and I'm
going to let Robert take us through that
that what that critical moment was that
the move that should have been played
for black to keep the pressing chances
was Knight F4 he did not play it Robert
because because Rook A4 seems to kick
that Knight right off the F4 square but
in reality you look for loose squares
and loose pieces in fact the D3 Pawn is
only defended by the king so Rook B2
check forces that King to capture it and
then Knight takes D3 with check wins
that Rook back with interest in Pawn F3
is probably going to fall and White's
king size and shamble so that would have
been a great opportunity ahead of course
Jan blundered into it which he would not
have but I think that's why he didn't
play Knight F4 so it was an oversight by
Magnus instead Magnus played Rook D7 but
after Knight C4 that was going to be a
four straw yawn did not miss his chance
to get out of a slightly worse end game
and that was how the coinbase recap
coinbase rapid recap if you will came to
a close for game one of the feed a World
Chess Championship here uh in 2021 well
first of all as I said many times
throughout the show we're going to have
a lot of action the moment the game is
over we are going to listen in to every
post-game conference we will have live
feeds we will have amazing guests first
up Maxine Bashe lagrav the Frenchman
with three names Levy Rosman is joining
the show to talk about his new
documentary debuting we will be joined
every day by you and Ludwig Hammer from
Norway he will be bringing us the
reaction of the country that the change
forever in regards to its love for chess
when Magnus Carlson came along a couple
decades ago so our post shows are going
to be full of fun full of more
educational and interesting moments and
uh the post show actually starts it
starts right now so we're going to take
a very quick break when we come back we
might already be listening in to the
post conference in addition to getting
set for all the guests that I just set
don't go anywhere it's chess.com's
coverage of the feed a World Chess
Championship brought to you by coinbase
more of it when we return
[Music]
today more than ever when the world
comes together to create a better
tomorrow it's going to be magic oh
[Music]
with architecture with colors magic with
celebration with your safety From Here
There and Everywhere for six homos day
and
day and starting October 1st
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
thank you
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
for the words I just said but now it's
not okay anymore so please sit or stand
on the sides if you're going to take any
photographs and otherwise please stay
seated throughout so that the cameras in
the back can film the entire press
conference
and finally for those of you who wish to
ask questions
there are microphones who are left and
right you may use those stand there do
not touch the microphones and please do
not take off your mask you should be
wearing masks at all times do not take
off your mask when you are asking the
players questions I will begin the post
game interview with a couple of
questions and then it will be open to
the media on the floor first of all to
you Jan
when were you the most optimistic during
this game
well actually I I was very slightly
optimistic you know during the whole
game let's say because
I mean this is quite a curious line from
black yeah let's
very very fine compensation uh despite
basically it's a pawn down in the end
game it's very hard to prove something
with white so I knew that but I felt
like okay maybe I can slowly build up
something in the center but uh yeah I
guess logically you know this bishop F4
idea is logical just to trade away a
pair of Bishops but it doesn't work due
to some
uh also as well positional and tactical
reasons uh so basically after I let this
exchanges happen
it was never
never something uh I could really help
for yeah more than a draw and then okay
after uh basically after before well
probably I have to bring my king to C2
and accept uh you know sacrifice the
pawn back and okay just accept the draw
Magnus the same question for you when
were you the most optimistic during this
game
say I was ever particularly optimistic
uh incense
um you know in the sense of winning
winning the game
uh I was a little bit worried
um
kind of equine young scent of being a
little bit optimistic
um but uh
yeah was was happy uh to find this idea
with uh with B4 but I I knew that if he
um remained prudent there and just
brought this King over I I thought
chances of winning the game were not not
realistic
John it's your first game in a world
championship match you're feeling now
that it's over
well uh I can't say much so I was white
and normally we might you want to you
want to try to win but yeah draw is also
result but yeah just
a I guess a fine game for Magnus so I
don't feel something specific
Magnus you add the black pieces in this
game uh salary result after the first
game
yeah the result was was solid
um I do feel that I was a little bit
bit shaky at times certainly things that
I I could have done better but overall I
think the result was fair enough
we opened the floor to the media the
Press you may go to the
to the microphones on the side and begin
your questions
yes myclined with chess.com my questions
from Magnus Carlson most of your games
played against the on in the past have
been in opens or at least in
invitationals this is your first time of
course playing them in a match do you
expect that his style will change given
that this is a match format
yeah I think Jan was already quite a lot
more more solid in in the candidates
um and uh this I guess was a
continuation of of that but yeah overall
is just a very good player
uh this is going to be a short press
conference if you guys don't have any
questions so please
um you said before the the press
conference before the first game that
you thought you were going to be fired
up Magnus when you were sitting at the
table for the first game and did that
happen today
um if I wouldn't say necessarily fire it
up but um
um very concentrated and eager to go for
sure
mask on sorry Saran from chess base uh
Magnus question to Magnus uh today it
looked as if you got your kind of a
position a favorite kind of position for
you uh an end game and the maneuvering
and
I mean I didn't particularly mind the
the position that I got uh I mean the
opening that I I played is not one you
can you can afford to to play if you're
not fine being down upon with the with
the bishop pair
um
but after that it does in general feel
like
um
why does a little bit
more more potential to um uh to maneuver
and black usually has to has to react a
bit more uh but I was pretty happy with
the plan that I I found eventually
giving up the bishop pair to some extent
looks very counter-intuitive but I
thought that I would still have have
reasonable compensation with um
[Music]
with his weakened Pawn structure and
relatively passive pieces and at least
in the game I was at least half
Vindicated
from Danish chess magazine I have a
question for both players can you reveal
a little bit about who are you uh
trainers or seconds
yeah
well I guess uh I was asked the same as
a starting press conference so I can
repeat that okay the part of the team
Remains the Same from the candidates and
the part of the team has changed
Magnus yeah it's funny you should
mention that you're from the Danish uh
chess magazine because I can reveal a
big secret that my chief trainer is
actually Danish
may I have a supplementary
question
yeah
the opening Choice suggests that perhaps
also a German is involved on the team
um you may speculate as much as as you
want I think that's half the fun of
being a journalist at the world
championship match yes thank you
Norway uh question for John uh how does
it now your first game in uh World
Championship is over uh how do you feel
do you feel relieved how was it
well uh I feel like you feel after Joey
white pieces
so I mean that's a quite usual result
nowadays but still uh obviously you want
more
Alexander is significant channel uh
Russia one and I'll speak Russian for
Russian audience
my question is for Jan
um
foreign
that is
um
thank you
um mycline chess.com again this question
is for Grandmaster Jan napomnishi we
didn't get to ask this at the opening
press conference but uh you're looking a
lot more fit I'm curious what you did
physically training for this match and
was there a Target weight you were
trying to get down to or anything like
that
well I as you correctly mentioned I was
trying to be more fit
well and uh I mean some may think that
uh I was successful at least at these
parts
so but I mean in general it's a quite an
obvious part of preparation for some
major event yeah you gotta be you know
you gotta feel well during uh the whole
the whole thing yeah and to let some up
and downs happen and I guess that's the
point but you know it's only game one so
uh hopefully uh everything goes okay
stock from a German newspaper decide a
question for Ian where you're surprised
to see the night move to A5 in the
opening by Magnus
uh well uh uh yeah this is by all means
not the main move in the position yes so
normally black chooses other moves but
uh this move uh was one monk I have
started before the match and uh this was
not a big surprise I would say and the
move uh rooked from F to B8 was also in
your preparation uh somehow yes
thank you
um yes from Ouija Norway again a
question for Jan
um how does it feel not to play for the
Russian flag is it that uh do you think
that's that's a problem
um well I mean obviously that's uh not a
good thing uh to play without your you
know usual flag and your usual Anthem
but you know during a chess game you
think about moves
and thus again uh how long time did you
spend for the preparation for the match
itself
this is directed to who both players
um yeah it's uh
it's obviously hard to to measure
um but um because there's the time that
I spent and also the time that was spent
by by the team
um so yeah I
I don't I don't particularly know
um but
I would say that it's a very similar
amount to
what what's been done for for previous
matches
yeah
well uh since I didn't prepare for
previous matches yeah
I can only say that it was a lot
uh question for Yan uh today's game you
started playing the match the first move
this was probably a moment you waited
since your childhood you imagine you
aspired how did it feel when you
actually sat down to play at the first
move could you keep your emotions and
the nose under under check how was it
well uh I think uh a statement that okay
I was waiting for this uh since
childhood is
you know sort of exaggeration because I
think I waited for this until the
candidates was over
uh yep so I I always prefer to do it
like step by step but indeed uh you know
you are normally very nervous until the
thing starts and uh yep I mean once I
think the first move has been played
there is no more space you know no more
place and no not a good moment to be
nervous you've got to start playing and
uh well that's particularly what I do
from childhood here playing chess
any more questions
I've got a question here from the free
day's Twitter followers
sent in by Matt beef and it's for both
players
how much do you dread post game
conferences
do you just want it to be over or do you
use it as a time of rest
Magnus
um I think it very much depends on on
the situation
um
I mean at the moment with uh
with uh you know the only the first game
played and not much has happened
um it's it's okay and I guess a way to
relieve the stress a bit after after the
first game
yeah
well I guess it's a part of the job of
the professional Sportsman so I I think
I come here and uh I try to speak
if there are no more questions that
concludes our press conference for today
game two will be tomorrow at 16 30 at
the Dubai Exhibition Center thank you
very much have a great night
[Applause]
we are back here
game one in the books for the feed a
World Chess Championship day one uh it
was a draw for those of you who might
just be tuning in uh a lot of reactions
there a lot of things to unpack from the
post game press conference but before we
do any of that we need to welcome a
guest here who's right over my left
shoulder Maxine Bashe the Krav uh number
now number two in France number one in
your hearts we'll unpack that a little
bit later uh Maxime thanks for being
here man
and therapy to tell you good morning
good morning it is good morning for us
um Bobby you're um yeah
your your super GM Brethren here he got
up bright and early and he and he was
looking good
yeah I still thought uh I did see uh
some of the commentary provided and the
yeah February was looking very fresh and
very instructive and my uh
my my man Robert test was apparently con
being confused with me well
um
Bobby I don't know if you want to say
anything to Maxine before we jump in
here otherwise I want to get his
thoughts on on maybe the critical
moments of the game yeah let's jump into
the game okay well Maxine um
on that note you obviously followed the
game live you watched some of our
commentary you probably watched some
with Kevin in in French I'll forgive you
for that
um for sure but but tell us what was
what jumped out to you here opening
middle game the the pace of the game
your thoughts
[Music]
clears that
Jan was prepared in the first game I
wouldn't make too much out of it though
because it might also be that you know
he didn't know what uh Magnus would
answer one info now he got his answer
it's easier to prepare something
specific when you don't have special
nickels Knight off and you know other
stuff uh getting out of the way
while uh for Magnus it's pretty clear
that Marshall would be his main weapon
if not his only weapon because uh
against Fabi especially performs
basically is on the weapon
so it's not all bad for for young in
terms of opening then I was slightly
surprised by his Pace yeah so
um
when it came to the early uh end game
um and at some point I don't know I
think I liked this idea maybe to to
bring this King to D1
uh earlier which in which position
after I think after work d8 when you
have a choice between Bishop A5 Knight
C3 which he played
and kinky2 and then to the one I thought
this might
when that was a possibility yeah
yeah I am going all the way back I yeah
yeah okay right here
yeah
you can see the screen right yeah I
don't know
yeah I can see the screen I don't know
what to make of this idea to bring the
king to the one oh interesting
at the same thing
yeah thingy two is is really interesting
um
um yeah why just once after then I don't
I don't know sorry go ahead Maxim
yeah
no it's a nice thought she got into some
sort of trouble by playing a bit too
fast paced but uh that's also how young
likes to play and
well
the world championship match so uh yeah
there were three things I'm expecting
better fights later three things that
came up in in the in the game in real
time with with Fabi
um that I wanted to unpack with you
first position I wanna I wanna go to was
Bobby commented that this line here
um
well while kind of rare to like top
players so you you more more aware of it
as well but that Rook FBA rather than
the idea of Queen E5 and queen H2 was
what Fabiano suspected maybe Jan wasn't
prepared for your thoughts on that
no like I said I think
uh well actually Jan said that the press
conference that he some odds would be
eight in his uh fast which I wouldn't be
too surprised because I think this was
also in a correspondence game but press
conferences are made for lying right I
mean let's be honest right you're
probably gonna say that yeah anyway yeah
but like like I said rugby eight has
been oh so he said it's been played
before okay bye now yeah I I expect that
Rook fb8
or I suspected that Rook fb8 was played
in correspondence and Maxime confirmed
but
it is a sideline and it's not clear how
much effort he put into the Marshall in
the first place right
for sure and like I said uh you know in
the first game you you're getting that
question answered like uh I don't know
about you Fabi when you played your
first game when you played G4 I mean
swishnikov was an option for madness it
was it was a very easy main one a second
not even secondary tertiary
um option that
the thing is last time
the Marshall was the main thing we
expected
from Magnus and he and he went with the
Sicilian like he played uh okay
he was mainly a marshall player then
and he completely threw a soft guard
with the swashikov so maybe
um
because Maxim also has to prepare
you know like seven eight very large
very difficult to prepare openings so
you can't
it's difficult to prepare everything
fully right makes sense so well then the
next critical moment Maxine that we
talked about was
well there were a lot of little
mysterious night Maneuvers happening
happening here but it was in this
position that Jan chose Bishop for this
was a big strange for yeah instead of
maybe the move Knight G3 which is what
Bobby thought was a better chance dude
you know obviously we know what happened
on Bishop F4 but what were your thoughts
on where this game could have gone if
yon wanted to push for more
this point uh Jan didn't really think
too much about it and thought Bishop F4
was kind of trying to press on and you
know exchange pieces and you you're safe
partner but as a game continuation shot
that's not exactly the case
so I think it was just more of uh
inaccurate judgment uh you know which
can happen in these positions by all
means from Amazon
um you know in a will to simplify the
games to to draw because that I mean
that wouldn't be successful
and actually kind of dangerous in a
sense but yeah there were definitely
curious options there were other options
for both players in many many lines I
mean it's a place by all means not first
and on concrete and that's
where Magnus trains uh also resides so
you know I think
uh all in all uh young is probably water
up in not to have you know got into more
more trouble after this inauguration
well obviously we know we know where
this went here um Jan
committed his pieces sort of passively
if Bobby was critical of 91 but but
other than that yeah he he did he did
because he recognized to
just need to go for a forces I think it
was not most accurate from Magnuson yeah
okay so it was G6 King E2 was was
Bobby's idea with the point of coming to
E3 seemed like the most accurate defense
um
uh yeah it should be of course like 91
is and not the sort of moves you you
actually want to consider but uh
you know in a sense you know you're
still upon it you're still um you know
very solid and made something bad up and
you know you still have you
uh your weapons to to at least all you
have to join that's precisely what
happens in my opinion well we'll skip to
that as you already know the last
critical moment perhaps was this uh
this our speculation that Magnus on move
40 last move simply simply missed maybe
the tactic preventing Rook A4 with the
idea of Rook B2 check because it didn't
make a lot of sense to us that he would
play Rook to D7 instead of 90.
yeah that's you know the most logical
explanation actually I wanted to ask you
a question Maxim after Rook D7 yeah I
was
briefly thinking about this position
and I'm wondering if white can actually
play for a small Advantage with Rook A4
now
because the A6 Pawn is a very serious
weakness long term
um that actually makes sense
um
C4 just wins some may spot so
okay
yeah yeah
so maybe this would actually be very
dangerous
yep
at least it could be
um
maybe then you will need to stay passive
with okay seven or Knight C7 maybe yeah
this looks this looks tough It's
yeah no actually 97 yeah 97 or 86. well
then let's wait let's transition to that
big more macro question with our with
our guest here I am going to put you on
the spot and ask you who you think is
going to win this match and what the
maybe what critical things will happen
but
is is in hindsight
this kind of uh revealing some of yawn's
nerves and psychology that he really was
just happy to get out of game one
without a loss because
it does seem safe for white to be able
to play for a little bit of something
here Maxime what are your thoughts on
that
um I don't know I think he maybe you
know young
as I mean
uh I saw a bit of pain sometimes a bit
wastily and maybe not
with without uh a deep enough think
about the position like you know Magnus
does Fabi does and such a Grisham we're
not the classic Grisha time which I'm
pretty sure Maxine would be the first
one to make it and not Robert Hess go
ahead
yeah but anyway
um it doesn't uh you know take anything
away from from him from his Trends from
you know his improvements in general uh
is
um Facebook has improved quite a lot
because even now later than two years
ago he lost against me yeah but I think
and one of them was the blender so
so
um so this doesn't happen to him
generally but still he likes that fast
pace and sometimes uh with that five
space I know it firsthand you can miss
some setup is in the position and she
probably didn't think too much about it
and just play Knight C4 and and make a
draw but um yeah okay for looks like
more serious well speaking speaking of
fast pace
chess there's a match coming up on
Monday
are you are you aware of that match
Maxime
not at all uh with some with my opponent
yeah you're you're playing too Danny
yeah some some random guy named named
Fabiano caruana so um well yeah yeah so
I I got Alpha fit right yeah I mean the
man was uh
on the video it was not not you but the
man is standing next to you there is the
the match indeed on Monday father you
want to say anything to Maxine maybe we
can get Maxine back on the on the camera
here if possible
yeah I'm ready for the match I'm looking
forward to it yeah
I at least you won't have to wake up at
2AM yeah not at 3am but um
it's difficult to adjust when you're
waking up at 3am to suddenly wake up at
a normal time
so so maybe I'll stick with it
yep well he won't be up at 3am
um but he will be ready for the match
we're gonna make sure he has a place to
play so don't worry about that
um you won't you won't uh we'll make
sure he wakes up but best of luck to you
in that match Maxime and like I said I'm
gonna gonna ask you so who do you think
is going to take home this world
championship match
of course it's hard to say
um
Magnus is a favorites but uh I have a
feeling that
Jan is gonna post serious problems
um well certainly not today in terms of
openings but uh
with this team and uh you know the
resources that have been put on uh I do
expect a great fight and I wouldn't be
surprised at all if
ended up winning it
um we also have to wait for tomorrow CEO
is black prep also because uh yeah last
time Fabi also had a tough time was
writing the first game but then never
had
any serious issues like in the next six
games uh since you played with black so
if uh Young's Square who's black all the
conversantly I think uh you know this
will help him relax and help him uh you
know getting the fights and of course uh
you know I don't expect magnets to to
back down and you know too interesting
so yeah I I'm hoping we we're in for a
great fights and the great three weeks
all right
well thank you thank you for those
thoughts we know we're going to have a
great fight on Monday in your speed
chess championship match versus Fabiano
but Maxine we will uh probably probably
see you again hopefully have you on as a
guest again but on that note we will let
you go and uh
introduce introduce for the fans that uh
Mike Klein caught up with yonda palm
Desi privately so we have a clip coming
up on that but appreciate you Maxime and
um we'll let you get back to your
afternoon there in France
yeah thank you Denise thank you Fabi and
see you soon bye buddy
right all right and that was Maxime
Bashi the group interesting comments he
made there about
he gave a very detailed answer about him
feeling it will be critical that Jan's
preparation holds up as black right and
that sounds like Captain Obvious right
obviously your preparation needs to hold
us back but it was interesting because I
think the psychology of that he's saying
will help will help yon relax it'll help
him then be himself in the ways that you
know the things we know he's you know
one of the best in the world at right I
mean he's aggressive attacking style
playing fast so if he holds with black
tomorrow he you know Maxine's saying he
thinks that's a big moment well from a
top player's point of view like Maximus
I'm sure following it closely uh the
opening is one of those interesting
stages because we get a glimpse into the
player's preparation and we can sort of
try to deduce what they're thinking why
they chose those openings uh magnus's
choice of opening
now that we know it I assume like Maxine
said that he'll stick with it is a very
logical one and now we'll see what what
uh Jan chooses and also we'll see
magnus's approach will he uh stick to
one first move or will he try to jump
around and try and probe and see if
maybe there's a [ __ ] in armor of
Maxim's preparation which is what he
tried last time to try to poke and proud
yeah
um
so I I suspect that he might adopt
something similar to the last time where
he relies on a solid open or last time
maybe wasn't the most solid but an
opening that he trusts with black and
and tries to
um
mix it up with white a bit playing
different first moves trying some
different openings
um
that's probably a good strategy because
you know let's say you are facing an
opponent who's prepared very deeply in
one opening
you might not be able to find any
inroads there but it's difficult to
cover everything so if you try different
things you might find a weakness yeah
interesting okay well obviously we know
we will uh we'll find out tomorrow it's
so much more in store uh right now
speaking of what's next for you the fans
we have a one-on-one with Mike Klein and
yonda pawn machine that happened right
after the game even before the the
official post press conference which you
just saw so let's see um what Mike and
John got up to and and get uh the Palm
Desi's initial thoughts right after the
game concluded
chess.com is here with Grandmaster John
napomnishi who just finished his first
ever world championship game with a draw
you said you were not going to be
nervous but when you sat down today tell
us was that actually the case well
actually once I started I never was
nervous I mean until I saw probably the
before move at uh at the board so I
don't know if maybe it's not me playing
for a win despite they have an extra
Pawn so I have to
regroup quickly but otherwise I guess
was a fine game from Magnus and well at
least you know even like this like this
Pawn sacrifice is very interesting but
well I knew it it's not quite much for
white but okay
and uh lastly at what point did you
decide to sort of shut it down as they
say where you decided it was probably
best to just try to go for the draw and
not play for the win anymore
well of this time we simulated this
position after Bishop of four so could
be
uh should seek some different
uh move order like because okay this
bishop F4 is very natural and like I
traded away uh his pair of his Bishop
pears so normally Pawn should uh should
be quite an advantage here but uh not
really as it seems like because okay
this Knight on F5 is like fully
compensated at some point you know once
night is only six it's clearly white is
not going anything in this before idea I
mean okay it's very smart but uh
fortunately I have this King goes to C2
at the end then okay after H4 basically
I think that's why I had an extra Pony
so to give it away and
maintain their quality thanks for your
time
interesting stuff there right
interesting comments there
from uh from Young I guess his nerves
he's uh he said he got a little nervous
when he saw B4 right that that's the
only real takeaway I had from that he
got a little nervous when he saw before
but otherwise he he was kind of felt
like it was okay and and he thought
Bishop F4 should be a draw yeah I think
we could see from his body language that
he was nervous after before yeah as far
as not being nervous before the game I
don't but you're calling BS on that yeah
I think I think I think as I say he's
capping on that one yeah Kevin yeah yeah
as my 16 year old would say that's cap
that's cap bro total cap bro all right
you know what's not cap is that we're
about to bring you the answer to the
earlier asked trivia question remember
we have an official trivia question at
the start of every show and we are
giving away a one year not one month one
year Diamond membership uh to a lucky
member of the community on social media
you tweet your answers with the official
FWC trivia hashtag the we that we
created just for that along with the
official Carson Carlson Depot or other
event hashtags so when we come back we
will have the answer to that trivia
question for chat and continue to break
down things on our feed a World Chess
Championship post show here on chess.com
brought to you by coinbase
foreign
[Music]
from Expo 2020 in Dubai matches are the
order of the day for World Championship
crowns however two world champions won
their titles in tournaments who are they
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
hi Jonathan corblock back with the
answer to our trivia question which two
world champions won their title not in a
match but in a tournament well one
macail bought vinnick and the other the
great Vichy Anand who hails from India
and we are here in front of the India
Pavilion at Expo 2020.
[Music]
foreign
there you have it the answer to today's
trivia question the two world champions
who won their title previously in a
tournament before also winning it in a
match where Mikhail bought benick and
vishwanathan although my partner here
has a has a hot take right there's
there's a slightly different
interpretation to that right maybe maybe
uh you disagree there should be a third
well we were discussing this a bit
earlier Danny yeah so the the two and
the two which come to mind first are
about vinnick and Avro uh 38 oh okay and
um and Anand in 2007 in Mexico he won
the double round robin yeah the the same
um type of tournament was
um it's Apollo 1 in 2005.
um in um in San Luis Argentina
um and he became the Fida world champion
so there's a differentiation
between fide world champion and the
world the chess champion or yeah class
yeah
just world champion yeah there's some
sort of uh differentiation between that
and there's also a lot of knock uh
players who won the b-day World
Championship in
v-day World Championship in knockout
um it's a long list yeah kazim John of
conamero halifman Vichy as well Visions
um and and then to Paul won the
tournament yeah and then there was a
reunification in 2006. so it's a
slightly more complicated answer but
indeed two of officially recognize now
world champion list yeah no it's
interesting and obviously we won't even
unpack the 90s when you had the PCA and
the feed a and Kasparov and karpuff and
all that stuff right there was a brief
period for those fans who followed in
the mid 90s where it was debatable who
the world champion was because of that
but hey that's politics that's not what
we're here for what we are here for
though is to debut the first part in our
15 15 part series chess a reflection of
us Jonathan corbla who is bringing you
both the daily trivia question as well
as the answer from Dubai narrates a
story about how chess where chess came
from how it how it traveled across the
globe and and grew and evolved
throughout the ages I won't I won't
preview it anymore because we'll let
we'll let the video do the talking but
every day there will be a premiere of
Chess a reflection of us right here on
chess.com's coverage of the world
championship and episode one is right
now
chess
a game for kings and commoners
revolutionaries generals and their
soldiers scientists artists Merchants
philosophers even computers and
artificial intelligence a symbol of
intellect
chess is a Timeless example of strategic
superiority
those who play well are revered because
chess Excellence cannot be purchased it
can only be earned
chess represents complete individual
power of Mind a venue for both
creativity and Technical mastery chess
captures the Zeitgeist of an era and
captivates our minds because chess is
much more than just a game
it is a reflection of life itself
chess is a reflection of us
[Music]
chess
a game for kings and commoners
revolutionaries generals and their
soldiers scientists artists Merchants
philosophers even computers and
artificial intelligence a symbol of
intellect chess is a Timeless example of
strategic superiority
those who play well are revered because
chess Excellence cannot be purchased it
can only be earned
chess represents complete individual
power of Mind a venue for both
creativity and Technical mastery chess
captures the Zeitgeist of an era and
captivates our minds because chess is
much more than just a game
it is a reflection of life itself
chess is a reflection of us
[Music]
dating back to 6th Century India
chaturanga is the earliest known form of
Chess and bore's similarities to today's
game variations of the game spread to
the sassanid Empire or Modern Day Iran
where they were taught to nobility
after hundreds of years these early
versions slowly converged into the
modern game we enjoyed today
chess traveled East to China where it
evolved into a game called xianchi
the game also traveled West as Islam
swept through Arabia North Africa and
the Iberian Peninsula by the Middle Ages
chess was being played throughout Europe
the game reached Mongolia through Silk
Road routes and Genghis Khan's spread
chest throughout the empire in the 1200s
as the European Renaissance ushered in
an era of rebirth chess became popular
with the artists scientists and
religious leaders who dominated
Renaissance culture
in fact it was a Catholic priest rui
Lopez de Segura who in 1561 published
one of the earliest and most influential
books on the game which documented the
priest's opening theories including his
namesake the rui Lopez which is still a
common opening nearly 500 years later
in the 18th century ushered in an era of
revolutions most notably on the American
continent in France and even in global
industry
Napoleon Bonaparte was known to play
chess with his generals
Benjamin Franklin a founding father of
the United States was an avid chess
player who penned the essay
the morals of Chess in 1786 were hero
life is a kind of Chess in which we have
often points the game and competitors or
adversaries to contend with
as the beginnings of globalization
shrank the world
chess evolved into a standardized game
for over a century one could not claim
dominance in the Chess World Without
first stepping in to the venerable Cafe
de la origins in Paris it was here where
musical composer and Infamous blindfold
simultaneous player Andre Theodore
played against Benjamin Franklin the
most notable of the players who
frequented the cafe was the American
Paul morphy a child prodigy who stormed
the chessboard after earning a law
degree at the age of 20 but not being
old enough to practice law in New
Orleans
Paul traveled to New York City where he
won the first American chess Congress
and was recognized as the United States
chess champion the following year morphy
traveled to the United Kingdom and
France where he easily beat Europe's
best players including German Master
Adolf Anderson who attested that morphy
was the strongest player to ever play
the game widely regarded as the world's
best chess player Paul morphe stunned
the Chess World when he abruptly and
permanently left the game to begin his
life as a lawyer
morphy's death in 1884 left a hole in
the chest world that begged the question
who was the best player in the world
two years later the world would finally
know
stay tuned for our next segment to learn
more about the first official World
Championship in 1886 and who would win
that coveted title
foreign
I don't know about everyone else
watching that I definitely learned a
thing or two some things I didn't know
about the history of our great game the
game of kings and I can't wait for
episode two uh speaking of learning
things
a reminder that we announced a contest
at the top of the show that we will be
holding a special one hour group session
with the man Fabiano caruana on December
13th as we debut our new feature
currently in beta coming called
classroom where coaches and students can
connect a real-time video analysis tools
being shared save their lessons to
library all kinds of amazing things
coming with our new classroom feature
and Fabiano caruana will be giving the
first live classroom in a show format
all you have to do is solve at least one
at least one video in his new video
series on chess.com and tweet or
Instagram share proof of it sorry I
sounded like a I sounded like an old dad
on social media Instagram share uh no so
tweet or insta is that what the kids say
insta and why would I know what the kids
you you you you got it and stuff you
have kids I don't have kids okay
um tweet or insta a proof that you
solved at least one with the hashtag
learned with Bobby and you will be
automatically entered away again 10
people are gonna have a chance to ask
their questions to you are you scared
about that that make you nervous a
little bit Yeah make you nervous I think
I'll be ready for it okay all right all
right well we are going to take a very
quick break when we come back our next
guest John Ludwig Hammer joins us to
give us the reaction from Norway and uh
get his thoughts on on how he thinks the
world champion is feeling he was
obviously magnus's second when he first
won the World Championship from
vishwanathon and on all the way back in
Chennai India in 2013. so we can't wait
to catch up with hammer and still much
more ahead Levy Rosman is around the
corner don't go anywhere chess.com's
post show coverage of the 2021 fide
World Chess Championship continues in
just a moment
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
's coverage of the 2021 v-day World
Championship is brought to you by
coinbase whether you're an experienced
Trader or just looking to make your
first crypto purchase coinbase has you
covered visit coinbase.com chess to get
five dollars in a free Bitcoin just for
verifying your account today
foreign
[Music]
this is this so here's what we're saying
[Music]
this game of the 2021 video World
Championship
Emerald lighting and audio
we're going to crush through the top of
the show
[Music]
all right
[Music]
want to play chess online or learn how
to improve join us at the number one
chess destination in the world chess.com
with thousands of people playing at any
moment you'll quickly find a game with
someone at your level whether you're a
beginner or a Grandmaster test.com makes
learning fun and easy sharpen your
tactics with puzzles and enhance your
strategy with our lessons by top Masters
learn from your own games with our easy
to use analysis tool chess.com has
everything you need to take your game to
the next level signing up is free and
easy join chess.com today
[Music]
the 2021 feed a World Chess Championship
kicked off today
the first game was a draw for fans in
Norway they've been watching their man
Magnus Carlson for for years this is now
his fifth World Chess Championship match
and perhaps none of his friends who are
now
famous commenters in Norway would know
would know what to talk about as far as
how Norway is feeling better than young
Ludwig Hammer Hammer thanks for being
here uh you look you look great today
can I say that
thank you thank you for inviting me and
may I say your setup is awesome
how does Robert look you really found a
way to
ah thank you the the couches look great
I I wish I was with you guys I'm a couch
now well you could you could fly out
here if if TV2 will let you let you go
um I'd poach a hammer
um anyway man hey so give give us your
breakdown right Magnus has been here
before
um he's played Black in his last three
World Championship matches another draw
um you know just take it away you
covered the game your thoughts on on how
you think magnus's team is feeling and
and what you think they take out of this
first game
well I I think Magnus showed that
there's been so much talk about this
Russian super computers and you know how
napomnia she got kayaking and he's
getting old of Russians and it's
basically an entire country working
against our little Magnus but our Magnus
is a big boy and he showed that today he
came in with a sacrifice right out of
the opening and he wasn't playing around
he's done some real opening work and I
think if anyone was pushing in this game
it was Magnus with the black pieces I I
think it was a tremendous success yeah I
mean on that note you said he was
pushing and that's been the case for the
third consecutive World Chess
Championship first game he had the black
piece in all three he was better he's
won zero of those games do you think
that's gonna frustrate him at all or is
he going to be okay simply because
drawing with black is a great result
I I think he's gonna be okay this time I
I think uh last time in 2018 he was
legitimately just winning against
Fabiano Carana and that I think was
frustrating this game was more like yes
maybe I had some Advantage but
nepomyachi defended very well so I don't
think there will be any frustration out
of it I think it's just gonna be you
know I I showed I showed him that that
I'm gonna be able to create some winning
chances even with the black pieces
you're just never gonna get to relax
over the course of these next couple of
days how are the fans taking this mat
what's the temperature in Norway we know
that Magnus Carlson is seen globally as
as the favorite you mentioned some
things that have been discussed right
about being all of Russia versus the
little Magnus but how did the fans do
this do they would they be shocked if he
lost are they just kind of expecting
that Magnus Carlson wins World
Championships or what's the general
storyline going on there from Norway
Norway expects Victory nothing less but
to be fair we're not putting that
pressure on Magnus alone right I mean no
one has more expectations of Magnus than
Magnus himself
uh but yes we too uh just like Magnus
expects himself to win every time uh the
Norwegian people expects Magnus to win
and
um I I would say he's on course so far I
I think it was a a good game today and
and he uh he showed up and and he showed
that he he's able to to put pressure
even with the black pieces which is uh
uh an achievement at this level
certainly is and you know how Danny has
those Fat Heads including several of
Magnus do people in Norway wear mags's
name on their back is their merchandise
that people are out and about sporting
because he's a household name of course
people stop what they're doing to watch
Magnus play what's that scene like
I think there's a Market opening here I
I've not seen any Magnus jerseys and I
feel like that is the fault of uh
producer people who uh produce Goods
more than
um the a problem of uh of the Norwegian
people if there were more Magnus jerseys
available it would sell I guarantee it
well I think uh you left us thinking
that magnus's uh Magnus is a happy
magnet today that's that's what you're
that's what you're telling us right that
even though it was a draw and uh despite
the yet another draw with another
advantages black that this one feels
like probably a good start you were with
them in 2013 and Chennai what's he doing
right now after his game what does he do
well I think in Chennai it's it's a
um I I think he has gotten some
experience about how difficult it is to
play your first world championship match
and that's why he has a focus on trying
to put pressure immediately if you
remember the first move in a World Chess
Championship Magnus ever played it
wasn't tonight it was with the black
pieces against vishy Anand and Magnus he
was so nervous he was shaking his hand
as he was moving the pieces and he
actually flipped the pawn as he was
trying to execute his Karo Khan defense
like even Magnus who at that time was
world number one even he was so nervous
he he he
um he flipped the pieces over by by
accident executing his move and I think
we've seen him against karyakin against
Karana and now against nepalnyachi he's
actively trying to use that first game
to use that
the pressure of the new situation and
and use his opponents and experience to
to just a exploit that moment because he
knows how
um difficult that can be mentally uh he
didn't win today but let's be honest if
Magnus doesn't lose a game with the
black pieces
he's probably going to win the match and
and here he played with the black pieces
and he was never in trouble
well said yeah um I think he fumbled the
pawn because the caracon is all pawns no
hope but on a serious note you know
we're asking about the reaction to
Magnus what do the people in Norway
think about Yan because Magnus himself
said that Jan's not the number one most
feared Challenger from his perspective
do people see it the same way but you
said they kind of assumed Magnus will
win despite John's plus record against
Magnus right I was gonna say does that
play a part that Magnus is a losing
record against Jana palmchi heading into
this match
well I think part of the thing is that
we don't really know Jan the the
Norwegian chess audience are not very
familiar with him because he had this
late surge in his career and and Chaz
has been on TV in Norway a regularly
since since the late 2013 but it's only
in like the last five four years that
napomnia cheese had that big Surge and
and as you were saying in the classical
games yes nepomichi has the lead but
they have played a shocking amount of
games in that they almost haven't played
at all uh we have seen so many epic
battles with Magnus and Hikaru Magnus
and Anon Magnus and avronian these are
the players uh Magnus and Fabiano I'm so
sorry
I I forgot that for a second
um but
um but you know these are the players
the Norwegian chess audience are the
most familiar with nepomyachi can kind
of he he can make his own Legend
here uh very similarly to how carjakin
through amazing defensive work in the
match in in 2016 he got the nickname in
Norway Minister of Defense yeah
uh and so uh naponyachi's effort in
these first couple of games will be what
defines him in the eyes of the Norwegian
all right well as if he didn't need more
pressure now he now he needs to live up
to the Norwegian audience and and how
they Define him but no uh hammer I'll
just say this was this was awesome I
knew you would bring bring the heat and
bring bring all the interesting takes
and you you did not uh disappoint thank
you so much for for tuning in again for
those of you who didn't hear at the top
of the show Young Ludwig will be joining
us every day uh after his amazing
coverage that he's doing uh for for the
Norwegian fans so uh have a great have a
great evening there we'll let you get to
it hammer and we'll see you tomorrow
bye guys
all right well with hammer dropping I
will cue up that our next guest will be
International Master Levy Rosman Gotham
Jess will be joining us to talk about
his life and times the documentary that
we'll be debuting his thoughts
potentially on on uh on what happened
here in game one and we continue to wrap
things up here but still lots of
interesting stuff ahead I actually can't
wait to hear what Levy thinks about what
happened in game one I'm sure he's
preparing a video for all of his fans as
we speak so don't go anywhere
chest.com's coverage which is brought to
you by coinbase of the 2021 fide World
Championship continues when we come back
foreign
I you know how I feel about this man
we've talked about it I I don't
I know the game needs sponsors
I know what a wallet is I know what a
wallet is okay and it's where you keep
real things not no not made up things so
yeah I I know what crypto is
dude I'm not that out of it everybody
follows Elon Musk on Twitter
all right well here's the deal I'll look
into it this week I'll see if I can
figure this out and get behind it but
otherwise it's a no-go so all right now
all right see ya
I hung up on Austin and I knew right
away that this was going to be a
frustrating week
but I figured I'd give the kid a chance
so I did what any sensible manager does
in the 21st century
I let the internet tell me what to do
apparently there was already Bitcoin
near me and all I had to do was extract
it somehow
chain of blocks was also somehow related
what exactly is a blockchain I wondered
but I did learn that a chain of blocks
can apparently come from anywhere
and since nobody actually owns the
blockchain I figured nothing was
stopping me from building my own
I assembled a team of the most creative
minds I knew to help push this project
forward
[Music]
we worked for a long time
and we did our best okay girls what do
you think but we realized this wasn't
quite hitting the mark
if I was to find Bitcoin I would need to
step it up a notch
[Music]
well I wasn't sure anything could
actually be mined at my own home I was
determined to find out so I got to work
but it didn't take long for me to
realize I was mining in the wrong place
whatever information out there is
telling people they can earn free crypto
from their own house is obviously
clickbait
so I set out to where I knew at least at
some point in time Pioneers had once
mined for minerals
if metals had once been there maybe some
Bitcoin would turn up
I tried my best
but I knew I was off track
I suddenly realized I had no idea what I
was looking for
could I even spot Bitcoin if it was
right in front of me
I returned to the office empty-handed as
usual
I was feeling silly I was feeling
frustrated and I screamed in Anger uh
what is crypto
someone heard my call cryptocurrency
well crypto is a collection of binary
data which is designed to work as a
medium of exchange wearing individual
coin ownership records are stored in a
ledger which is a computerized database
using strong cryptography to secure
transaction records to control the
creation of additional coins and to
verify the transfer of coin ownership
shall I continue
does that mean
I didn't find anything sorry about that
Siri didn't help and I was still
searching for answers
so I did what I've seen a lot of other
smart people do
I grew a mustache
but even embracing the likeness of a man
who normally had all the answers LED
tasso
I was still being yielded none
the universe had turned its back on me
and I was prepared to turn my back on it
I was lost and I knew it
crypto was everywhere and nowhere at the
same time
was this crypto
where was I going to go from here
my life had fallen out of balance and I
was slipping into chaos
[Music]
was I just being selfish
sure I didn't believe in crypto but
maybe crypto didn't believe in me either
and if all my years in chess had taught
me anything it's that you don't always
have to understand a position to play
The Right Move
just because I didn't understand
something didn't mean others couldn't
and coinbase was after all being more
than generous
this is a partner who genuinely loves
chess and appreciates our community
I called Austin and I gave him the good
news
I promise I will no longer interfere
I said young man if a place does exist
that can tell people how to manage
crypto and learn about the industry
that you need to tell them where to find
them
the people deserve to know son
for of greatness is truly in store for
them as long as they're willing to
believe in something that they will
never feel taste smell or touch then who
am I to tell them that's crazy
so while I maintain that the only thing
I'll ever mint is my breath
I'm a big enough man to get out of the
way and let all of you mint well
whatever you want
it's time for everyone to start their
crypto Journey even though I clearly
still have a long way to go before I can
begin mine
sure I didn't find the Bitcoin I was
looking for this week but that doesn't
mean the chess Community can't get
theirs with coinbase and after all I
still have a lot of work to do
[Music]
yep yep hey man where are you um like
five minutes waiting for you yep
unloading up Zoom
cool thanks
[Music]
chess.com's coverage of the 2021 v-day
World Championship is brought to you by
coinbase whether you're an experienced
Trader or just looking to make your
first crypto purchase coinbase has you
covered visit coinbase.com chess to get
five dollars in free Bitcoin just for
verifying your account today
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
lighting and audio
we're gonna Crush through the top of the
show
[Music]
all right
[Music]
thank you
we are back now joined by our next guest
our last guest of the day always brought
To Us by our partners at grip six you go
to grip6.com chess for 25 off right now
during the World Championship I'm
actually wearing their belt right now I
know I'm not supposed to flash
but just to show that I actually do wear
their belt I really I really enjoy it so
go to grip6.com
I wasn't gonna what did you think I was
gonna Flash
I'm just not getting involved you're not
getting anything like I was not present
friend okay uh we are we are now here
with the one and only the amazing a man
who really doesn't need an introduction
but that's what we got to do anyway
International Master Levy Rosman also
known as Gotham chess the biggest
YouTuber in the Chess World uh his video
recapping what happened in game one was
out first uh and I expect it probably
will be every day that's what Levy does
and I'm sure it's awesome uh Levy thank
you so much for being here and uh we're
not going to get into the the board but
give us your quick takeaways from game
one and what people can find in your
video
uh well people can find I guess my
my breakdown of the game obviously I
actually kind of regretted saying uh not
saying one important sentence I wanted
in that recap like this is one of the
best times to be a chess fan because so
many amazing chess players are analyzing
this game uh and if you want to go into
any sort of deep variations and
hypotheticals like go watch as many
Recaps as you can I mean if you uh are a
fan of
me okay you can watch me first you can
go to Croatia and watch a godmother then
you can watch all sorts of you know uh
super GMS like Fabiano caruana on this
broadcast and by the way as an aside
guys uh unbelievable production thank
you uh I've been like loving the the
stream it's like uh it's like ESPN style
um you know so it I've honestly had a
great time watching so really appreciate
it yeah
um well
yeah it's like honestly I would just I
would I would keep complimenting you but
you started the segment with a threat of
flashing the audience so I you know I
feel like with with the exception of
that this was like almost a perfect show
um I hope you guys are you know hope
everyone's getting good cash to wake up
at 2 A.M to watch these games you guys
are crazy hit yeah you know it's gonna
be a long month you're right we are
waking up super early but I really
appreciate all the compliments and uh
you you deserve just as many for all the
work you're doing and on that note
that's kind of what we're here to talk
about right we're here to talk a little
bit about
the documentary that was done that is
World premiering on YouTube we will be
now that you can rate on YouTube we will
be rating our own video in World
premiering Levy's documentary right
after this but
there's so many ways we could go with
this I don't even know what to ask so
I'm just going to start at the top and
say
what was it like for you to be have a
documentary done by you I've never had
that experience right how crazy was that
and what were what were some just high
level takeaways of an experience of
someone doing a documentary on your rise
to become really the chess teacher for
the internet
they they got to do one on you too you
know and like uh you know even more they
gotta do like a 30 for 30. on uh on on
Danny wrench and building shells.com
because I mean it's uh so what I've
always said is throughout this growth
like uh at that at the core I'm still
the basically the exact same person uh I
was
um before all of this happened so I'm
not in any way sitting there like like
yes like I deserve all of this this is
like perfect like go get me my shoes and
everything you know it it was it was a
lot of fun honestly I had a lot of fun
uh seeing my family talking again about
you know the disaster of a child that I
was in childhood uh and and the whole
the whole chess story
um and uh you know it was it was a lot
of fun and I've seen the final version
and it's it's super great
um it it it really highlights like the
the the the fun family that I have and
um the kind of sad part is that the
pandemic happened like we used to hang
out with my grand my grandparents house
and
um joke around and have a good time like
a whole lot more so I think people will
enjoy it I I don't know if they're going
to get anything out of it that's like
shocking that uh that they didn't know
about me uh growing up or anything but
um I think they're gonna have a a fun
look into
my family
um you know Lucy who
who I'm marrying in like 11 days by the
way um congratulations on the engagement
by the way thank you
thank you Danny
um and uh I mean yeah I I think I think
they're gonna have a an awesome time
watching it and
I was going to say something else when
you asked me this question but I
completely forgot so please ask
something else because I I completely
lost Patrol let me also congratulate you
uh your wedding upcoming that's huge
congrats Levy and I actually noticed
that I could see your reflection in your
gold YouTube
um you know plaque back there yeah yeah
and it it's it's a bit of a fundamental
flaw of the setup but um yeah sorry I
was gonna say those plaques don't happen
by accident you put in so much work and
what kind of sacrifice have you made
throughout the last year because being
able to be the first person to post on
YouTube every time a chess game ends
that doesn't come without a lot of hard
work and giving up other opportunities
so what has that been like for you
uh I think from okay so there yeah
there's definitely a handful of
sacrifices uh the first of which is
definitely physical uh most of the last
year I
my schedule I think I talk about this in
the show I don't remember if it's in
there but I think it is like I was
waking up at seven eight in the morning
I would stream from anywhere from nine
in the morning until two to three p.m
then I would usually make a video that I
wanted to launch that evening and then
at 11 PM I would record a video that I
wanted to go live the next morning so
that was my day for a while uh
and I was like trying to hit 120 hours a
month of streaming and that was most of
2021 so yeah there's a lot of physical
stuff like your sleep quality is crap uh
I gained like all the pounds that I lost
uh the the prior years
um there's also the sacrifices like
you're completely immersed so it's just
basically I talked to Lucy like two or
three of my close friends uh my family
although even then I forget to sometimes
answer their text so I'm like very hard
to reach the past like year year and a
half all randomly just completely forget
I didn't respond to someone you know you
get a message you're like I'm gonna
respond to that and you forget and then
it's been four months and you're like
what how did that even
um and I think there's also a bit of a
sacrifice of um
it of of like the perfectionism that
that really the highest level of Chess
demands like today's game for example
there's many variations in my recap that
I didn't even that I didn't even go into
the hypotheticals which I have seen
covered live on other channels and chess
is such a deep and fascinating game and
I'm not a GM and let alone a super GM
right so the quality of some of the
content
it Stomps at a certain level where like
an 1800 and 1900 to 2000 level player if
they really want to immerse themselves
into learning and enjoying chess on
YouTube they will not watch me because
the truth is I I have to cut certain
Corners because I can't go in in as much
depth as the game demands and so on that
end I sacrificed the Perfection side of
things and also a bit of dignity because
you know I'm I'm like uh kind of a
sarcastic like Bright New York type like
I I talk some trash obviously but
anybody who knows me like knows I'm like
a like a pretty like normal chill guy
um very relaxed and um but on camera
like you have to Hype certain things up
you have to be more sarcastic you have
to say say certain things do certain
things so I'm sure there's people in the
Chatsworth who like this guy is such a
piece of crap I don't know how this
growth happened so
yeah there's a lot of sacrifices and I'm
like very aware of them but I wouldn't
trade it for the world so well I mean
it's being super self-aware and and
honest about that I mean I we can all
relate I can I can definitely relate
sometimes
really hard work and preparation as
shown by what you don't go into right
and and it's good to you know you know
as a chess player how hard it is to
really understand a game at a high level
even though you may not be displaying
that in in every video right so it's
it's an interesting interesting um point
you made there well last question I have
was what does this whole experience been
like for Lucy
I know you can't speak for her but how
you know the whole she's been with you
through the pandemic through
what you said yourself right coming from
someone who basically quit quit
streaming wasn't sure you really wanted
to continue being a content creator
online all together before ramping up
into where you are now so take me
through that if you would just quickly
yeah uh I I can give you like the just
as real as the other answer was
um
I I I've known like Lucy in the in the
modern era because we actually we we met
each other
six years ago for the first time so in
the modern area it's been three uh and I
was uh I was like a like a totally
different person and I had to
what I the way I would describe it is I
always had like my current personality
and you know uh morals and maturity and
although sometimes there are many big
flashes of immaturity but I promised
that scripted
um I I I I always had that in me but I I
like I said I mean I was just sort of
I was uh Rough Around the Edges uh
definitely insensitive uh could totally
be you know I didn't really have any
sort of focus which is why I would
sometimes stream 80 hours in a month and
sometimes 10 and my career and goals
were sort of all over the place at the
beginning of 2020 uh and that had to
change and a lot of things in my
personal life had to change
and Lucy stuck with me like every step
of the way uh and if that hadn't
happened I would not be who I am today
and I would not have this channel I
would these channels I suppose
um and none of this reached I mean this
documentary wouldn't exist uh the
potential impact that I could leave on
the Chess World through either videos or
charity or whatever it might be wouldn't
exist so uh she is everything to me and
none of this would be possible without
her so
well very very well said and uh I
appreciate you sharing it and we're
nothing but I I'm just super happy for
you and all your success I cannot wait
to watch the documentary I admit I have
not seen it yet
um I can I cannot wait I I and really I
I browse through it giving some creative
feedback to the team just based on what
I saw but I have not watched it start to
finish yet
um so I'm going to be doing that along
with all the other fans so um can I can
I can I can I drop just a fun nugget of
info for anybody who watched this
conversation live so the very first time
I watched it
um in the first minute when I walked
into my grandparents house
my grandparents made a very Politically
Incorrect joke
but it was in Russian
and I freaked out and I because I mean
okay very Politically Incorrect is a bit
of an overstatement but enough in our
current ERA that if someone translated
it from Russian we could get in a little
bit of trouble and uh I was like God
Gramps why did you do that man and it
was in there because Chandler doesn't
speak Russian and I like the first
minute
and then I had to like go and text them
and so uh it's not in there anymore it
wasn't it wasn't anything too bad but it
was bad enough that in 2021 someone
would get angry on Twitter about it so
no more that that's good to know very
good to know right no one wants anything
or cancel culture around here so all
right man well yeah we're gonna let you
go and um like I said can't wait to see
the documentary and I will be checking
out your video review of today's game as
well later tonight and uh thanks again
to you for your time and congrats on all
your success
thanks guys awesome show keep killing it
hopefully we get 100K concurrent viewers
and um yeah I actually won't be
satisfied if we don't hit it I think the
first world championship in the chess
boom your production was crazy today and
just keep it up here man
yeah
and that was
the one and only lovey Rosman remind you
that our last guest of the day is always
brought to you by grip six once again
you can go to grip6.com chess get
yourself a belt I won't flash you mine
again but it's 25 off and uh they are
they are huge chess fans and consider
consider giving them your support socks
or their socks are also very very comfy
uh all right on that on that note we are
going to bring you bring you our our
last kind of reviews of the of the chess
of the day our last our last thing we
get into here is the the coinbase
critical moment and really it speaks for
itself because it was this it was this
last moment nope not that moment right
there because that's the beginning it
was this last moment when Magnus played
Rook to D7 rather than the move Knight
F4 to me Knight F4 again
we could we could we could still be
covering this game live right Robert I
mean this game could still be live if
Knight F4 had been played again we
believe and speculate that he missed in
his last move Before Time control that
Rook A4 would be met by Rook B2 check
followed by a crushing Fork on D3
and if Rook A4 can't be played then
Knight F4 is a monstrous move
this is a very tough position so
he didn't play that he played Rook D7
and that ultimately led us to why we are
wrapping up the show here which was a
quick repetition of moves so
that critical moment and that position
is set up on our house of stunt board we
thank those sponsors as well are our our
partners at House of Staunton they make
all kinds of of amazing wooden chess
sets more than 600 models if you didn't
know that I I learned that in their
sponsorship we really appreciate it
right now we have that final position
set up and we will always have our
coinbase critical moment moment set up
on our house of Staunton board and we do
appreciate them for their sponsorship uh
let's let's talk about tomorrow's guess
you excited you're so excited you forgot
I'm so excited I forgot first I'm a
human being this is live television
um I believe tomorrow's guests we don't
have them on the teleport are Lavon
aronian I believe it's levonne aronian
another good friend of Bobby's yep love
town just getting Super Jam after super
duper good friend of Fabi yeah and I
mean it's gonna be awesome to hear his
thoughts we had him on in the 2018 World
Championship he was very insightful yep
and I think as a top player they watch
these games and they really enjoy it no
they want to be there but they're
happily not stressing out as well it's
well that's probably how I sold Bobby to
come was I was like hey man like we all
know we you wanted to be there but since
you're not I know you're just going to
be watching these games anyway you're
gonna be watching the show you want to
just come be on the show and then and
then you can follow the games in real
time and I think that was partly why
Fabi said yes um our second guests are
we we pretty much will have a a great
chess guest and then but another another
guest if you will after hammer every
time and tomorrow's is the one and only
Logic the rapper Bobby
um is a good good buddy of mine we can't
wait to have him on the show so we'll
see we'll see how closely Bobby's going
he's very busy I believe he's recording
his next album just published a book so
we'll get into it with logic talk about
Chess he played in POG Champs 3 and he
is uh he's a huge fan of Chess and I
know he's only taking it more and more
seriously I can't reveal more of that
but he's still like he takes lessons
ever if not every day but every week
um and I believe at some point he even
plans to play in tournaments so I'm
really excited to catch up with logic uh
the the rapper and uh and see what his
thoughts are so
um
I actually don't know if we're if we're
taking a break or if we're rolling
yeah okay we're rating we're raiding
Gotham chess on Twitch and uh and we're
gonna YouTube World premiere
the documentary Levy Rosman how Gotham
Chef became the chess teacher to the
internet and uh and that's what we're
gonna do right now so on that note on
behalf of Fabiano who's not with us
anymore
that wording was five minutes right over
there
he's not he's not here in studio anymore
but he's with us he survived day one
with you one working with me barely
um but uh on behalf of Fabiano caruana
my amazing partner Robert Hess the man
who brings you chest you can't you can't
have it without him I am Danny wrench
and I am honored to have been here again
day one is in the books I can't wait to
see what we have in store for the next
few weeks so please continue to tune in
to chess.com's coverage of the 2021 feed
a World Chess Championship it's brought
to you by coinbase and we will see you
bright and early tomorrow whether it's a
good day for you a good night this is
goodbye goodbye today
[Music]
magic magic magic
with music with architecture with colors
magic with celebration with your safety
From Here There and Everywhere for six
Hollows day and night join the making of
a new world starting October 1st
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
chess.com's coverage of the 2021 v-day
World Championship is brought to you by
coinbase whether you're an experienced
Trader or
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you